GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE GOING TO
CALL THE THAT'S GOOD MORNING.
WE ARE GOING TO CALL IT FEELS
LIKE AFTERNOON.
WE ARE CALLING THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING HERE
ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHAVEZ HERE OBERNOLTE.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. ROTH
SKINNER.
THANK YOU SO TODAY WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THE.
FOR MAJOR PIECES AND.
OF THE OF THE BUDGET CONFERENCE.
WILL BE TACKLING THEM AT A VERY
HIGH OVERVIEW AND.
REVIEWING MAJOR ISSUES IN EACH
OF THE VARIOUS SUBCOMMITTEES ARE
WE'RE GOING TO START FIRST WITH
EDUCATION THEN GO TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. THEN RESOURCES
AND THEN LAST WILL BE AYE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC
SAFETY.
SO WITH THAT WE'LL START WITH
EDUCATION WE HAVE.
MUST COME FROM HELLO TO GIVE US
AN OVERVIEW ON EDUCATION.
ASSN JENNIFER CAN LEAD TO
ANALYSTS AM IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FIVE OF YOUR EDUCATION AGENDA.
THE FIRST TWO BULLETS HIGHLIGHT
THE MAJOR ASSUMPTIONS UNDERLYING
BOTH HOUSES OVERALL EDUCATION
PACKAGE SO YOU HEARD IN THE
OVERVIEW A HEARING YESTERDAY
BOTH HOUSES HAVE TAKEN HIGHER
GENERAL FUND REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS.
BOTH HOUSES HAVE HIGHER PROPERTY
TAX ASSUMPTIONS AND THE HIGHER
PROPERTY TAX ASSUMPTION IS
REDUCING REQUIRED GENERAL FUND
PART NINETY EIGHT SPENDING
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR.
SO THE LAST TWO BULLETS SHOW YOU
THE OF FACTS OF THOSE REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS TO CONCEDE I EVEN
THOUGH BOTH HOUSES HAVE HIGHER
REVENUE. ITEM THEY HAVE THE SAME
OVERALL PROP NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING AS THE GOVERNOR FOR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THE ASSEMBLY HAS JUST
SLIGHTLY LOWER SPENDING THAN
EITHER THE GOVERNOR AND THE SUN
AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN NOT SET A
DUE TO A SLIGHT DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR UNDERLYING REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS.
PAGE SIX SHOWS YOU GENERAL FUND
SPENDING BY SEGMENT SO YOU CAN
SEE PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND SPENDING.
IS LOWER ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS LOWER IN BOTH
HOUSES THEN THE GOVERNOR AGAIN
THAT'S JUST DUE TO HIGHER
ASSUMED LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES.
IF YOU STAND ON THE LIST OF
SEGMENTS UNDER THE NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND PROGRAMS YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE SENATE AS MANY MORE THAN THE
GOVERNOR FOR EACH OF THE SIX
SEGMENTS. YES SOMEBODY A
SPENDING MORE ON FIVE OF THEM IN
THE SAME ON ONE.
IN TOTAL FOR NON PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND SPENDING YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE SENATE SPENDING
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR. THE ASSEMBLY
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
MORE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SEVEN YOU
CAN SEE PROP NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING BY FISCAL YEAR SO YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
IT ASSEMBLY ARE AT THE SAME
PLACE AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. YOU CAN SEE
THIS ON BILLION GONNA SLIGHTLY
LOWER AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
ALTHOUGH THAN SPENDING LEVELS
ARE VIRTUALLY THE SAME ACROSS
THE PERIOD IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE CHART YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE SUN IS SPENDING MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR FOR ONGOING
PURPOSES LASTS FOR ONE TIME. AND
THE ASSEMBLY AS SPENDING EVEN
MORE FOR ON GOING AND LESS FOR
ONE TIME.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE EIGHT.
AND YOU CAN THE GOVERNOR IN
SEVENTEEN AM SORRY IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FUNDS IS DEDICATING
ALMOST A BILLION OF THOSE FUNDS
FOR ONE TIME SPENDING. AND BY
COMPARISON THE SENATE HAS A
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION IN ONE
TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY AND ONE TIME. SO THE
LAST ONE TIME SPENDING YOU HAVE
IN YOUR NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE THE
MORE VULNERABLE YOUR ON GOING
PROGRAMS AND OUR NINETY EIGHT
WILL BE IN NINETEEN TWENTY.
THE ASSEMBLY ALSO SUPPORT SOME
ON GOING EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDS
AND PROGRAMS I'M SORRY WITH ONE
TIME FUNDS SPECIFICALLY THEY'RE
TAKING FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION AN ONGOING SPECIAL
AND COST AND FUNNY NOT WITH ONE
TIME MONEY.
SO THE ASSEMBLY PLANT AGAIN IS
BANKING ON NINETEEN TWENTY
MINIMUM GUARANTEE BEING AT LEAST
THAT MUCH HIGHER SO THAT IT CAN
SUPPORT EXISTING SPECIAL ED
PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR IN BOTH HOUSES
COMMIT TO PROVIDE MEAN AN
AUTOMATIC COLA FOR LC A FIVE
WHICH IS AGAIN THE LARGEST PROP
NINETY EIGHT PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP
AS TO WHAT'S ON THE HORIZON
PROVIDING ELSE IF OFF WITH A
COLON NINETEEN TWENTY AT THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATED RATE OF TWO POINT SIX
PERCENT. WOULD COST ONE AND A
HALF BILLION.
SO AGAIN AFFECTIVELY ALL THE
PLANS ARE COMMITTEE IN THAT
GROWTH IN THE GUARANTEE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY HAS AT LEAST ONE
AND A HALF BILLION TO COVER THAT
COMMITMENT. SO IF YOU TAKE ALL
THREE OF THESE CONSIDERATIONS
LAST ONE TIME SPENDING FUNDING
SOME ONGOING PROGRAM WITH ONE
TIME MONIES COMMITTING SO WHAT
COLIN NEXT YEAR.
IT'S JUST CREATING SOME COST
PRESSURE FOR YOU TO I'M
RECOGNIZED IN NINETEEN TWENTY.
WHEN WE WERE ON WHAT A MODERATE
RECESSIONARY SCENARIO LOOKS LIKE
IN NINETEEN TWENTY WE HAVE THE
GUARANTEE FOLLOWING ROUGHLY FIVE
BILLION WHICH IS ABOUT FIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN FIVE
PERCENT.
SO UNDER THAT SCENARIO AGAIN YOU
WANTED TO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
BACK FILL FOR SPECIAL ED
PROGRAMS YOU WANT AND HAVE
ENOUGH FOR THE COLA YOU'D HAVE
TO TURN TO THE BASE.
AND CONSIDER WHAT TO DO INSIDE
THE BASE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE NINE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND BOTH HOUSES OUR SPENDING
ROUGHLY SIX POINT TWO BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR KEY TWELFTH.
OVER THE OVER THE BUDGET WINDOW.
THE GOVERNOR IS DEDICATING SIXTY
ONE PERCENT OF THAT ONGOING
PURPOSES THE SENATE'S AT SEVENTY
FOUR PERCENT ON THE ASSEMBLY
THAT EIGHTY THREE PERCENT.
SO THE NEXT FEW PAGES PAGES TEN
THROUGH TWELVE JUST PROVIDE
DETAIL ON THE DIFFERENCES IN
THAT PART MAY BE A KEY TWELVE PM.
ACTIONS OF BETWEEN THE HOUSES.
AND MOST OF THOSE ARE ITEMIZED
LEADER IN YOUR AGENDA SOME JUST
GOING TO SKIP OVER THOSE AND
TURN TO PAGE THIRTEEN.
PAGE THIRTEEN GIVES YOU I'M
SHOWS YOU THAT THE GOVERNOR IN
BOTH HOUSES ARE SPENDING ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN NEW SPENDING. AND
BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND SENATE OF
THAT NEW SPENDING ABOUT FIFTY
I'M SORRY FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
ITS DEDICATED FOR ONGOING
PROGRAM SYSTEM LEASE JUST
SLIGHTLY HIGHER WHEN IT COMES TO
THE COLLEGES. AS SIXTY TWO
PERCENT.
THE LARGEST ONGOING INCREASES
ARE FOR APPORTIONMENT SON THE
LARGEST ONE TIME AS FOR THE
COLLEGES AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE MOST OF THOSE ARE
ITEMIZED LATER IN YOUR AGENDA.
SOME ALSO GONNA SKIP PAGES
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THERE JUST FOR
YOUR ON AND SIXTEEN THERE FOR
JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE YOU CAN
SEE THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
HOUSES.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SEVENTEEN
AND THIS FOCUSES ON CHILDCARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED WITH A
COMBINATION OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND NON PROPPING IT
GENERAL FUND INTO FEDERAL GRANTS
SO WHEN YOU COMBINE INCREASE
SPENDING ACROSS ALL OF THOSE
FUNDS SOURCES. THE GOVERNOR IS
INCREASING SPENDING FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE MILLION. YOU CAN
SEE THE SENATE IS UP AT NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE MILLION
AND THE ASSEMBLY AS AT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION.
MOST OF THE ON GOING SPENDING AS
FOR ADDITIONAL SLOTS AND RATE
INCREASES AND A LARGE SHARE OF
THE ONE TIME SPENDING AS TO HOLD
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS FIND A
OBTAIN AND RENOVATES FACILITIES.
THE NEXT TWO PAGES ARE AGAIN
JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE
EXPLAINING THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES MORE
SPECIFICALLY THOSE ARE ALSO
ITEMIZE LATER IN THE AGENDA.
SO IF YOU TURN TO HIGHER
EDUCATION PAGE TWENTY YOU SEE AN
OVERVIEW OF SPENDING FIRST YES
YOU.
AS WITH CHILDCARE BOTH HOUSES
SPEND NOTABLY MORE ON THE
UNIVERSITY IS
THE GOVERNOR INCREASES GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT BY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. THE SENATE
IS UP AT FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION AND THE ASSEMBLY
JUST SLIGHTLY LOWER THAN THE
SENATE AT FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE MILLION.
BOTH OF THE HOUSES DEDICATE.
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION FOR ONGOING PURPOSES SO
THAT ONGOING INCREASES PRIMARILY
FOR EXISTING STAFF THEIR
SALARIES AND BENEFITS AND HIRING
ADDITIONAL STAFF.
THE ONETIME MONEY UNDER BOTH
PLANS AS PRIMARILY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
NEXT PAGES ARE THERE FOR YOUR
REFERENCE AND THEN FINALLY ON
YOU SEE. PAGE AT TWENTY THREE
YOU CAN SEE THE OVERVIEW FOR ED.
GOVERNOR'S INCREASING GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT AT YOU SEE BY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE MILLION AGAIN
BOTH HOUSES ARE HIGHER SIMILAR
TO SEE US YOU'LL. SENATE'S OUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
MILLION AND ASSEMBLY AS A
SLIGHTLY LOWER AT FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE MILLION.
BOTH HOUSES ARE DEDICATING A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HALF OF
THAT TOTAL INCREASE IN SPENDING
TIME ONGOING PROGRAMS AND WITH
YOUSEE THE ONGOING PROGRAMS
THAT PRIMARILY BEFORE EXISTING
STAFF SALARIES AND BENEFITS AS
WELL AS HIRING ADDITIONAL STAFF.
BOTH HOUSES HAVE ABOUT TWO%
HUNDRED MILLION AND ONE TIMES
SPENDING FOR YOU SEE. I'M FOR
THE SENATE ON THE SENATE SIDE
THEY DEDICATE MOST OF THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION. AND
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIGNED AND OTHER
KEY MOST OF IT TO UC'S OUR
RETIREMENT PROGRAM AND THEY TIE
CONDITION TO IT THAT YOU SEE
MAKE CERTAIN CHANGES TO ITS
PENSION PLANS.
SO THAT'S AN OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE BEFORE YOU DIVE INTO
ISSUE ONE.
GREAT THANK YOU.
BULLETIN THIS CONSTANT FORMER
FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURES
ANY COST WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WANTED TO START OF.
BY JUST PROVIDING SOME HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGES JUST UP ITEM CONTACT
ABOUT AND SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES.
WITHIN PROP NINETY EIGHT AND
AND PERHAPS STRANGELY EVEN
THOUGH THE HOUSES REVENUE
ADOPTIONS ARE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ACTUALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE GUARANTEE IS IT
REALLY CHANGING ACROSS THOSE
THREE PLANS. AND THAT'S LARGELY
DRIVEN BY THE TEST.
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT WHICH IS
IT IS A TEST TWO MONTHS IT MIGHT
SEEM COUNTERINTUITIVE DISARM
THAT EVEN THOUGH THE REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE QUITE DIFFERENT
THAT THE GUARANTEE ITSELF ISN'T
REALLY CHANGING WILDLY.
THAT SAID I THINK.
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WILL
OFFER AS WE GET INTO MORE
SPECIFIC ISSUE AREAS WITHIN
NINETY EIGHT.
HAVE TO DO WITH THE MIX OF ONE
TIME VERSES ON GOING IN SOME
WAYS A MICROCOSM OF THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING IN THE
BUDGET AS A WHOLE. ON THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING.
LESSEN THE ON GOING SIDE AND
REALLY FOCUSING THAT ON ON LCF
ACT AND BASS FUNDING ON END OF
PUTTING MORE ON THE ONE TIME
SIDE SO. THE TOTAL DOLLAR
AMOUNTS ARE DIFFERENT KIND OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE IS WHERE THE
DIFFERENCES LIE. ADDITIONALLY AS
I MISS KUHN POINTED OUT ON THE
PROPERTY TAX ASSUMPTIONS WILL.
DRIVE SOME DIFFERENCES IN THE
MIX OF DOLLARS WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE AND IS A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR.
SAVINGS TO THE GENERAL FUND
BASED ON HOW MANY MORE PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES.
R. ASSUMES.
LASTLY I WOULD JUST KNOW I'M AS
THE ANALYSTS POINTED OUT AND
THAT THERE IS A PRETTY WIDE
VARIANCE IN THE ONGOING COST OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND IT
INCLUDES THREE POINT SIX BILLION
AN ON GOING COSTS THE SENATE'S
UP FOUR POINT FOUR SEVEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT CLOSE TO. FIVE
BILLION ON MEN SO THOSE WILL AND.
IMPACTS ON AS THE ALICE HAS
POINTED OUT IF WE WERE TO HIT A
ROUGH PATCH.
JUST LIKE THE GENERAL BUDGET
ONE TIME FUNDS GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY A TO RIGHT
THE SHIP IF SOMETHING SHOULD
HAPPEN AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'VE
I'M REALLY FOCUSED OUR EFFORTS
ON THAT. A WITH THAT I WILL. GO
BACK TO THE CHAIR AND ALL SPEAK
MORE THAT THE HIGHER EDUCATION
WE GET TO THOSE ISSUE ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I'LL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEN DONE BEEN LIKE TO MOVE
TO ISSUE.
NUMBER ONE.
WHICH IS JUST TO.
.
GOING TO NEED LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FROM.
SO IF.
MISTER HARRISON FURTHER ISSUES
ONE THROUGH THREE FROM LL ONE TO
GET YES GOOD MORNING RYAN
ANDERSON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO THE FIRST ISSUE YOU'RE
HEARING THIS MORNING IS ACTUALLY
THE THE HEART OF YOUR K. TWELVE
PACKAGES IN BOTH HOUSES IS
APPROXIMATELY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS AN ON GOING SPENDING
COMMITMENTS. MOSTLY RELATED TO
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
SO THE LITTLE BACKGROUND AGAIN
LC F..
IT'S STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN IS THE STATE'S
PRIMARY MECHANISM FOR PROVIDING
FUNDING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
NOW AT THE TIME IT WAS ADOPTED
IN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE FORMULA
COST ABOUT EIGHTEEN BILLION MORE
THAN THE STATE HAD AVAILABLE SO
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE JUST
BEEN MAKING UP THAT GAP. OF IT
SLOWLY I'D CREEPING CLOSER TO
THAT STATUTORY TARGET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED FULLY
IMPLEMENTING LCF F. STARTING IN
NINETEEN NINETEEN AND IN FACT
ALL THREE PACKAGES BEFORE YOU.
THINK GO A STEP FURTHER NOT ONLY
FULLY IMPLEMENTING THOSE OF
REGIONAL STATUTORY TARGETS PUT
INCREASING THEM ACROSS THE BOARD
BY SOME AMOUNT. NOW THIS ACROSS
THE BOARD INCREASE IS NOT THE
ONLY OPTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AVAILABLE FOR AUGMENTING OR
ADJUSTING THE LC FF BUT IT IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH. AND IT HAS
TO A BIG BENEFITS FIRST IT HELPS
ALL SCHOOLS ACCOMMODATE SOME
ACROSS THE BOARD COST PRESSURES.
INCLUDING IMPORTANTLY PENSION A
CONTRIBUTION INCREASES WHICH I'M
SURE YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT.
AND SECOND FOR EVERY DOLLAR YOU
PUT INTO INCREASING THE LC FF
ABOUT SIXTEEN SENSE
GO SPECIFICALLY DEFINED
INCREASED OR IMPROVE SERVICES
FOR STUDENTS AND DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS. CURRENTLY THAT WOULD BE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND ENGLISH
LEARNER STUDENTS.
NOW THE ASSEMBLY GOES A STEP
FURTHER AND MAKES AN ADJUSTMENT
TO THE LC FF AND SPECIFICALLY TO
ITS DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS ADDING TO IT AND NEW
GROUP. OF THAT WOULD BE THE
GROUP THAT IS THE LOWEST
PERFORMING ON STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS OF READING AND MATH
CURRENTLY THAT GROUP IS AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS.
THEY ASSEMBLY ESTIMATES IT WOULD
COST ABOUT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADD THOSE
STUDENTS.
AND TO THE COUNT OF
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR THE WAY EL CFF
WORKS IS IT'S AN UN DUPLICATED
COUNT. A DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
SO CURRENTLY IF AS SOON AS BOTH
LOW INCOME AND ENGLISH LEARNER
THEY RECEIVE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE BUT THEY'D JUST RECEIVE THE
SAME RATE AS A STUDENT WHO
BELONGS TO ONE GROUP OR ANOTHER.
I CURRENTLY MOST AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS FALL INTO ONE
OF THESE CATEGORIES SO THIS
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
WOULD EXCLUSIVELY GO TOWARDS
PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
TO AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO
ARE NOT LOW INCOME AND NOT
ENGLISH LIKE.
THAT SENATE HAS A PROPOSAL THAT
IN SOME WAYS SOUND SIMILAR BUT
IT ACTUALLY WORKS VERY
DIFFERENTLY THEY IT THEY SET
ASIDE. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO CREATE A ONE TIME
COMPETITIVE GRANT.
FOR THE SCHOOLS SERVING AN
UNUSUALLY LARGE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO DON'T MEET
STATEWIDE STANDARDS.
NOW WE WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
BOTH OF THESE APPROACHES.
.
WHO ARE HAPPY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT
THEM IF YOU'D LIKE TO DIG INTO
THEM EARLY JUST LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THAT AND THE STATE DOES
HAVE MANY OTHER OPTIONS FOR? A
ADDRESSING ITS PERSISTENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY WILL NOT BE RESOLVED
IN THIS THIS BUDGET DELIBERATION
WILL BE SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL BE
CONSIDERING. OF FOR MANY YEARS
TO COME.
OF THE FINAL ISSUE IN THIS
PACKAGE IS THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATES TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO PARTIALLY EQUALIZE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING RATES.
IN MANY WAYS THIS IS PART AND
PARCEL OF THE AUSSIE FF EFFORT
WANTED THE OBJECTIVES OF LC FF
WAS TO REMOVE. HISTORICAL
FUNDING INEQUITIES IN SCHOOL
FINANCE IN THE STATE AND WITH
FULL IMPLEMENTATION WE HAVE
LARGELY DONE THAT THE LARGEST
EXCEPTION IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
WHERE RATES VARY FROM AS LITTLE
AS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
STUDENT TO AS MUCH AS FIVE NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS PER
STUDENT. IS REALLY HAS NO
LOGICAL BASIS IN THE USER RATES
THAT HAVE BEEN LOCKED IN PLACE
FOR DECADES.
AND OUR OFFICE DOES RECOMMEND
TO THE EXTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMFORTABLE
COMMITTING SIN BICU ON GOING.
EXPENDITURES THAT IT MAKES THIS
OF ONE OF ITS HIGHEST PRIORITIES.
I THINK YOU TO PART OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M FOR
THE FIRST OUT IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AGAIN THIS IS REALLY.
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WOULD PREFER
THAT AND BASS FUNDING OUR ON
GOING FUNDING IS REALLY BALLOTS
WITH THE ONE TIME FUNDING TO GET
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE PACKAGE
ITSELF.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD KNOW THAT
IN THE ASSEMBLIES VERSION THEY
USED FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
MILLION ONE TIME RESOURCE SAYS.
THAT WOULD BE USED TO FUND
ONGOING PROBLEM PROGRAMS EXCUSE
ME SUCH AS THE HEALTHY ABOUT SO
WE WORRY ABOUT USING A ONE TIME
FUNDING SOURCE FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY ONGOING IN NATURE.
SECONDLY ON THE.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE LC FF A
TARGET BASE RATES IN NINETEEN
TWENTY. WE WOULD KNOW OBVIOUSLY
I ANY NEW TARGETS WILL CREATE
COST PRESSURES WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE WE ASK MADE IT WOULD
AYE. OUT APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
BILLION AND LTFS COST PRESSURES
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE.
SECONDLY WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
WAGE STRUCTURE THE PER PEOPLE
DATA USED IS BASED ON
EXPENDITURES NOT APPROPRIATIONS
SO THEORETICALLY IF THE DISTRICT
HAD MONEY THAT THEY DIDN'T
SPENDS FOR EXAMPLE THEY KEPT
THEIR RESERVES. IT WOULDN'T BE
CALCULATED UNDER THE STRUCTURE
AND SO WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THAT.
MOVING ONTO A BOTH HOUSES
INCLUDING.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROPOSALS
FOR.
LOW PERFORMING STUDENTS.
WE WOULD KNOW AGAIN.
THAT IT'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ONE TIME VERSES ON GOING FOR
THIS PROGRAM WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
ONTO REALLY FUN THIS PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD NOTE THAT
WE HAVE SOME LEGAL CONCERNS WITH
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE
ASSEMBLIES PROPOSAL AND
SPECIFICALLY AROUND PROP TWO ON
NINE.
LASTLY AND SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL BUDGET
CYCLES AND WE HAVE PUT FORWARD
SEVERAL DIFFERENCE.
GOVERNANCE PROPOSALS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION TO FURTHER FORTIFY THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SELF WAS
AND LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THOSE
GOVERNANCE CHANGES TAKE PLACE
BEFORE WE HAD BEGIN ENTERTAINING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INTO THIS
PROGRAM.
WITH THAT HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
WE THINK YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR NELSON.
ON THE LOCAL FUNDING FORMULA
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE.
TO FOCUS.
IN HELPING THE LOW PERFORMING.
HOW ARE YOU DEFINING THAT
UNIVERSE?
I'D CURRENTLY THE LCF HAVE.
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING.
THE STUDENTS WHO FALL IN ONE OF
THREE CATEGORIES.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THAT'S
BASED ON ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT
FEDERAL.
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEAL
PROGRAM WHICH IS DEFINED AT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PERCENT OF
THE FEDERAL POWER AND POVERTY
NEXT ON THOSE WHO HAVE APPLIED.
GETTING THOSE FUNDS IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
CURRENTLY ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION DOES
MEET THAT DEFINITION OF LOW
INCOME.
IN ADDITION.
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS ARE PROVIDED
TO ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS EASY
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FIRST
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE THE
LANGUAGE WE SPEAK AT HOME IS
SOMETHING OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AND SECOND HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THAT THEY DO THAT THEMSELVES
HAVE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY. THE FINAL GRANT
BASED ON ACTUAL TESTING OR JUST
THAT'S CHRONIC DOUBLE TESTING OR
AN ANECDOTE STATEMENT THERE'S A
THERE'S A TWO STEP PROCESS TO
IDENTIFYING IN ENGLISH ONE OF
THE FIRST IS A.
HOME LANGUAGE SURVEY.
ON WHICH THE STUDENT MUST
IDENTIFIED THAT AT HOME THEIR
FAMILY SPEAKS A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH ALL THOSE STUDENTS
ARE GIVEN. AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY AS ASSESSMENT AND
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT PASS THAT
ASSESSMENT ARE LABELED AS
ENGLISH LEARNERS.
THE FINAL CATEGORY OUR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THAT HOW IT IS
EVOLVED OVER THE YEARS I WAS A
MEMBER MANY YEARS AGO OF
SOMETHING CALLED THE FIRST
BILINGUAL BICULTURAL.
STUDENT THE.
OR PARENT ADVISORY COUNCIL AND
SO WE BY FOUGHT OVER THE YEARS.
ONE OF THE THE CONCERNS OF AND
CONSIDERATIONS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
THIS COMMITTEE CONSIDER.
THE THE FUNDING.
MAKES SENSE.
BUT.
TO INCORPORATE IN OUR BUDGET IN
THIS WOULD BE IN MANY AREAS.
HOW DO WE?
TEST HOW DO WE ASCERTAIN SUCCESS.
DEFINING SUCCESS AND THEN HAVING
IT CHECKED SO NEXT YEAR'S
COMMITTEE.
TO LOOK AT THE MONEY EXPENDED.
AND SEE HOW MANY YOUTH WERE
SERVING.
THEN WHAT PROGRESS
THEY'RE MAKING YOU HAVE ANY
IDEAS HOW WE MIGHT ACHIEVE THAT.
YEAH I THINK THE.
A CERTAIN BASIC CHALLENGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH FOR MANY YEARS
IS. WHETHER.
THE FOCUS SHOULD BE ON
EDUCATIONAL INPUTS ARE ON STERN
OUTCOMES AT THE PREVIOUS SYSTEM
WAS MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON. THESE
ARE PARTICULAR TYPES OF
EXPENDITURES ARE PROGRAMS THAT.
WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT FOR
SCHOOLS TO RUN AND WE WILL HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR RUNNING
THOSE PROGRAMS WITH WITH LC FF
WE'VE TRIED TO SWITCH. TOWARDS A
SYSTEM THAT'S MORE BASED ON
STERN OUTCOMES AND.
AND MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
SCHOOLS TO SPEND ON WHATEVER
PROGRAMS THEY THINK ARE
NECESSARY WITH THE PROMISE THAT.
THAT WOULD RESULT IN A IMPROVE
SOON OUTCOMES I I WILL SAY AT
THIS POINT THE RESULTS DO APPEAR
SOMEWHAT MIXED ON THAT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BETWEEN FOR
EXAMPLE LOW INCOME AND NON LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. HAS NOT
NOTICEABLY BUDGETS IN THE FIRST
FEW YEARS OF LCF FAT. SO I I DO
THINK THAT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE.
.
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S PART AND AND
CONTINUE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
ADDITIONAL WORK CAN BE DONE.
FINE WELL I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THAT. TO
SOME DEGREE HERE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO.
LAY DOWN A MARKER.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ROUTE THERE ARE RESULTS.
FOR THE INVESTMENT OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TOO OFTEN WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT
DO YOU HAVE A THOUGHT ON THAT.
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING ONLY SUMMERS AND
GIVE IT A PART IN A PLANE AND SO
I RECENTLY IN THE FALL WE'VE
STARTED WE RELEASED THE FIRST.
RESULTS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DASHBOARD. AND YOU KNOW IN THE
STASHED WHERE IS MEASURING NOW
MORE.
.
ADDITIONAL AND SO YOU WE USED TO
BE LIKE A REAL HIGH TEST
EVERYTHING WAS BASED ON THE TEST
SCORES NEED THE DASHBOARD NOW
HAS A BETTER RANGE OF OUTCOMES.
BUT HOW HOW DO YOU THEN REPORT
THAT YOUR DASHBOARD THAT RESULTS
TO PUT IT THAT WAY POWER THEY
REPORTED.
THE DASHBOARD RESULTAR.
POSTED ONLINE AND ARE INCLUDED
IN EVERYONE'S EL CAP SO THAT
THEY ARE THERE ADDRESSING THEM.
AT THE END EACH YEAR.
IT'S A ONE OF THEM HAS RESULTS
THERE'LL NEITHER EXPERT HERE ON
YES. PLEASE.
JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
SO THE NATIONAL RESULTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC I'M ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
WEBSITE ON THE DASHBOARD OF.
POSTS RESULTS OF BOTH THAT TASK
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSESSMENTS FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
IN MATH.
IT POST INFORMATION ABOUT
THINGS LIKE A SUSPENSIONS
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM GRADUATION
RATES AND CAREER. AT AND A
COLLEGE READINESS.
WELL.
WOULD YOU.
SAVE MYSELF AND MY STAFF A
LITTLE.
WORK AND.
PRESENT THE MOST RECENT DATA TO
US SO WE COULD TAKE A LOOK AT IT
AS WE PROCEED IN THE.
AND HERE. WE CAN GET SOME
STATEWIDE DATA FOR YOU AND FOR
YOUR STAFF CERTAINLY OKAY.
MISS COSTA DO YOU HAVE A THOUGHT
ON THAT.
I'M JUST THAT I THINK THIS IS
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT POLICYMAKERS
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH FOR DECADES
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT LCF FAST
AND THE EL CAP REALLY REPRESENT
A PRETTY SEISMIC SHIFT IN HOW WE
THOUGHT ABOUT EDUCATION
FINANCING. AND HOW WE THINK
ABOUT OVERALL STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND HOW WE DEFINE
THAT AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOTED.
WE MOVED FROM A SYSTEM IN WHICH
WE HAD MANY DIFFERENT
CATEGORICAL AS FOR SEVERAL
DIFFERENT STUDENT SUBGROUPS
ALLOWANCE AT EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS.
WE HAD THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL EXIT EXAM AND MANY OTHER
TASKS.
WE'VE NOW MOVED TO.
A STRUCTURE IN WHICH INSTEAD OF
IT BEING COMPLIANCE DRIVEN ON
THE STATE SIDE IT'S REALLY
EMANATING MORE FROM THE LOCALS.
ON AND THEY USE THE EL CAP AS
WELL AS THE DASHBOARD.
AND TO YOUR POINTS TO MEASURE
PROGRESS.
ON THE HOUSE BROUGHT UP THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND I WOULD KNOW
AGAIN AND THAT'S BEEN A
PERNICIOUS PROBLEM FOR THE STATE
FOR MANY YEARS.
EONS THAT EXISTED WHEN WE HAVE
THE CATEGORICAL.
SYSTEM OF A EDUCATION FINANCE
IN A CONTINUOUS AND IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING NOT.
ALL OF US NEED TO BE AWARE OF
THE MONITOR ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
BY POINT IN ALL THIS TO THE
COLLEAGUES ON THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE IT IT REQUIRES OUR
ATTENTION THAT HAS BEEN LONG
STANDING.
FOR DECADES.
BUT WE NEED TO CONTINUALLY FOCUS
ON IT AND TRY TO MAKE PROGRESS
IN THIS.
DELIBERATION AT LEAST LIKE TO
BRING THAT TO OUR ATTENTION. AND
ASCERTAIN A LITTLE BIT IF MONEY
INVESTED THUS FAR MADE MUCH
IMPACT. THAT LASTLY.
I HAVE GOT THE OF INQUIRED THAT
SHE ISSUE AND YOU SEE.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE?
TO
SAVE MONEY.
TO BE MORE PRUDENT.
WITH THE DOLLARS THAT THEY
INVEST.
I DON'T.
EDWARD BACK FROM YOU SEE YET.
BUT TIM WHITE AND I MET
YESTERDAY MORNING.
AND HE HAD A LOT TO SAY ABOUT
WHAT CSU HAD DONE.
IN THEIR INSTITUTION.
TO IMPROVE DELIVERY.
MAKE IT MORE PRUDENT.
I WAS VERY PLEASED.
THAT HE HAD SPENT SO MUCH
ATTENTION.
TO THAT ISSUE.
I WOULD CALL ON OUR EDUCATORS IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO SIMILARLY IN
ALL BE ASKING THAT QUESTION HAVE
YOU SEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO GLOBAL SAVE THAT
QUESTION FOR THE HIGHER AND
PORTION OF THE
SCHEDULED TO BE FOLLOWING THIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION ON THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION EQUALIZATION.
THIS TUNER MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
ADDRESS FUNDING.
RATES WHICH HAVE BEEN UNEQUAL
FOR DECADES.
I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT A DISTRICT
WHERE WE HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST
RATES.
PER STUDENTS IN OUR STATE AND I
CAN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND WHY
STUDENTS AND FRESNO WITH
DISABILITIES. SHOULD RECEIVE ANY
LESS FUNDING THAN A STUDENT IN
ANOTHER DISTRICT.
AND WANTS TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF I CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S TAKEN US.
SO LONG WHY IS IT TAKING US
DECADES TO RESOLVE THIS
INEQUITIES.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
FOCUS OF THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
REALLY BEEN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA SO SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE GENERAL
ED STUDENTS FIRST SO ANY MONEY
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED BY THE
STATE FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AT ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY. GRANTS WHICH ARE
YOU KNOW NEARING. EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANOTHER TWENTY
BILLION AND I'LL SEE IF AFTER IS
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
AS WELL SO.
PUTTING IT IN A UPS POP FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WHILE IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE AND THE LCF UP IT'S
NOT A IF WE PROVIDED MORE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING IT
WOULD SIMPLY MEAN THAT LAST.
OKAY FF MONEY WOULD BE FUNDING
THOSE STUDENTS.
I'M.
STRUGGLING TO NOT FEEL LIKE THIS
IS A BUREAUCRATIC WAY OF SAYING
WE HAVEN'T ADDRESSED THE PROBLEM
THOUGH FOR DECADES.
AND WANTS TO UNDERSTAND.
WE HEARD A DIFFERENCE OF A
DOUBLING BETWEEN ONE COUNTY AND
ANOTHER COUNTY IN TERMS OF WHAT
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION RATES ARE.
AND THE EXPENSES ARE THE SAME.
AND SO I'M JUST REALLY TRYING TO
PUSH US A LITTLE BIT TO ADDRESS
A PROBLEM I KNOW WE FOCUSED ON
LC FF.
BUT WANTED JUST TO PUT MY MARKER
AND TO SAY I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND REALLY
HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT COULD
FIND A WAY. TO BE SUPPORTIVE AS
WELL.
IF I MAY UM TO JUST DOT TELL MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS A THINK.
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY GOALS HAS
BEEN TO FULLY FUND LCF PFAFF
WHICH THANKFULLY WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO BOTH HOUSES OF ADOPTED
THAT AS WELL AND THAT'S BEEN A
PRIMARY GOAL. THE ISSUE OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION EQUALIZATION
IS NOT A NEW ONE EITHER ON IT'S
ONE THAT HAS BEEN DEBATED IN THE
BUDGET.
SEVERAL TIMES AT LEAST DURING
MY CAREER.
AND SO I THINK IT'S NOT THAT WE
HAVEN'T SOUGHT TO ADDRESS IT BUT
WE WANTED TO REALLY GET TO FULL
FUNDING OF THE BASE AMOUNT FOR
DISTRICTS FIRST.
ADDITIONALLY AS I TESTIFIED
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME GOVERNANCE
ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED WITH SPECIAL EDUCATION
IN THIS NEW WORLD OF ALTHEA FAST
AND THE AL CAPP. WE REALLY
WANTED TO ALIGN ITSELF AS BETTER
WITH THAT LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND DEVELOPING THEIR EL CAP. ON
ESPECIALLY BASED ON SOME OF THE
RESULTS WE SAW FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS THIS PAST
FALL.
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY I'M GONNA TALK
A LITTLE BIT FRANKLY I'M ABOUT
THE ASSEMBLIES ON INITIATIVE
AROUND ACHIEVEMENT GAP. I
APPRECIATE.
ARE BOTH THE AGENDA AND IN THE
LA ELSE DESCRIPTION THEY. REFER
TO AFTER AMERICAN STUDENTS AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT GETS US INTO
DANGEROUS WATERS ONLY TALK ABOUT
PROP TO A NINE BECAUSE I AS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. FROM MY COLLEAGUE
ó IN THE ASSEMBLY IN OF THE
FOCUS IS CREATING A SUBGROUP TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS.
WHO TODAY AND FOR MANY YEARS
HAPPEN TO BE AFTER AMERICAN
STUDENTS
SO IF WE'RE FOCUSING ON LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS THAT GROUP
I'M NOT SURE HOW TOOL NINE?
TECHNICALLY COMES INTO PLAY FOR
SOMEONE TO ADDRESS THAT I'D
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M JUST COMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS AROUND
AND THE HEAD SO MAYBE START
AGAIN SOME CONTEXT. SO FAR
SUBGROUPS STATEWIDE WE HAVE
SUBGROUPS BASED ON ETHNICITY WE
HAVE SUB GROUP AND BASED ON
SUSAN DISABILITIES WE HAVE A SUB
GROUP FOR FOSTER YOUTH LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
AND.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND
OTHER LANGUAGE IN THE AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT AND. TO BE FAIR WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ON THE AYE TRAILER
BILLING WHICH WAS PROPOSAL YET
BUT OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IS
VERY SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT'S
THAT'S AND EXISTENCE RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT BILL BASICALLY AND. AT
SAYS THAT YOU KNOW THIS THE
SUBGROUP IS DEFINED BY.
BOTH BEING ONE OF THOSE SUB
GROUPS AND AT ELIMINATING ALL
THE SUBGROUPS THAT RECEIVE
FUNDING FROM OUTSIDE SOURCES.
SO WHAT THAT DOES ESSENTIALLY IS
THAT ELIMINATES TUNES
DISABILITIES BECAUSE THEY
RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
IDA. I'M ELIMINATES AND THOSE
SUBGROUPS THAT RECEIVES UP
MIDDLE CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING. SO. OUR CONCERN IS RUN
THE FACT THAT WITH THAT LEAVES
HIS STUDENTS UP. SUBGROUPS ARE
ONLY BASED ON ETHNICITY. TO THE
LAWYER THOSE PERFORMING WOULD BE
ONLY BASED ON ETHNICITY SATS
WERE CONCERNED THROUGH POP TUNIC
GOT IT GOT IT.
AND THEN IS THERE A WAY.
TECHNICALLY.
TO AVOID.
.
THE LACK OF A BETTER TERM
COUNSELING NOW THE SUPPORT TO
THOSE OTHER GROUPS.
WHILE ADDRESSING
RESOURCES TO THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS BASED ON
THEIR PERFORMANCE ON CASTING IN
YOUR DEVELOP DASHBOARD IS THERE
A WAY TO DO IT.
SO I UNDERSTANDING IS AND AND
AGAIN WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON IT BUT
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL. ON DOES.
GET AROUND THIS ISSUE BY
ESTABLISHING ANOTHER SUBGROUP
THAT'S BASED ON AND TASK
PERFORMANCE AND I NOTICED THAT
HE GOT IT GOT IT. TO THE ALLEY
OFF I MAY YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT
IT AND I WOULD AGREE BOTH TO THE
I'D MINISTRATION AND LA I'LL
TALK WITH THIS IS A NEW ISSUE
AND THAT'S TRUE.
I I WOULD HOPE THAT WE MOVE
BEYOND A NOTION OF MONITORING TO
REALLY TRY TO ADDRESS THE
REALITY.
AND WHAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT THE
CURRENT. LAW IS PERFORMING
SUBGROUP IS YOUR RIGHT FOR AFTER
AMERICAN STUDENTS IT SPANS
SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS WHICH IS
ALL THE MORE TROUBLING.
IN TERMS OF WHY THAT CONTINUES
TO BE WHAT IS IT IN OUR. ON
SYSTEM THAT IS NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THIS GROUP OF CHILDREN.
YOU TALK ABOUT THEIR OTHER
THINGS THE STATE CAN DO TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS THAT YOU
DON'T SUPPORT.
EVEN ASSEMBLY OR THE SENATE.
.
PROPOSAL LOTIONS WHAT MIGHT
THOSE BE.
AND SO TO BE A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT THE CONCERNS WE
WE HAVE A AT THE LEGAL
CHALLENGES WITH THE ASSEMBLY
pEXPLICATED BUT TO TALK ABOUT THE
THE SENATE APPROACH.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS THAT.
THE USE OF ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ADDRESS WHAT HAS BEEN A
PERSISTENT AN ON GOING. UP
PROBLEM IS UNLIKELY SAID MAKE
THIS SORT OF IMPACT THAT WE WE
DESIRE. BUT SO WE DO THINK THAT
ANY.
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEMS SHOULD
JUST AS THE PROBLEM BE ON
ONGOING COMMITMENT.
THE FIRST OPTIONS THAT THAT
SUGGESTS WOULD BE MODIFICATIONS
TELL CFF SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSED. I'D AND WE
HAVE MANY OPTIONS BESIDES ADDING
ADDITIONAL GROUPS TO THE ON
DUPLICATED COUNT FOR EXAMPLE. OF
THE LC FF INCLUDES CONCENTRATION
FUNDING WHICH IS.
DESIGNED TO BE TARGETED TOWARDS
THE HIGHEST POVERTY DISTRICTS
BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT
PARTICULARLY WELL TARGETED
ATTRACT ABOUT SIX
PERCENT OF DISTRICTS RECEIVED
THIS FUNDING. IF YOU WERE TO
TARGETED MORE SPECIFICALLY TO.
JUST THE HIGHEST POVERTY
DISTRICTS FOR THE SAME DOLLAR
AMOUNT YOU CAN.
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING TO THEM.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WOULD BE YOU
COULD GO TO AND I DUPLICATED
COUNT OF STUDENTS WEAR UNDER
WHICH STUDENTS TO FOR EXAMPLE.
ARE BOTH IN FOSTER CARE AND LOW
INCOME WOULD RECEIVE TWICE AS
MUCH FUNDING AS A A STUDENT WHO
BELONGS TO JUST ONE OF THOSE
CREW.
AND THESE ARE JUST EXAMPLES.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MANY OPTIONS BEFORE IT ON IT BUT
OUR GENERAL ADVICE WOULD BE
BECAUSE THIS IS A PERSISTENT
PROBLEM. YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT SOME ONGOING SOLUTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
BRIEFLY I SHARE THE CONCERNS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE.
THE ASSEMBLY IS.
BOB PROPOSAL BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS A A PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
REALLY IT IS.
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND.
THE SENATE PROPOSAL I THINK.
.
AND DOES IT IN A WAY THAT IS
APPROPRIATE EXCEPT FOR THE FACT
THAT IT'S OUTSIDE OF LCF F. AND
I'D REALLY LIKE TO SEE. BECAUSE
AS THE LOW POINTS OUT.
THIS IS A PERSISTENT PROBLEM AND
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT I THINK
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
A LOT OF KNOW HOW. ON I HAVE
HELPING TO SOLVE AND I I'D LIKE
TO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT SO. IT WOULD BE NICE TO
SEE THE SENATE PROPOSAL ADOPTED
BUT BUT WITH THE PROVISION OF
PUTS IT UNDER LC FF.
THANK YOU SIMILAR METROPOLIS.
LIKE JUST DISCUSSION I'VE BEEN
ON THE.
SUB TO FOR SIX YEARS DOWN THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY SEE
THE. DEVELOPMENT AND.
OF LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING HAS HAD
ON THE EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
WITHIN THE STATE.
I THINK OF A COUPLE ITEMS HAVE
NOT BEEN DISCUSSION THAT.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN USE MONEY
TO INFLUENCE HAD AN EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
ONE OF THE.
LOW.
ISSUES THAT OFTEN COMES WHEN YOU
VISIT.
SCHOOLS AND TALK TO PARENTS IN
THE IN PROFESSIONALS ARE YOU'LL
FIND OUT. THE GREATEST IMPACT
UPON THE EDUCATION OF THE CHILD
AS A PARENT.
THE* SECONDARILY BE TO TEACH
THE TEACHER.
SO WHAT LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
ONLY STARTED THIS IT WAS STE.
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE FONT OF
KNOWLEDGE WAS NOT OUT OF
SACRAMENTO DO YOU CATEGORICAL
BUT TO PUT IT DOWN WITH IN THE
DISTRICTS.
AND UNDERSTANDING THERE'S A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT. AND
FRESNO OR BAKERSFIELD ARE
CARLSBAD WHICH I REPRESENT.
SO WE PUSHED OF MONEY DOWN THERE
BUT WE RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT THERE
WAS SOME CONSTERNATION FUNDING
FOR THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. AND ECONOMIC ISSUES
AND I THINK THAT THAT WAS A GOOD
IDEA BUT WE KNOW THAT IN THE
PAST.
THE FIRST THREE OR FOUR YEARS
JUST CHANGE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF EL CAPS.
A LOT OF PARENTS WERE INVOLVED.
I HAVE A BILL GOING THROUGH
REQUIRING THAT THE PARENTS
ACTUALLY BE INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AL CAPS OFF MY FIRST
STATEMENT MOST PORN EDUCATION IS
APPARENT.
SO.
THE YEAH DEL CAPS FROM OF ALL
MEANING GOING WE HAVE CARVED OUT
SOME MONEY BEFORE. OFF FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN IN THE SPECIAL
NEEDS I'VE HAD TAKEN THE TIME TO
ATTEND THE NUMBER OF THE
SEMINARS. A SPECIAL NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IS VARIED ACROSS
THE STATE BECAUSE SOME SCHOOL
AND OTHERS. HAVE THESE
CONSORTIUM SAY LOOK THEY'RE
LOOKING AT REGIONAL SOLUTIONS
FOR BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND I THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
TO ALLOW LOCAL.
AGENCIES FIGURED TO DEAL WITH
THE BEST WAY TO DO IS SPECIAL
NEEDS.
AND SO.
I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF A
CONTINUING THIS PROCESS LOCAL
PATROL FUNDING.
I THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THE ALL CAPS.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHEN JUST
LISTEN TO PEOPLE TALK THAT.
A DASHBOARD IS SOMETHING YOU CAN
PULL UP ON YOUR COMPUTER RIGHT
NOW AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN
YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
I TO BE ALL ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IT
SENATORS USE WHEN THEY VISIT
AREAS SAYING HERE'S YOUR
DASHBOARD IS JUST WHAT YOU WANT
TO BE SAYING AND THERE. IT'S A
BEGINNING PROJECT WE'VE ADDED CT
IN IT AND SOME OTHER ITEMS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT AND SPECIAL
NEEDS.
SO THE DASHBOARD IS REALLY THE
METRIC OF SUCCESS THAT WE CAN
GET THE PARENTS INVOLVED SIDE
ASK YOUR WE LOOK AT THAT.
MY FINAL POINT IS THIS.
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
WHO WOULD QUESTION CREASE
FUNDING FOR LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING.
FORMULA BUT WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
I THINK WE NEED TO DO THAT.
I THINK WE NEED TO DOIT BECAUSE
HAVE I SAID IN THE LAST SAID TO
MEETING.
REGARDLESS OF HOW THE ECONOMY
GOES UP OR DOWN.
A WE HAVE LEARNED THAT IF YOU.
SHORT CHANGE EDUCATION IS JUST
NOT.
LAS CHILDREN AND.
IN A PARTICULAR GRADE PERIOD
ACTUALLY HAS A HUGE ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
AND SO I WOULD MUCH RATHER
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
INFORMED WORKING.
PUBLIC
I CAN GET A GOOD JOB.
THEN DO PUT IN A PROGRAM.
BECAUSE SOMEBODY CAN'T GET A JOB.
SO I.
CAN TREAT A STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO. INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IN LOCAL
TWELVE FUNDING.
INVESTMENT AND PARENTS INVOLVED
THE EL CAP.
AND PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING REALLY
THE METRICS OF THE DASHBOARD IS
SEEN WITH THE SUCCESS IS GOING
ON HERE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT
WE SHOULD GO BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS
AND THANK THE FONT OF KNOWLEDGE
IN SACRAMENTO. TO CARVE OUT
MONEY FOR DIFFERENT GROUPS
I WOULD STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR IN IS PLANNED TO GO
FORWARD JUST MORE MONEY IN IT.
I THINK IT'S CHAVEZ.
IF I'M I MEAN JUST ONE FINAL
COMMENT AS A POINT OF CONTACTS
BOTH HOUSES AND THE GOVERNOR IN
THEIR BUDGET PLANS HAVE SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION TO CREATE A NEW
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FROM
LOW PERFORMING DISTRICTS.
THIS MONEY IS INTENDED TO
IDENTIFY DISTRICTS WE KNOW THAT
THE FIRST GROUP OF DISTRICTS
HAVE ISSUES WITH THEIR SPECIAL
ED PERFORMANCE.
THERE'S LOTS OF DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE ACHIEVEMENT GAP ISSUES AND
THE SYSTEM CAN IDEALLY BE USED
TO ADDRESS THIS PANOPLY OF
PERFORMANCE ISSUES AND AS LONG
AS THE LEGISLATURE REMAINS
FOCUSED ON PERFORMANCE ISSUES
INCLUDING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. IT
HAS WAY IS TO I THINK DIRECT
MONEY IT'S CITIES PERFORMANCE.
I'M PROBLEMS.
IF I MAY JUST THAT TELL ON THAT
POINT I THINK THE POLICY
QUESTION FOR EACH OF US TO
GRAPPLE WITH IS IN THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT. WE'RE REALLY FUNDING
CAPACITY BUILDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
ON THE PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU AND
CONFERENCE ARE REALLY MONEY
DIRECTED MORE TOWARDS DISTRICTS
SPECIFICALLY ANYTHING THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS LONG BEEN
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO BUILD
CAPACITY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
CANDIDLY MANY DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING SOME OF THE VERY
SAME ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
SO WE'D LIKE TO BUILD UP OUR
KNOWLEDGE BASE STATEWIDE TO MAKE
SURE THE ALL DISTRICTS CAN AND
TO LEARN FROM THAT TO DEAL WITH
SOME OF THESE.
SUBGROUP ISSUES THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING LOCALLY.
WELL THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW
WHERE ALL STILL TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH HOW BEST TO.
SHRINK THIS ACHIEVEMENT GAP I
KNOW IT'S BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
I KNOW EVERYBODY UP HERE AND
WENT DOWN THERE IS AS QUITE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
ON ONE OF THE ISSUES I THINK
WE'VE ALL BEEN.
STRUGGLING WITH THIS YES THE
MONEY IS GETTING TO TO DISTRICTS
HOW DO WE ASSURE THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY GETTING TO THE SCHOOLS.
SO IN FACT IF I COULD HEAR FROM
AYE WELL FINANCED TO IN WHICH OF
YOUR FEEDBACK AND MAKING SURE
THAT.
I HOW HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY
ENSURING THAT THE MONEY IS
GETTING INTO THE CLASSROOM NOT
JUST TO THE DISTRICT THAT
NEITHER.
.
SO.
THERE A LOT OF.
ISSUES I'VE BEEN RAISED WITH
THIS GENERAL QUESTION OF
TRANSPARENCY OVER LC FF
EXPENDITURES.
I THINK THAT THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING OUR
SCHOOL LEVEL EXPENDITURES.
SO THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING WE
HEAR A LOT FROM THE FIELD JUST
TO EXPLAIN THAT.
.
AND THE ISSUE RIGHT NOW THE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
.
METHODS THAT WE HAVE FOR ALL
SEAFOODS EXPENDITURES ARE
EXCLUSIVE TO ARE FOCUSED ON THE
DISTRICT LEVEL. I DISTRICTS
SUBMIT EL CAPS THAT SAY
GENERALLY WHAT ARE THEIR THEIR
PLANS FOR EXPANDING THESE FUNDS.
FOR DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS OF
MANY ADVOCATES IS CLAIMED THAT
THERE WOULD BE MORE RELEVANT TO
REPORT THIS.
AT A SCHOOL LEVEL.
THAT'S BEEN AN AREA OF
CONTROVERSY I I I BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IS OPPOSED TO IT.
.
LEGISLATING OF THE FIELD.
THANK YOU.
FINANCE.
SO A I HESITATE TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION OR SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE
IN ONE OR TWO SENTENCES BECAUSE
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT THAT THEY'RE
A OF SIMPLE ISSUE.
I THINK WE'D LIKE TO NOTE A
COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST THE TRANSITION TO LOCAL
CONTROL HAS BEEN ANYTHING BUT
SIMPLE.
IT'S A VERY BIG LEFT
IT'S A HUGE CULTURE SHIFT.
ON YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IN SOME
WAYS FOR FOR LOCALS IT IT COULD
BE EASIER TO SAY WELL WE HAVE TO
DO THIS BECAUSE THE STATE SAYS
SO.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE TO SAY WELL
WE'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE WE ALL
AGREE IT CELL AND THAT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT KIND OF
CONVERSATION I
HAD WITH YOUR COMMUNITY.
I WOULD PIGGYBACK ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD.
ALL OF YOU SAY REGARDING AND
ENGAGING WITH PARENTS AND
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
AN EXCELLENT JOB OF REACHING OUT
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSTANDING. ON WHAT THEY NEED
TO SAY AND HOW THEY NEED TO SAY
IT
WE'VE PROPOSED AND BOTH HOUSES
HAVE ADOPTED AND FUNDS TO HELP
AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES BECOME A BETTER
ENGAGE WITH EACH OTHER WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING THESE DECISIONS
THAT WE THINK THAT. THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT
SCHOOL SITE LEVEL EXPENDITURE
REPORTING ON IN THE WAY THAT
IT'S BEEN PRESENTED TO US.
THE WAY THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED
HAS.
REALLY FOCUSED ON TRACKING
INDIVIDUAL DOLLARS TO INDIVIDUAL
KIDS.
AND WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ON
SEVERAL LEVELS ONE THAT'S A HUGE
A WORKLOAD THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU
RATHER SEE THOSE FUNDS IN THAT
WORKLOAD GO INTO THE CLASSROOM.
I THINK ALSO THERE CAN BE
PROBLEMS.
THOUGH SOPHOCLES WITH THE IDEA
THAT YOU WANT TO TRACK KIDS TO
TWO DOLLARS.
SO I THINK WE'RE OPEN TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BUT WE
THINK THAT THERE'S SORT OF A
MIDDLE GROUND.
BETWEEN THE INFORMATION THAT WE
PROVIDED ON AND WHETHER NOT IT'S
HELPFUL.
I ALSO THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
ALL AGREED THAT THE EL CAP WAS
GOING TO BE THIS AMAZING
DOCUMENT THAT WAS GONNA. YOU
KNOW TELL PARENTS EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED TO KNOW AND HELP THEM
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS. BUT
WE'VE HEARD THAT IT'S KIND OF A
MIXED BAG.
AHMED SO WE KNOW THAT THAT NEEDS
TO WORK AS WELL. AND SO I THINK
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS I THINK WE
JUST DON'T WANNA GO DOWN THE
ROAD OF PUTTING A TON OF WORK
INTO SOMETHING THAT MAY NOT HAVE.
IT MAY NOT PROVIDE THE VALUE
THAT WE THINK IT WELL.
AND REALLY FOCUSING MORE ON
ENSURING THAT THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO FESTER
LOCALLY FOR DECADES. THAT WERE
MAKING SOME INROADS IN
ADDRESSING THOSE.
BECAUSE WE CAN PUT ALL THE MONEY
IN THE WORLD THAT WE WANT TO
INTO LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BUT IF IF THERE COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT WORKING ON IT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM IN THEIR COUNTIES ARE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM.
TO SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS THAT
REALLY ARE ARE DEEPER THAN JUST
MONEY. I'M WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED WE WON'T MAKE ANY ANY
MOVEMENT ON THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
GREAT THANK YOU NOW THAT TO
CHALLENGES.
THAT.
.
WHAT WE GAS SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
DO SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN DOING
THEM FOR YEARS AND DECADES AND
OTHERS?
THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO DO IT
SO I THINK THAT IS HOW I THINK
THE CHALLENGE OF OUTLINED WHICH
IS A.
TO SOME EXTENT A STRUGGLE RIGHT
BECAUSE WE'RE ASKING TOM THE
INTO. THE WHOLE MODEL THE WHOLE
TWENTY FOR ME THAT WAS SET UP
BASED ON THE. ASSUMPTION THAT
DISTRICTS WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
FEEDBACK FROM PARENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
TO.
.
FUNDING AND HOW. THAT FUNDING
FORMULA BOX THEY CAN GET GENUINE
FEEDBACK PROCESS JUST TALKING TO
ONE OR TWO PEOPLE OR EVEN JUST
TALKING TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS I THINK. ON THE.
IF THERE'S SOME WAY FOR US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND OUT.
WITHOUT CREATING.
LOT MORE BUREAUCRACY I THINK
THAT WOULD BE BE HELPFUL BECAUSE
I.
IDEOLOGY SAUSAGE FOR FOR MY
DISTRICT OF SAN FRANCISCO I
THINK. THERE'S THEIR THEIR OWN
FEELING IS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR DECADES AND THEY
HAVE A SET WAY OF DOING IT. BUT
THERE'S NO WAY TO REALLY
EVALUATE IS IT ISN'T REALLY THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT IS IT REALLY
THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
WAY TO DO IT I KNOW AS A PARENT
MYSELF HOME I. HAVE NEVER HEARD
THE WORDS LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA OR AL CAPP OR. YOU KNOW.
FUNDING OR EXETER IMAGES JUST
IT'S DOESN'T IT DOESN'T FLOW
HASN'T FLOWED BACK TO ME AS A
PARENT.
SO THAT THAT TO ME IS VERY
CONCERNING BECAUSE IF I'M A
PARENT AND ONE OF THE MOST
ENGAGED CITIES IN OUR STATE. ON
HOW I CAN JUST IMAGINE IS A CITY
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT LAST ENGAGE
IN MIND. AYE WHERE PEOPLE TEND
TO SORT OF TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING.
THAT I THINK THAT ON WE WE FACE
A VERY DAUNTING CHALLENGE THAT
IT'S IT'S THE ABSOLUTE LYNCH PIN
OF THE.
PROMISE OF OUR FUNDING FORMULA
SO I THINK WE DO HAVE TO. THINK
ABOUT THAT AND I AGREE THAT
NECESSARY MONEY IS NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS THE ISSUE BUT.
I THINK WHEN WE DID THIS FORMULA
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
WE WILL TRY TO MAKE UP FOR LOST
TIME MAKE UP FOR LOST GROUND AND
I THINK WE YOU KNOW WE CAN'T
WAIT FOR ANOTHER TEN YEAR SO
THAT SOME PHD IS FROM SOME
UNIVERSITY CAN STUDY THIS. AT
THAT POINT MY KIDS WILL HAVE
FORTY GRADUATE.
SO.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE TIME ITS
I THINK WE DO HAVE TO AS POLICY
MAKERS MAKE THE BEST DECISION
WITH THE BEST INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE.
HERE TODAY AND I THINK WHAT WE
ARE AT KNOWLEDGE IN AND I THINK
WITH ALL THAT KNOWLEDGE AROUND
THE TABLE ON BOTH SIDES OUT THAT
WE DO HAVE ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND
THAT. SEVEN YEARS OR SIX YEARS
INTO THIS.
YOU KNOW MISTER CHAVEZ AND I
WERE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE
PASSED LCS HALF. ON.
SIX YEARS GOING INTO IT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE KIND OF
PROGRESS THAT WE. HAVE HOPE I
DON'T THINK WE WERE EXPECTING
MIRACLES BUT THE SAME TIME I
THINK WE HAD WE WERE HOPING TO
SEE. SIGNIFICANTLY MORE PROGRESS
GIVEN THE HUGE INVESTMENT WE'VE
MADE.
SO ARM AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT OURSELVES TO
MAYOR IN BE IT YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S IT'S REALLY.
IS IS YOU KNOW REALLY THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO CONTINUE DOWN OR DO
WE NEED TO DO SOME MODIFICATION
I THINK BOTH HOUSES. HAVE COME
UP WITH PROPOSALS TO.
AUGMENTED I THINK WE TAKE A
SERIOUS LOOK AT THE ACTORS. ON
IT YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY WHICH IS
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN EXPECTING A DIFFERENT
RESULT SOUTH. ON I KNOW THAT
FUNDING FORMULA WAS TING
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT WE WERE
PURSUING GAP I THINK WE DO HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT THIS
FUNDING FORMULA STILL IS IN THE
INITIAL STAGES WE STILL NEED TO
PROVIDE THE FEEDBACK AND WE'RE
HEARING FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT.
THEY THEY HAVEN'T FELT.
SO I THINK THAT IS
THE FEEDBACK THAT I BEEN GETTING
WHICH IS THAT THEY THEY HAVE A
SENIOR SO AGAIN. ON THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS TOUCHING ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES ALL OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO.
LISTENED TO THAT NOT JUST NOT
JUST.
BE DEFENSIVE ABOUT THEM NOT
JUST DEFEND WHAT WE HAVE DONE
THE TO SAY HEY WE TOOK A BIG
STEP. NOW WE HAVE TO KEEP.
IMPROVING AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WERE I
THINK AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY SINK
LIKE WE WE TOOK A BIG STEP WE
THINK THIS IS STILL THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
DOZEN DEPARTMENT.
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AND IT WAS
INTERESTING AND AND LISTEN TO
YOU ARE BECAUSE THAT AS A PARENT.
I HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE ALPHABET
SOUP OF PUBLIC EDUCATION ALFIE
FF EL CAP BECAUSE I I HEARD IT
FROM. MY.
SON WHICH LET ME KNOW THAT IT
WAS BEING DISCUSSED IN THE
CLASSROOM PROBABLY BY TEACHERS
AND NOT ALWAYS IN A POSITIVE
LIGHT WHICH BIG WHICH KIND OF
INFORMED THE WAY WHICH WOULD.
COME UP AT HOME.
IN ADDITION TO YOU KNOW THE
TESTING WHICH SHE.
.
ONE IT POLICYMAKERS TO HEAR HIS
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT A REGULAR
BASIS ANYWAY I HOPE HOPE FROM.
WHO EXACTLY IN THE HE HE AUGUST
BEEN THE ACCOUNTABLE FOR ONE OF
THEM?
?
I HEAR YOU WINNING WHEN YOU SAY
IT'S NOT JUST MONEY I GET THAT.
AND YET IN IN ALL AS AS BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN ALL
DISCUSSIONS AROUND INVESTMENT OF
OF.
VERY.
HARD FOUGHT FOR DELICATE PUBLIC
DOLLARS
THE THE PUBLIC AS WE ALL ARE
LOOKING FOR A RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT ARE LOOKING FOR.
TRANSPARENCIES WE CAN TRACK THE
DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NO WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE
SOULS YOU KNOW THE FAMOUS QUOTE.
AND SO IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SAY IT'S NOT JUST MONEY WHEN YOU
THERE'S A GROUP OF ADVOCATES WHO
CURRENTLY ARE ARGUING FOR YOU
KNOW TWENTY K. BY TWENTY TWENTY.
AND YOU WE ALL WILL CAUCUSES TO
SIX UP ABOUT OUR PER PUPIL
INVESTMENT COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES IN CALIFORNIA'S NOW THE
FORTY NINTH AT THE. EIGHTY
EIGHTH OUT OF FIFTY STATES
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE SALT
WHILE WE SAY IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT.
THE DOLLARS AND THEN YET.
IT SEEMS TO ALSO BE
AND SO IT'S IT'S
IT'S CHALLENGING WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL. ON
TRANSPARENCY FOR US AS POLICY
MAKERS WHO WHO FOLLOWED THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION AROUND LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING DOWN THIS PATH.
BASED ON SOME ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
HOW DIFFERENT IT WOULD BE I
APPRECIATE IT'S A CULTURE SHIFT
BUT I GET I THINK MY CONCERN IS
KIDS DON'T GET DO ALL VERSE.
AND SO WHILE THIS GROUP OF THE
BIG KIDS ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THIS CULTURE SHIFT LITTLE
HEADS ARE CONTINUING TO SUFFER.
WHILE WE.
ART.
SEEM SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
FROM THOSE WHO NEED THE MOST
HELP AND PERHAPS THE GREATEST
INVESTMENT.
AND SO I YOU KNOW THERE IS A
CONCERN AROUND THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND HOW WE CANNOT.
COMFORTABLY SAY AS POLICY MAKERS
AT THE STATE LEVEL WITH THIS NEW
LOVE CONTROL EMPHASIS THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE.
FOLLOWING THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
IN GREATEST NEED I THINKAS A
RESULT OF THAT YOU DO GET
POLICIES FROM BOTH HOUSES TRYING
TO. CREATE.
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE TO SUPPORT
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
EVERYDAY IN CALIFORNIA PUBLICLY
FUNDED SCHOOLS.
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR ME.
.
YOU KNOW WE WE CAN DISAGREE ON
THE TECHNICALITY WHETHER IT'S
LEGAL UNDER PROP TWO ONE NINE OR
NOT OR HOW WE DO IT BUT I THINK
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO SEE A
RESPONSE. FROM THIS BODY ABOUT
HOW WE FIX IT IN REAL TIME
BECAUSE KIDS DON'T GET TO
OVERSEE AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
WAIT. FOR A SLOW CULTURE SHIFT
TO HAPPEN.
AND.
TOO MANY KIDS NOT BENEFIT.
TO THE TUNE THEY CAN IF WE WERE
TO MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THE
FORMULA.
TO GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR
INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE.
TO HELP SORT OF MORE LIKE.
I AM I APOLOGIZE YOU'RE RIGHT I
APOLOGIZE.
SORRY AT NEXT THE MOST A CLOSER
TO YOU.
MINUTE MISTER CHAIR IT'S BEEN A
REAL PRIVILEGE TO SERVE ON.
SUB ONE FOR THE SENATE SIDE ON
EDUCATION.
AND.
EVERY WEEK WE GET TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IN ITS USE IN A GOOD
DEBATE.
THE.
AB SAYS THIS ALEJO'S SAYS SAYS
THAT.
AND SO.
I AM A MISSING THAT IN THIS
ROUND YOU DON'T.
SEE A FIFTH COLUMN.
IT SAYS SAYS YOU KNOW GOVERNOR
ASSEMBLY.
SENATE AND THEN THEY'LL YELL
AGAIN TO TELL US HOW YOU REALLY
FEEL.
SO WITH THAT I I JUST WANNA LOOK
AT PAGE.
TEN ELEVEN WHERE YOU DISCUSS A
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION. AND
THE ASSEMBLY IS WILLING TO.
BUMP THE.
GOVERNOR'S SUGGESTION OF TWO
HUNDRED FOURTEEN SAID WHICH I
WITH FURTHER IF YOU ARE. SO FOR
THAT ITEM THAT IS ISSUE NUMBER
THREE.
WOULD YOU MIND HOLDING THAT
QUESTION I'LL I'LL LEAVE WITH
YOU ON ISSUE THREE FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
YES SIR THAT WOULD UP YOU CAN IF
YOU HAVE A PROP IF YOU'VE A
BROADER QUESTION FEEL FREE TO
OUR HOUSE THAT NOW IF NOT A NEW
IDEA THAT THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS JUST THE. AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE.
PLEASE OUT HOW THE HELL DOES
THAT FACTOR INTO. OF THE THE.
L. CFF.
.
HOUSE AWAITED.
A.
I AM GOING TO.
ANSWER I BELIEVE YOUR QUESTION
BUT PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M A
IF I'M NOT GETTING QUITE IT
LATER ASKING. A SO L. CFF IS
FIRST BASED ON A SERIES OF
WEIGHTS.
BY GRADE SPAN
SO THEREFORE GRADE SPANS THAT
EACH.
GENERATE UNIQUE BASE RATES
GENERALLY THE HIGHER GRADES.
EARNERS.
LARGER WAIT IN THE LOWER GRADES
AND THIS.
BASE RATE IS GENERATED PER UNIT
OF AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE SO.
THAT IS TO SAY.
NOT ONLY HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE
SHOWING UP BUT HOW FREQUENTLY
ARE THEY ATTENDING SCHOOL SO WE
WE TAKE AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
TIMES THOSE BASE RATES AND
THAT'S HOW WE. WE CALCULATE
BASICALLY ALSO. IN AND ARE WE
SEEING IN ATTENDANCE LEVELING.
I AND I THINK THE ISSUE MIGHT
BEGINNING AT TOTAL ATA AND HOW
THE GUARANTEE IS AFFECTED BY
EIGHT YES SO WE KNOW THAT I'LL
SEE IF I FOR THE PER STUDENT
FORMULA.
ABA.
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE HAVE
SOME PRELIMINARY DATA K. TWELVE
EIGHTY HAS BEEN DECLINING FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS OUR OFFICE IT
EXPECTS THAT TO CONTINUE
DECLINING.
FINANCE HAS A SLIGHT PICKUP IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IT'S AN
ASSUMPTION IF IT WILL BE WHAT IT
WILL BE AND IF IT COMES ON LOWER.
THAT THE THING IS ONCE YOU
ESTABLISH YOUR SPENDING LEVEL.
WHICH IS TYPICALLY LINKED TO
YOUR ABA ASSUMPTION YOU EITHER
OVER OR UNDER SHOT.
SO OUR CONCERN FOR OLD A FEW
WEEKS NOW HAS BEEN THAT YOU'RE
LIKELY OVER SHOOTING A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE OUR ETA LAST MONTH
AS LOWER.
SO IF EIGHTY A ARM.
IT COMES IN HIGHER.
YOU BUILD OUT YOU HAVE A TWO
YEAR HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION SO
IT WAS BECAUSE OF THAT YOU WILL
NOT SEE ANY NEED TO CLIMB IN THE
GUARANTEE AND NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EVEN IF
ABA IN FACT GOES DOWN
BECAUSE THE CONSTITUTION HAS US
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION. THE
COST OF THAT AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS ALREADY IN YOUR PLANS
BECAUSE YOU ASSUME THE SLIGHT
TICK UP AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
YOU'RE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GUARANTEE US HIGHER BY LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION AGAIN. NOW HAVING SAID
THAT ALL OF YOUR PLANS HAVE
CERTIFICATION LANGUAGE NEW
CERTIFICATION LANGUAGE THAT IS
AN EFFORT TO ALIGN YOUR SPENDING
WITH THE ULTIMATE GUARANTEE ONCE
YOU KNOW WHAT ABA ACTUALLY US.
SO IT COULD VERY WELL BE YOU GET
A YEAR FROM NOW AND YOU HAVE
SPENT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION MORE
THAN THAT GUARANTEE US ESTIMATED
AT THAT TIME BECAUSE EIGHTY
ACTUALLY CAME IN LOWER.
AND THE LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU
YOU'RE STILL WORKING ON THE
SPECIFICS OF THE LANGUAGE BUT
THEN FUNDS OF THE LANGUAGES THAT.
YOU WOULD EFFECTIVELY SCORE THAT
AS.
FUNDING INTO AN ACCOUNT.
THAT WOULD NOT AFFECT YOUR
NINETEEN TWENTY GUARANTEED IT
WOULD BE A CREDIT TO A FUTURE
YEAR ARE WHEN THE GUARANTEE WAS
HIGHER.
THIS IS THE SUCH THAT WE HAVEN'T
NO LONGER MADE A BIG DEAL ABOUT
IT BECAUSE YOU'VE BUILT INTO
YOUR PLANS A SORT CUSHION TO
PROTECT YOU AGAINST THE BASIS
THAT YOU'VE SPENT MORE THAN
YOU'VE INTENDED ONCE ALL THE
INPUTS ARE LOCKED IN PLACE.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING TO
CONCLUDE.
WITH WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
EIGHTY EIGHT AND SEVEN DISTRICTS
STARTING TO LEVEL LOUDER DECLINE.
.
ARE WE BUILDING ENOUGH BY A GOOD
INFLATION FACTOR IN ME. LC FF SO
THAT OBVIOUSLY COST STILL
CONTINUE EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A
DECLINE IN ATTENDANCE CORRECT SO
WE ARE WE PROTECTING THOSE.
ORTON DO WE CREATE. A AT ABILITY
TO MANIPULATE.
AYE EE.
NOT PUTTING STUDENTS ON.
EXPULSION FOR A DAY OR TWO
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS THEIR ABA AND
THEREFORE CERTAIN STUDENTS ARE
BEING PUNISHED.
JUST FOR FINANCIAL REASONS.
LET THE AND SAY WE HAVE NOT
HEARD ANY REPORTS OF.
GAMING STUDENT DISCIPLINE.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF ITS
EIGHTY EIGHTY IMPACTS OF THE
GENERAL QUESTION ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON SCHOOL FINANCE OF
DECLINING EIGHTY A. A IS A
GENERAL CONCERN BECAUSE.
OVER ALL SOON ATTENDANCE HAS
BEEN DECLINING IN THE STATE FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS.
MANY SCHOOLS ARE IN THE CASE OF
OF.
HAVING COHORTS ONE SMALLER THAN
I HAD THE PREVIOUS.
O. CFF ADDRESSES THIS BY HAVING
A TEMPORARY HOLD HOMELESS SO.
IF A SCHOOL SEIZE OF ONE YEAR
DECLINE IN. AN ATTENDANCE A DOES
NOT AFFECT THEIR.
ABA IMMEDIATELY THE OTHER.
FACTOR AS YOU NOTE IS COST OF
LIVING.
ATTENDANCE. ó COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS THOSE ARE APPLIED TO
THE L. CFF RATES. BUT THEY ARE.
INTENDED TO HOLD THE PURCHASING
POWER OF LC FF CONSTANT SO THEY
WOULD NOT.
DIRECTLY ADDRESS AND ENROLLMENT
DECLINES.
AND AND MISTER ANDERSON IS CUTE
THANK YOU FOR RESPONSES I'VE I'M
JUST CURIOUS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WE DO HAVE PRESSURES. WITH
CALPERS MCALISTER'S
AND SO ARE WE.
ACCOUNTING FOR THOSE PRESSURES
IN THE LC FF.
WELL. MOST OF THE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS THEIR MAIN TO
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS DO COME OUT
OF LCF F..
AS YOU KNOW THOSE.
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE INCREASING
LARGELY BECAUSE THE. RATES ARE
INCREASING ALSO BECAUSE THE
UNDERLYING SALARIES ON WHICH
THOSE RATES ARE APPLIED ARE AND.
IF THE QUESTION IS ARE WE
EXPLICITLY BUILDING IN INCREASES
TO THE LC FF.
IN LINE WITH THOSE INCREASES
THE ADVANCERS NO I I MEAN
GENERALLY IT'S BEEN THE CASE
THAT I'LL SEE IF I FUNDING HAS
INCREASED.
AT A AT A FASTER RATE OVER THE.
PAST FEW YEARS THAN RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE INCREASED IT
WILL BE UP TO THE LEGISLATURE
DID DECIDE WHETHER. SIMILARLY IN
FUTURE YEARS LCF A FUNDING WILL
INCREASE AT THE SAME PACE.
SO WHY WOULD THAT BE A
LEGISLATIVE.
RESPONSIBLY WHEN OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RESPOND.
I HAD THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
DISCRETION OBVIOUSLY OVERHEARD
HOW FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATED RIGHT.
RIVER WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAKE THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE WOULD DEBATED AS OPPOSED
TO. US TRYING TO TELL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THAT IS.
YEAH YOUR YOUR CRACK THAT THE
GOVERNOR ALSO HAS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE TO PLAY AND THAT BUDGET AS.
.
I AS A STAFF MEMBER FOR THE
LEGISLATURE I JUST LIKE TO
REMIND YOU ALL THAT YOU HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AS WELL.
RIGHT BUT IF I MAY SENATOR MORE
LIKE TO YOUR AT YOUR. TO YOUR
POINT SO.
HIGH LEVEL WITHIN LCF OUT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
DID PROPOSE A TWO POINT SEVEN
ONE PERCENT INCREASE IN THE BASE
FUNDING AMOUNTS AND WE KNOW
ACTUALLY IN ONE OF OUR MAY
REVISION AND PUBLICATIONS WE
ACTUALLY QUOTE THE ALEJO. BUT
THAT SINCE ENACTMENT OF THE CAL
STIRS FUNDING PLAN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN CASTERS AND CALPERS
CONTRIBUTION REQUIREMENTS FOR K.
TWELVE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ON HAVE INCREASED BY THREE
BILLION DURING THAT SAME PERIOD
OF TIME THE FUNDING FORMULA HAS
INCREASED BY SEVENTEEN POINT ONE
BILLION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GREAT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO WE HAVE A REQUEST FOR THE
SENATORS TORETURN TO THE FLOOR.
THIS WILL BE A GOOD TIME FOR US
TO TAKE A SHORT BREAK.
SO WE WILL.
WE WILL RECESS UNTIL ONE PM TO
ALLOW THE CENTERS TO. GO TO THE
FLOOR AND THEN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CAN. TAKE CARE OF
WHATEVER BUSINESS THEY NEEDED TO
CARE SO WE WILL ADJOURN TILL ONE
PM THANK YOU
WE ARE RECONVENING THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
ASK EVERYBODY TO COME BACK UP
.
LET'S BEGIN AND DIE A PICKUP
THAT ISSUE NUMBER TWO ONE TIME
FUNDING ALLOCATION.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
SLASH COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
YES RYAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO I'VE PAGE
THIRTY OF YOUR AGENDA HAS A
TABLE LISTING ALL OF THE ONE
TIME SPENDING COMMITMENTS.
OF WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE THERE IS A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS HEAR SOMEONE
GO INTO DETAIL IN AND INTO ANY
OF THEM UNLESS.
YELLER INTEREST IN DISCUSSING
THEM JUST A HIGHLIGHT FIRST OF
ALL THAT TOTALS AT THE BOTTOM.
AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED EARLIER.
THE TWO HOUSES MEN.
NOTABLY LESS THAN THE GOVERNOR
AND ONE TIME AND THIS DOES LEAVE
YOU WITH US OF ABOUT HER IF THE
GUARANTEE WERE TO DROP OR GROW.
MORE SLOWLY AND FUTURE YEARS
ALSO.
THE LARGEST USE OF ONE TIME
FUNDS AND ALL THREE PACKAGES IS
FOR THESE DISCRETIONARY GRANTS
THOSE ARE GIVEN OUT ON A FLAT
PER STUDENT BASIS AND CAN BE
USED FOR ANY PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON
COSTA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE ELSE'S POINTED OUT AGAIN
THIS GETS TO SOME OF THE
STRUCTURAL ELEMENTS OF THE
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE. IN WHICH
WE WOULD PREFER HAVING UTILIZING
ONE TIME FUNDING ON LIMITATIONS
TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY OVERALL
IN CASE REVENUES WERE TO
DECREASE JUST A COUPLE OF HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS ABOUT SOME OF THE
PACKAGES BETWEEN THE HOUSES. THE
ONETIME DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A MUCH HIGHER
AMOUNT HERE AND WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT TO GIVE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ADDRESS THINGS
SUCH AS PENSION COSTS WHICH
SENATOR MORLOCK RAISED EARLIER
IN THE COMMITTEE ON AND TO ALLOW
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT MAY BE OF SPECIFIC
CONCERN TO A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
I WOULD NOTE ON THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAM WE DO SUPPORT
THE SENATE VERSION THE ASSEMBLY
AUGMENTED.
THE PROPOSAL AND THEY RE DIRECT.
SOME FUNDS.
TO SHIFT THE PROGRAM FOCUS
WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
PROPOSED AS.
FOCUSING ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND THEY BROUGHT IT TO INCLUDE
BILINGUAL AND STEM TEACHERS AND
IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
SPECIAL EDUCATION OUTCOMES IN
THE STATE WE REALLY THINK THAT
IT DESERVES THIS AYE AYE FOCUS
HERE. PUFF WAR ADDITIONAL
TEACHERS.
LASTLY BOTH HOUSES DID FUND A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SUMMER
FURLOUGH PROGRAM WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THERE WAS SIMILAR
LEGISLATION THAT THE GOVERNOR
VETOED AND SO WE WOULD WANT TO
ENSURE THAT ANY SUCH PROPOSAL
ADDRESS THOSE VETO CONCERNS.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS BECAUSE THE
BACTERIA.
COMMITTEE.
I'M NOT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
ARE AND WHAT I WILL DO IS SEND
SENATOR MORLOCK IS NOT HERE WE
WALL PERHAPS TAKE IT BACK UP
WHEN HE RETURNS AS WELL BUT. IF
WE COULD START AND THEN WE WILL.
MAKE SURE HE GETS TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE TO REPLACE START.
YES ISSUE THREE IS.
I SCHOOL CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THE.
AND BOTH PACKAGES INCLUDE A
PROPOSAL FOR OF FOR EXPAND ITS
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THE SENATE
ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CREATE A NEW
HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAM WITH IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. A STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM THE ASSEMBLY
ADOPTED A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
ESTABLISHING ARE CONTINUING
THEIR PROGRAM OF CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION INCENTIVE
GRANTS WHICH ARE ADMINISTERED BY
CD AND PROVIDING FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THAT PURPOSE. WHAT
WE WILL SAY THAT WE RECOMMEND
THE ASSEMBLY IS APPROACHING THIS
ISSUE WE THINK THAT THE?
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF.
HANDLING HIGH SCHOOL CTE
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IS NOT PROPERLY LEVERAGE THE
EXPERIENCE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. AND.
OVERSEEING IT AND OFFERING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR A HIGH
SCHOOL CT PROGRAMS.
SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND USING THE
ASSEMBLIES APPROACH BUT ADOPTING
WHATEVER DOLLAR LEVEL THE
LEGISLATURE WAS COMFORTABLE WITH.
MISTRUST CONVERSELY THE
ADMINISTRATION RATHER THAN
LEVERAGING CD HE'S.
EXPERTISE IN THIS ISSUE WANTS
TO LEVERAGE WHAT'S HAPPENING
REGIONALLY SO THE COMMUNE.
STRONG WORKFORCE INVESTMENT WE
BELIEVE IT MAKES SENSE FOR
REGION'S TO HAVE THE. FULL
EXPOSURE OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION STARTING AT HIGH
SCHOOL THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. CLEARLY THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS HOME WILL BE DICTATED BY
THE TOTAL NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION REMAINS
COMMITTED TO THE GOVERNANCE
MODEL THAT WE PUT FORWARD. WHICH
WOULD CREATE A OUR BROADER
REGIONAL APPROACH TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION ADDITION
LEAN THIS PROGRAM WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINALLY FUNDED WAS OVER THREE
YEARS ON AND AS SUCH IT'S REALLY.
BEEN STRUCTURED AS REALLY A
TEMPORARY PROGRAM SO WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT INCLUDING ONGOING
FUNDING IN THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH SENATOR
MORLOCK ONCE HE SETTLES DOWN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I I I
FEEL THE LOVE.
ANOTHER BILL THAT.
JUST ON ARM.
CAREER. TECHNICAL EDUCATION
WE'RE SEEING THE ASSEMBLY OFFER.
HIGHER NUMBER THAN THEM THE.
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION.
AND I JUST WANTED TO KNOW ONE. I
GUESS IT'S LIKE TO SAY I AFFIRM
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL.
AND INTO CAN WE MAKE A HIGHER.
WOULD BE THAT THE OF THAT THE
THOUGHT I'M JUST WONDERING WERE
LA O. MIGHT BE.
ON ON THIS ONE SINCE WE'RE NOT
GETTING A DEBATE GOING.
.
IT IS SO I AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE
ASSEMBLIES APPROACH.
WHO WE THINK THAT IT? THAT IT
IS ANNA APPROPRIATE LEVERAGING
OF CD'S EXISTING EXPERTISE IN
THESE PROGRAMS TO OPERATE THE
PROGRAM UNDER THEIR DIRECTION.
AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT
WHATEVER APPROPRIATION LEVEL
THEY MAY FIND APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OTHER QUESTIONS
MR TRUST BOB.
I MAKE ME THE.
GALLAGHER FARTHER INTO THE.
ASSEMBLY IS PROGRAM IS SENATE
GRANT PROGRAM.
WHAT ELEMENTS OF IT DID YOU FIND
APPEALING?
I IT AGAIN THIS IS LARGELY A
QUESTION OF.
WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE BODY WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
THE PROGRAM AND WE JUST BELIEVE
THAT? BUT.
WITH THE PARTICULAR NEEDS OF
HIGH SCHOOL BASED CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM CD
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
ADMINISTERING CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS FOR THAT PURPOSE STATE.
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH THE
SCHOOLS SO. THAT HISTORY AND
EXPERIENCE WOULD HAVE TO BE
REPLICATED IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND IN ORDER FOR THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE THE SAME SUPPORT FOR.
SPECIFICALLY CD HAS GONE THROUGH
AND ACTS EXERCISE OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE CT <c.green> CAREER.</c>
THE CT ACADEMIC STANDARDS ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE COMMON CORE
STANDARDS SO THESE QUE TALL
ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CAREER TRAINING AS A LINE STUCK
TO THEM.
CD IS ALSO WORKING WITH
SOMETHING LIKE SEVEN TO NINE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE TO TRY TO
PROVIDE. REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP CTT PROGRAMS
LOCALLY IMPROVE THAT ALREADY
EXISTS SO WE WOULD SUGGEST
WHATEVER YOU DO YOU TRY TO
LEVERAGE THAT IN SOME FASHION.
AND DOES IT IS A GRANT PROGRAM
WHAT WAS THE AMOUNT OF THE.
.
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR USE IN TO
APPLY FOR THE GRANT WHEN THERE
ARE PEOPLE MATCHING AMOUNT.
I'D YES IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE
CITY INCENTIVE GRANT WAS FUNDED
ON A ONE TIME BASIS WITH A
MATCHING GRANT REQUIREMENT THAT.
MATCHING.
REQUIREMENT.
CHANGED INTO YEARS IT IT.
STARTED OUT I BELIEVE IT FIFTY
FIFTY IN AND DID.
AT TWO.
LOOK AT WHAT.
TWO ONE IS THAT.
THE PAY A YAWN I THINK WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING BEYOND ALL CFF WITH
CTE AGAIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
DISPOSED TO DO CTE WITHIN HIGH
SCHOOLS ARE THE HOT DASHBOARD
MEASURE TO KEEP TRACK OF
PERFORMANCE IN THAT AREA. IF
YOU'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
SPECIAL WITH CTE THAT LOCAL
COMMITMENT WE THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT SO THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO BUILD OFF OF THESE THINGS
AGAIN THAT HAPPENED HAPPENED IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS. BUT THE
FINAL POINT HAS OVER THE LAST
LIKE EIGHT YEARS THE STATE'S
MAIN NOTABLE INVESTMENTS TO TRY
TO GET COLLEGES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ARTICULATE THEIR
THE STATE HAS. CREATED SEVERAL
PROGRAMS THAT TRY TO GET
COLLEGES TO SIT DOWN WITH HIGH
SCHOOLS TO SAY. LET'S RUN
PROGRAMS IN THESE AREAS AND
LET'S COME TO HIGH SCHOOLS RUN
THE FIRST TWO LEVELS AND
COLLEGES THE NEXT THREE LEVELS
BUT MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN BE
ARTICULATED AND LEAD TO. AN
INDUSTRY VALUED SIR TO
THE CAT.
SO. I THINK THERE'S A WAY AGAIN
FOR THE STATE TO LEVERAGE ALL OF
THESE EFFORTS THAT IT'S MADE
OVER THE LAST. ALMOST DECADE TO
IMPROVE CITY IN THE STATE.
AND THAT'S WHAT AND THAT'S WHY
AM I WANTED YOU TO DISCUSS THAT
BECAUSE AND. HAVING BEEN A
NUMBER DISCUSSIONS WITH.
WHERE WE GOT THE NUMBER FOR?
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
.
PARTNERING WITH.
WHEN YOU'RE BACK TO OPEN DRAW
FUNNY WHEN YOU PARTNER WITH.
WITH THE COMMUNITY.
AND GET THEM INVOLVED IN
EDUCATION.
IT JUST MAKES SENSE THAT WE KNOW
NOT ALL CHILDREN ARE GOING TO GO
TO BERKELEY.
THAT SOME CHILDREN ARE GOING TO
BE GOING INTO CAREERS IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEM.
EARLY ENGAGE IN A CAREER PATH.
JUNIORS
SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS.
OUR AND PARTNERING WITH A LOT OF
THE DIFFERENT TRADES I VISITED
NUMBER THE TRADE UNIONS WHEN YOU
TALK TO THE CARPENTERS
ELECTRICIANS. PIPETTERS THE
SHEET METAL WORKERS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS THEY NEED. AS A
YOUNGER WORKFORCE THE DEPEND ON
THE AGENTS ARE LOOKING AT.
TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY SIX YEAR
OLD INDIVIDUALS GOING INTO THESE
CAREERS AND I'D LIKE TO SEE HIM
COME IN AND AT AN EARLIER AGE.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR HIM
APPRENTICESHIP FELIZ TARGET
INVOLVED IN THIS.
TO OF TO CONTINUE ON TO BECOME A
JOURNEYMAN BY THE AGE OF.
TWENTY TO YOU COULD HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE MAY BE IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
AND SO.
I THINK THIS IS JUST A.
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNNIES DOING
RELEVANCY.
OF EDUCATION WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY.
ALIGNING WITH OUR CORE
CURRICULUM.
WE WE'VE BEEN TALKING IN THE
DASHBOARD TO ADD THIS AS ELEMENT
SO IMPACTS LOOK AT IT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW YOU SEE WHAT PERCENT
OF THE CHILDREN ARE GOING TO
COLLEGE CAREER READ. COLLEGE
READY GRADUATING COLLEGE.
BUT YOU CAN ALSO SEE WHAT
PERCENT OF YOUR CHILDREN MAY
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO GO INTO
CAREER WHICH I THINK IS A GOOD
MEASUREMENT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND INCOME
EQUITY ISSUES THAT WE HAVE SO.
I WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS HEAR AN ANSWER TO A
SENATOR MORE LAST QUESTION IS
THAT THE RIGHT NUMBER. WE
ORIGINALLY HAD A PLAN TO HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
TO DO IT. OVER THREE YEARS SO
I'D BE CONTINUE INVESTMENT. OF
THREE YEAR PERIOD LEO ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION AND IF WE DO A
MATCH WHATEVER THE RATIO IS.
CONCEIVABLY YOU COULD HAVE.
TWO TO THREE MILLION BILLION
DOLLARS INTO A PROGRAM OVER
THREE YEARS WHICH WOULD THEN
HAVE LEGS AND LAST. THING BICU
HIS GREAT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE SO I'D ASK.
OF THE COMMERCE COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT.
GOING WITH THIS WE UNDERSTAND
THAT NOT ALL CHILDREN ARE GOING
TO BE.
YOU KNOW FRENCH LITERATURE
MAJORS OUT OF BERKELEY.
SOME. SOME MORE I'M SORRY MR
JIANG NOT AND WE WANT TO BE SO
SUMMER ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
WORKING HARD OUT IN THE FIELDS
AND WORKING IN THE TRADES WHICH
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. GREAT MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS SO.
IN THE DISCUSSION HAIRLIKE IS AT
STAKE WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED THAT
SHOULD BE THE FLOOR WE
ORIGINALLY REQUESTED FIVE
HUNDRED.
IF I MAY ON THE GOVERNANCE ISSUE
OUT MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT WE PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ON THEIR
REGIONAL MODEL THEY ALSO HAD A
MORE TRADITIONAL MODEL THEY'VE
MOVED TO THIS REGIONAL MODEL
BECAUSE IT REALLY HELPS.
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROGRAM
OFFERINGS ARE LINES TO THE
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF ANY
PARTICULAR REGION WE DON'T THINK
THAT K. TWELVE SHOULD BE OUTSIDE
OF THAT PROCESS AND WE DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING IN OUR
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD PRECLUDE THE
CURRICULUM ALIGNMENT THAT THE
ANALYST HAS SUGGESTED.
I'M GONNA SIR NIELSEN EXPLICIT A
FOLLOW UP ONE QUICK QUESTION ON
THAT POINT.
SO I I DID WANT TO NOTE.
THE A DISTANT WE HAD SOME
CONCERNS. REGARDING THE OUR
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE THIS SEVENTY
TWO REGIONAL CONSORTIA CREATE A
K. TWELVE SELECTION COMMITTEE.
TO DISBURSE FUNDS SO COULD YOU
ARMY GIVE US SOME BACKGROUND ON
THE I THINK THE CONCERN WAS THAT
IT WAS ANOTHER. LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY IN A LOT OF MONEY
JUST TO. MOVE MONEY.
AMBER ALEXANDER WHAT DEPARTMENT
CLARIFICATION ON THAT POINT
THERE ARE ONLY EIGHT REGIONAL
CONSORTIA SO THERETHIS WOULD BE
HAPPENING I MEAN EIGHT REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
SEVENTY TWO FIGURE THAT I
BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERENCING IS
THE SEVENTY TWO WORKFORCE
PATHWAY COORDINATORS WHICH WOULD
BE KIND OF THE REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
WITH IN THOSE REGIONS.
SO BE EIGHT REGIONAL CONSORTIA
WOULD EACH THE SET UP EIGHT KATE
FOR SELECTION COMMITTEE SO THERE
WOULD BE EIGHT SELECTION
COMMITTEES.
SO YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN
THEIR.
FICKLE THOUGH REALLY IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ARE LOCALLY
DRIVEN DECISIONS AND THAT IS WHY
THEY ARE STRUCTURED THAT WAY
WITHIN THE EIGHT REGIONS. ON THE
SELECTION COMMITTEE PURPOSE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT KEY TWELVE IS
REALLY HAVING CONTROL OVER THOSE
DECISIONS BECAUSE THERE WAS A
CONCERN THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD BE GUIDING AND THE
DECISIONS BY MOVING TO THIS
MODEL.
GREAT THANK YOU DO IN THE COULD
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
BETWEEN THE SEVENTY TWO IN THE.
GIVE A ROUGH FISCAL ESTIMATE FOR
WHAT THE WHAT THE COST WOULD BE
FOR THAT TO ORGANIZATION. THAT
SO THAT DOLLAR FIGURE THAT WE'VE
PUT FORWARD IN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WILL REMAINS WOULD BE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION.
ALLOCATED OUT TO THE CONSORTIUM
VIA THE FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE REGIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THE PROJECTED
JOB OPENINGS IN THE SEVEN TO
TWELVE EIGHTY A IN THE REGION.
AND WE HAVE DONE SOME ROUGH
PRODUCTIONS BUT.
UNTIL WE KNOW THE THE
CONSORTIUM AS ON THE COUNTY
LINES IT'LL BE HARD TO GET AN
EXACT FIGURE BUT WE WE DO
ROUGHLY.
GOSH I GOT ABOUT MY MEDICAL
FIGHT THE DEED YOU HAVE ASSISTED
YOU BUDGET FOR WHAT ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WILL GO TO.
CREATE THESE COMMITTEES AND SO
WE DID AT AND AS PART OF A MAJOR
MISSION AND ADDITIONAL TWO
MILLION THAT'S ON TOP OF THE TWO
HUNDRED THAT'S PROVIDER FOR
GRANDSON NOT SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE CONSORTIUM MINISTRY OF COSTS.
GREAT THANK YOU AND ANOTHER
OPTION RATHER THAN CREATING AN
ADMINISTRATIVE APPARATUS ABOUT
THE MONEY THAT DOESN'T ALREADY
EXIST AND YOU HAVE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ANAHEIM CD.
IS WHETHER IT'S THE STRONG WORK
FORCE OR THE SI TIENES SON OF
GRANT PROGRAM YOU COULD JUST PUT
A REQUIREMENTS THAT BY VIRTUE OF
GETTING EITHER OF THESE POTS OF
MONEY HIGH SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES
YOU NEED TO TALK WITH EACH OTHER
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOUR. COURSES
ARE LINED.
IF I JUST RESPOND TO THAT POINT
AND THERE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
THOSE TYPES OF REQUIREMENTS AND
PASSED PROGRAMS IN BOTH CAREER
PATHWAYS TRUST AND A CT
INCENTIVE GRANT.
THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THOSE BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY OUTCOMES FROM THOSE
PROGRAMS AND WE DON'T KNOW IF
THOSE INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND SO BY BRINGING IT
TO A REGIONAL LEVEL WE WILL.
MEAN SEXUALLY FORCE THAT
CONVERSATION TO BE HAPPENING
LOCALLY.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION
SENATOR NIELSEN.
ON THAT POINT I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE.
SELECTION COMMITTEE COULD BE AND
SHOULD BE SCRUTINIZED AS.
WHETHER IT WORKS VERY WELL OR
NOT. AYE I'M NOT READY TO BUY IN
A FULL TIME.
BUT I. COULD ACCEPT WERE SET
RIGHT NOW
I I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT.
THAT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD NOT.
THE WE DIRECT MONEY AT THAT THAT
WHOLE RESTRUCTURING. GAVE ME
SOME CONCERN.
AND THE MORE LOCAL.
THE BETTER.
CAREER TECHS HAD A. KIND OF A
TORTURED HISTORY.
SEEMS LIKE ABOUT THREE OR FOUR
YEARS AGO.
CRITICS WAS VERY VULNERABLE.
AND FIVE THOUSAND.
BLUE AND GOLD JACKET FUTURE
FARMERS MARCHED HERE ON THE
CAPITOL.
IT MADE A DIFFERENCE.
VENDORS CREDIT.
THE NEXT YEAR THE GOVERNOR.
STRONGLY SUPPORTED CRITIC AT.
AND IN FACT HE EXPANDED THE
INCENTIVE GRANTS.
TO THE OTHER PROGRAMS.
IN.
NOT JUST TO PROVOKE AG.
CAREER TECH MATCH BUT ALSO TO
THE REST OF CRITICAL.
IS THERE ANY.
INCENTIVE GRANT MONEY AS A PART
OF THIS PARTICULAR PLAN.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS IS THAT
RIGHT.
THIS PROGRAM IS IF SEPARATE FROM
THE C. T. INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE
EXISTING CITY I THINK GRANT
PROGRAM TO SUNSET AND. AND
ESTABLISH THIS NEW PROGRAM
WITHIN THE STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM. AND THERE IS I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE AG INCENTIVE
GRANTS THAT'S A SEPARATE PROGRAM
SEPARATE AND APART FROM CT
INCENTIVE GRANT AND WE DO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THAT. THAT'S THAT'S
A SHEPHERD THE. PROVISION IN THE
ANTICOAGULANT TIRE.
WE GOT A SONG CYCLE.
SO YOUR CONCEPT THEN IS WITH
THE MONEY STE.
DIRECTED HERE MAN.
THE LOCALS WILL HAVE ENOUGH
ABILITY.
THE P. FLEXIBLE.
AND THEREFORE WOULD NOT NEED THE
INCENTIVE GRANT IS AT THE THE
LOGIC.
I MEAN THAT'S A SEPARATE DEAL
BUT ITS ALSO PART OF THEIR
FUNDING STREAM.
SO BE AND CTS CENTER OF GRANT.
FROM ITS INCEPTION IT WAS IT WAS
MESSAGED OUT A SHORT TERM
PROGRAM TRIP TO TRANSITION TELLS
THE A FAP. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY CLEAR IN
THAT WE STRUCTURED IT THAT WAY
WITH THE.
DECREASING STATE COMMITMENT AND
THE INCREASING LOCAL MATCH
REQUIREMENT.
SO.
FROM THE GET GO IT WAS ALWAYS
ENVISIONED TO BE A THREE YEAR
PROGRAM. AT THIS PROGRAM WHILE
IT DOES HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
ELEMENTS BECAUSE WE DID HERE IN
THE FOCUS ON HIGH QUALITY CTE
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS REALLY
VALUED IN THE FIELD. WE PULLED A
LOT OF THOSE ELEMENTS IN THE
DIFFERENCE REALLY IS THAT OUR
PROGRAM IS FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY
ON CTV PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALIGNED
TO REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
FEEDING INDUSTRY DEMAND AN AREA.
WELL. I CAN SEE SOME MERIT WITH
THAT IN THE PART THE REGIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THE THE LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIPS PROGRAMS WHICH
WE COULD DIRECT.
INDIVIDUALS AND TO. THAT I THINK
THAT FIT.
I I WOULD ARGUE WHO ALONG WITH
CENTER MORE LACK FOR EVEN A
HIGHER COMMITMENT TO PROTECT AT
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT IN.
CALIFORNIA MORE SO NOW THAN
BEFORE.
AND I BRING ANOTHER ASPECT.
CAREER TECH IT.
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION.
CAREER TECH ED.
STUDENTS.
DIRECT THEMSELVES AND.
TRAINED.
CERTIFIED.
INTO CAREERS.
MANY THAT'S A CAREER TOPPER.
IN THE GREAT CAREERS.
BUT OTHERS MIGHT WANT TO ASPIRE
TO DO MORE WITHIN THAT
PARTICULAR CAREER.
OR. GO ANOTHER DIRECTION TO
IMPROVE THEM SELVES AND THEIR
OWN. FUTURE.
AT AND NOT YOU MENTIONED A BIT
AGO.
METRIC ARTICULATE AND
MATRICULATE.
I HAVE LONG. ADVOCATED.
FOR C. S. YOU AND YOU SEE TO
EMBRACE.
CAREER TECH STUDENTS.
TO ENCOURAGE THAT.
TO BE AVAILABLE.
PROGRAMS THAT CSU YOU SEE WOULD
HOLD.
FOURTH.
TO THE CAREER TECH INDIVIDUAL.
WHO HAS GONE TO THEIR CAREER IN
THEIR ESTABLISH BUT NOW THEY
WANT TO DO MORE?
I THINK SHE ISSUE IS A LITTLE
BIT INTERESTED IN THAT I DON'T
THINK.
YOU SEE AS YET.
BUT MY POINT IN ALL OF THIS AND
THE REASON FOR THAT THE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR CAREER TECH ED.
I THINK CALIFORNIA AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR OR
FINALLY VIEWING CAREER TECH AT.
AS PREMIER AND WORTHY OF SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE. NUMBER FOUR.
KINDERGARTEN PRESCHOOL AND AFTER
SCHOOL.
IN WE HAVE WAS CORTES AND MR
CABRAL FROM THAT WE KNOW YOU CAN
STE
BEGIN A TRUCK.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR CORTES FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
IT'S ON PAGE.
THIRTY SIX OF YOUR AGENDA ISSUE
FOR HAS BOTH HOUSES ACTIONS ON
KINDERGARTEN PRESCHOOL AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
NOW BOTH HOUSES INCLUDE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT
A MULTI YEAR BUDGET AGREEMENT.
THIS INCLUDES ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND FULL DAY STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS IN A RATE
INCREASE IN A COLA. AND THE
ASSEMBLY A PLAN INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION THOSE
NOTED ON PAGE THIRTY SIX.
NOW THE FIRST TWO BULLETS ARE
RELATED TO KINDERGARTEN.
THE ASSEMBLY'S PLAN INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FOR INCREASED FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN RATE.
IT AND ALSO INCLUDES A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE HIGH NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT UP FOR.
THE SILLY GRANTS FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
WITH REGARDS TO THE RATE
PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT A MAJORITY
OF KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS OFFERED
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN I'M SICK
JUST UNDER WAY IS NOT THE
BARRIER FOR. OFFERING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
I'M WITH REGARD TO THE
FACILITIES PROPOSAL WE THINK
THAT THIS COULD HELP PROMOTE A
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
AS.
AS ELEAZAR REPORT THEIR INTEREST
SAID ELEAZAR OFFER PARTY CAN OUR
GARDEN REPORT THAT THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN OFFERING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN BUT A BARRIER TO
OFFERING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
IS A FACILITY CONSTRAINTS.
NOW THE PRESCHOOL PROPOSALS ARE
THE NEXT FOUR BULLETS ON THIS ON
THIS PAGE.
THERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION FOR
ONE TIME ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FIRST A
PRE SCHOOL FACILITIES.
THEIR SIXTY MILLION FOR
ADDITIONAL SLOTS A THAN SIX
MILLION FOR ONE TIME ONE TIME
GRANTS FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION.
WITH REGARDS TO THE FACILITY
PROPOSAL FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
WE'VE HEARD FACILITIES IS A
CONSTRAINT FOR STATE PRESCHOOL.
EXPANSION.
BUT BOTH HOUSES TOOK ACTION ON
AN ITEM PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
THAT INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN MILLION FOR
EXPANSION GRANTS THAT THEY COULD
SEE PRESCHOOLS COULD USE FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
WITH REGARDS TO INCREASING SLOTS
GIVEN THAT RECENT FLOW INCREASES
HAVE GONE NOT FULLY UTILIZED.
A WE HAVE CONCERNS AT THE SLOTS
WOULD ALSO COULDN'T GO NOT FULLY
UTILIZED.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OUR CONCERN IS THAT
MAJORITY OF THE ACTIVITIES ARE
FOR THAT HAS PROPOSED FOR THIS
ONE TIME FUNDS. ARE BEING FUNDED
WITH.
ONGOING RESOURCES.
AND THE LAST BULLET ON THIS PAGE
IS A RATE INCREASE FOR THE AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND SAFETY
PROGRAM WHICH IS SEVENTY SIX
POINT THREE MILLION.
AND THAT CONCLUDESMY REMARKS
THAN HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THIS COST.
THANK YOU YES WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE'S VERSION OF THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM I'D NOTICED A
COUPLE OF AND CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE WITH.
SOME OF THE ASSEMBLY PROVISIONS.
AS NOTED AND THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION PROVIDES FIVE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL FULL DAY STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS WE WOULD NOTE
THAT TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
IDENTIFIED ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND SAVINGS IN
STATE PRESCHOOL ATTRIBUTED BACK
TO THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FISCAL
YEAR.
A OUR BELIEF IS THAT THESE ON U.
SLOTS REFLECT AT BIGGER ISSUES
THAT ARE HAPPENING LOCALLY THAT
COULD BE THINGS LIKE.
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE OR
FACILITIES AND WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD OPEN UP ELIGIBILITY
OF STEEP PRESCHOOL TO ALL
STUDENTS ATTENDING A TITLE ONE
SCHOOL.
DON'T ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THOSE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING SERVED
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE ISSUES
I'VE JUST OUTLINED.
THIS SIMPLY IS INVESTMENT OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND EACH FOR KINDERGARTEN
PRESCHOOL FACILITIES ARE
DUPLICATIVE OF OTHER PROGRAMS.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED AND BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE ADOPTED
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD BUILD CAPACITY FOR
PRE KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM THROUGH
ONE TIME INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND LOW ACCESS AREAS
OF THE STATE. GETTING BACK TO MY
PREVIOUS POINT ABOUT.
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AS WELL.
THIS SIMPLY PROVIDES A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS FOR
INCENTIVES TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO OFFER EXTENDED DAYCARE GUARD
AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT NEARLY
THREE QUARTERS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ALREADY OFFER EXTENDED
DAY KINDERGARTEN. AND THOSE THAT
DO NOT MAY HAVE OTHER REASONS
FOR NOT OFFERING AN EXTENDED
DEEP CREEK OUT.
EXCUSE ME AN EXTENDED THE
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM.
AND WE WOULD KNOW YOU KNOW WITH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WOULD PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY IS FOR DISTRICTS
THAT WANT TO OFFER SUCH PROGRAMS
TO DO SO WITHIN THEIR HEALTH FF
FUNDING.
LASTLY THE MINISTRATION DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE AUGMENTATION OF ACES
OR AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION SAFETY
PROGRAM FUNDING.
STATE ACES FUNDING IS NOT
INTENDED TO COVER THE TOTALITY
OF THE PROGRAM EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES A THIRTY THREE PERCENT
LOCAL MATCH OF THE TOTAL CRAP
WITHOUT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
BUT YOU KNOW THE ISSUE WITH
REGARD TO STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
AND AND.
THE FACT THAT IT EIGHT YEARS
AND WE STILL HAVE SPOTS THAT ARE
GOING ON USED.
IS ADMINISTRATION ARTISTS LA EL
HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT WERE INSTEAD OF CONTINUING
TO ASK WHAT'S THE GOING YOU THAT
WE CONTINUE TO DO IT EVERY YEAR.
WHAT ELSE SHOULD WE BE DOING TO
REALLY FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
BARRIER IS? IS IT IS IT AN
OUTDATED AND I HAVE I DON'T WANT
TO STAKEHOLDERS TO.
BLOW ME UP ON TWITTER BUCKET BUT
IS IT IS IT IS IT A A.
FRAMEWORK THAT DOESN'T WORK
ANYMORE I I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW
I AM NOT INTERESTED IN
CONTINUING TO FUND.
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS THE GOING
USE WHEN WHEN WE EXPAND AP SLOTS
THEY GET TAKEN UP SO I AM MORE
INTERESTED IN PUTTING MONEY INTO
SLOTS THAT WILL BE UTILIZED SO
WHAT'S THE DEAL WITH THE
PRESCHOOL.
THANK YOU SENATOR AJUSCO HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SO WE KNOW THAT NOT ALL FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN THE STATE HAVE
ACCESS TO STATE PRESCHOOL.
AS YOU KNOW I LOOK AT IT IT'S
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED IT'S
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED THAT'S
CORRECT AND AND WHEN I SAY THAT
I SEE STATE PRESCHOOL WHICH WE
KNOW WE ALSO HAVE HEAD START
DOLLARS WE KNOW THAT THEIR OTHER
LOCAL PROGRAMS AS WELL SO. WE
KNOW THAT NOT ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN THE STATE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
IN THE CURRENT STRUCTURE TAXES
THOSE SERVICE TO US.
WE WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
DATA FROM A LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCILS THAT GIVES US A SENSE
OF YOU KNOW WHO'S BEING SERVED
AND WHO'S NOT RIGHT.
OUR SENSE OF BASED ON THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL AS.
INFORMATION WE'VE RECEIVED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
BASED ON PAST RFP PROCESSES TO
PUT THESE THOUGHTS OUT. ON THEIR
VARIETY OF FACTORS ONE OF THE
FACTORS AND THAT WE ARE ARM IS
MOST CONCERNING TO US IS THAT
THERE ARE SOME. AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT WOULD LIKE TO DRAW
DOWN THESE FUNDS BUT THEY HAVE
NOT HISTORICALLY HAD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE I MEAN NOT JUST
FACILITIES. BUT.
STAFF TRAINED STAFF.
TO SUPPORT A TITLE FIVE
REGULATED PROGRAM.
SO EXPENSIVE AND COMPLICATED TO
DEVELOP.
CORRECT IF IT'S FIVE IS NOT YES
IS COMPLEX APPROPRIATELY FELL
YES AND. YES SO.
EAT WHAT WE'VE DONE IS A IN
PUTTING IN THE HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION FOR THE INCLUSIVE
REALLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM WE HAVE PRIORITIZED
PRIORITIZE LOW ACCESS AREAS OF
THE STATE. WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ABOUT HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FUNDS GO TO
WHAT YOU KNOW WE WOULD FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM CALL PRESCHOOL
DESERT'S. UP AND WE KNOW THAT
THOSE EXIST.
SPECIFICALLY IN PLACES LIKE
INLAND EMPIRE.
IT TO ENSURE THAT YOU WERE
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE THERE.
SO THAT THE FOLKS THAT YOU KNOW
HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN ABLE TO DRAW
DOWN AT THESE FUNDS.
AND NO LONGER HAVE A NEED FOR
THEM AND THAT THEY'RE NOT THE
ONLY ONES THAT ACTUALLY CAN
COMPETE FOR THOSE FUNDS SO
THAT'S WHERE YOU'LL TARGET YOUR
THREE THOUSAND THAT YOU PROVIDE
FOR IN THE BUDGET.
SO IN OUR CONVERSATIONS THAT
PART OF EDUCATION ON HOW WE'RE
GONNA PUT OUT THE ONE TIME FUNDS
AND. THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
THEY HAVE NOT ONLY.
TEEP PRESCHOOL SLOT THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE TO FOLKS WHO ARE NOW
OPENING UP AND NEWS NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR KIDS BUT ALSO
SOME GENERAL CHILDCARE AS WELL.
SO THE IDEA IS THAT YOU WORK
WITH DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WERE NOT ONLY. YOU KNOW BUILDING
WE'VE THAT ONE TIME FUNDS THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE KIDS BUT THEY
WERE SAYING AND BY THE WAY WE'RE
GONNA PARA WITH SOME ON GOING
FUNDS FOR SLOTS SO THAT YOU CAN
UTILIZE.
THAT INTEREST.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE RAISES THAT THESE NEW SLOTS
HAVE BEEN GOING TO ELEAZAR
BECAUSE IT'S A FULL DAY SLOT
THAT IS USED ENTIRELY WITH
PROPOSITION NINETY MONEY.
BUT THERE'S ALSO ELEAZAR AT
ALSO OFFERS THE PRESCHOOL BUT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO USE
THE FULL DAY SLOT BECAUSE A FULL
DAY SLOT FOR A NON ELEAZAR USE
WITH THE COMBINATION OF
PROPOSITION NINETY AND ON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
SO ONE THING THAT WE SAY IS
THAT.
MAYBE ALL OF STATE PRESCHOOL
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WOULD
HELP NINE ELLIE IS ALSO ACCESS
SOME OF THE SPENDING.
I WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
FARM IT WILL MORE QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO.
.
THIS BECAUSE HE MADE A COMMENT
WITH REGARD TO A SYSTEM IT IT'S
NOT YOUR EXPECTATION THAT IT.
I DON'T MISQUOTE YOU THAT IF THE
FULLY FUNDED BY GENERAL FUND.
COULD YOU ELABORATE AND THEN
TELL ME WHAT.
WHAT OPTIONS YOU THINK THEY HAVE?
QUITE SIMPLY CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES AS THIRTY THREE PERCENT
LOCAL MATCH SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VIEWPOINT IS
AGAIN.
YOU CAN UTILIZE YOUR LCF FAST TO
COME UP WITH THAT LOCAL MATCHING
COMPONENT.
AND THAT WOULD.
REQUIRE THAT.
THE LOCALS.
BUT STEP UP IN FUND THEIR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
GOT IT OKAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I. ON
PAGE THIRTY SIX.
I'M JUST TRYING TO CONNECT THE
DOTS I THINK I'VE FOUND.
POLICE THREE OF THE ASSEMBLY
NUMBERS THE ONE FIFTY THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FIRST.
AND THE SEVENTY SIX MILLION BUT
I'M I'M NOT FINDING ON THE LA
DOES REPORT ON PAGE ELEVEN.
THE OTHER NUMBERS FOR THE
HUNDRED MILLION.
COURT FACILITY GRANTS IN THE
SIXTY.
MILLION FOR THE ADDITIONAL FIVE
THOUSAND THE SIX MILLION.
FOR THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION SO I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF. YOU TIME ACROSS FOOTER IFI
MADE THE FUNDING SOURCES ARE
DIFFERENT THOSE ARE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS VERSUS WHAT'S IN THE
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
SO DO I HAVE ANY ANYTHING AT ALL
TO LOOK AT THAT WOULD MATCH UP
WITH THE.
THE ISSUE FOR PRINT OUT.
WHERE DO I GO GOT THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET?
PROVISION DO I HAVE DROPPED TO
LOOK THERE ARE I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT PAGE NINETEEN.
I MIGHT BE ON.
THEY LITTLE EASIER TO.
SEE SOME OF THE DETAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALL DIG
INTO THAT. THANK YOU.
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ISSUE OF
FIRE PRESCHOOL SLOTS THAT ARE
NOT.
FULLY BEING UTILIZED I THINK.
IT'S BROADLY ACKNOWLEDGED BY
OUR BUDGETING AND A POLICY
MAKING.
JUST HOW IMPORTANT.
OF A PRESCHOOL IS.
AND NOT A CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND.
IT IT IT SOUNDS LIKE WE DON'T.
FULLY HAVE A GRASP ON WHAT THE
GAPS ARE AND TO. HOW WE CAN BEST
SPEND THE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE SO I AM WONDERING WHY WE'RE
NOT TARGETING SOME MONEY AT IT?
LOOKING DEEPER INTO THAT AND
DEVELOPING A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN THAT WE CAN PUT INTO EFFECT.
THAT WAS BLOOM CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU I'M.
FIVE A COUPLE DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS WILL
FIRST ON THIS ISSUE OF THE STATE
PRESCHOOL.
SLOTS AND IF IF WE WERE AT THE
POINT THAT WE COULD FULLY FUND.
THE STATE PRESCHOOL.
PLACEMENT FOR EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE
HOURS THAT FAMILIES NEED.
THEN I THINK THIS WOULD BE THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR US TO GO IN
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT YEAR.
SCHEMES ME SENATE BUDGET YOUR
NOTED.
IS THAT THAT WHILE. WELL I THINK
ALL OF US VALUE.
THE THAT NOT ONLY THE ROLE OF
STATE PRESCHOOL BUT.
.
ITS OFFERINGS.
IT'S NOW NOT.
IT'S NOT EVERYWHERE.
IT'S NOT AN ADEQUATE HOURS.
AND SO FAMILIES ARE NOT
UTILIZING IT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
PROVIDED IT ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SO.
IN THIS INTERIM I THINK WE NEED
TO.
STEP BACK FROM THAT PERHAPS GET
YOU KNOW ASSIST THAT MISTER
BLOOM IS REQUESTED.
BRITTANY BUT IN THIS INTERIM
RATHER THAN TRYING TO DIRECT
MORE MONEY TO STAY PRESCHOOL
BEFORE WE FULLY FIGURED OUT. HOW
TO ADEQUATELY
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S?
?
THE SLOTS ARE GETTING TAKEN UP
IN PROVIDING FOR ENOUGH KIDS.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR THE KIDS
IN THE WAYS THAT WE KNOW.
THERE UTILIZING WHICH IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE WHAT WILL
DISCUSS IN ITEM FIVE.
SO.
THAT'S WHERE I AM MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS SENATE'S
APPROACH.
ON THE STATE PRESCHOOL SIDE.
NOW I HAVE A COUPLE OF OTHER
QUESTIONS THOUGH THAT ARE ON
OTHER ITEMS OF THIS FIRST.
IT'S REFLECTED IN OUR MATERIALS
THAT.
A LARGE NUMBER OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE NOW OFFERING FULL
TIME.
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN BUT IT
ALSO INDICATES THAT THERE'S
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT. MIGHT NOT
BUT THE.
THE THE WAY THE MATERIALS ARE
PRESENTED IS THAT WE DON'T NEED
TO.
TO EITHER PROVIDE MORE FUNDING
OR PUSH FOR THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN BECAUSE.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S SORT OF
ASSUMPTION IS LIKE BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S BEING PROVIDED.
WHAT I WANT TO GET IS SOME OF
THE DATA ON WHAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AREN'T
BECAUSE WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THAT IT'S
TENCH LEAVE THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT MOST NEED FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN? ME NEITHER THE
FAMILIES THAT MAY NOT BE
PROVIDING IT
BECAUSE OF OTHER RESOURCE
CONSTRAINTS.
AND.
IN SO THAT'S.
BEFORE I CAN ACCEPT THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO EXTEND THIS JUST
BECAUSE TWENTY PERCENT OF
DISTRICTS MAY NOT. BE ARE THE
ONLY ONES NOT I'D LIKE TO KNOW.
TO GET SOME DATA ON WHAT ARE
THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
AREN'T.
THEN FINALLY ON THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
.
THE INFORMATION I'VE BEEN
RECEIVING IT MIGHT THIS IN MY
OFFICE IS THAT.
BETWEEN COST OF LIVING INCREASES
AND OF COURSE THE LEGITIMATE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES NOT ONLY
THAT THE STATE HAS APPROVED BUT
SOME OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE APPROVED. THAT ARE ON A
FASTER TIME SKILLED IN THE
STATE'S.
HAVE PUT ALL MANY OF OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS NEW POSITION
WHERE THEY CAN'T KEEP UP.
AND
WHAT I UNDERSTAND IS THERE'S
POTENTIALLY UP TO A THIRD OF THE
OF OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE. THAT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE.
DOT THE CURRENT RATES.
AND I THINK WE RECOGNIZE THAT
JUST LIKE.
PRESCHOOL THAT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE OUR OUR.
NORMAL OUR FIRST SECOND THIRD
GRADE THEIR QUOTE UNQUOTE ALL
DAY BUT THEY'RE NOT A FULL
WORKING DAY THEY'RE NOT A
FAMILIES WORKING DAY AND SO OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS VERY MUCH.
MAKE UP FOR THAT. IN ADDITION TO
ADDING IN RICHMOND SUCH.
.
SO I.
I AM INTERESTED IN UNDERSTANDING
BETTER. THE THIS GAP FOR THAT
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE.
DESCRIBING AND ALSO POTENTIALLY.
IN THE IN THE LANDING ON IT
WHATEVER WE LAND ON ULTIMATELY
IN THIS BUDGET. MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
CAN'T.
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
MISTRUST.
THANK YOU I'D JUST LIKE TO.
.
STATE MY SUPPORT OF WHAT WE JUST
WE JUST HEARD FROM THE SENATOR.
I THINK SHE'S EXACTLY RIGHT TERM
WE KNOW ALL THOSE SLOTS ARE
BEING USED AND THAT'S WHY.
IT'S ONE BUDGET ITEM UNDERNEATH
THE ASSEMBLY SAYS
SIX MONEY ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR COUNTY HOUSE EDUCATION IS IS
DISTRICTS AND EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM TO FIND OUT THE PROBLEM
IS SO WE CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF
IT.
.
I WOULD JUST ALSO LIKE ADDED
ANOTHER ITEM I NOTICED EARLIER
ON THE ON OUR LIST YEAR.
IS A HUNDRED BILLION ONE TIME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
FOR FOR SILLY GRANTS FOR SCHOOL
BASED.
YOU KNOW I TALKED TO MY
SUPERINTENDENTS LOT OF THEM ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN GOING IN
THIS DIRECTION. BECAUSE WE HAVE
REALLY BURDEN THEM SIGNIFICANTLY.
WELL LOCAL FUNDING IN ALL CAPS
IN CT <c.green> AND EVERYTHING ELSE.</c>
YOU KNOW COMMON CORE IN OUR SAY
NO GO DO THIS TOO. AND SO
THEY'RE SAYING WELL YOU KNOW.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO WHEN I VISIT.
AND I WANNA MAKE.
THE POINT HERE.
QUALITY.
QUALITY PROGRAMS THAT ONCE HE
CHILDREN WAREHOUSE BECAUSE I
FOCUS A LOT OF IT TO HAVE A CITY.
THIS DATA IN OCEANSIDE TO CITIES
THAT HAVE LARGE LATINO
POPULATIONS.
AND. THE EARLY A. PRE PRESCHOOL
A CAN OF OUR VOTERS ARE NEARLY
AS. GOOD AS SOME OF MY MORE
FLUENT AREAS LIKE IN SEASON
CARLSBAD AND I SEE THESE YOUNG
CHILDREN BE AND. AND THIS IS A
ROCKY TERMS ON A STRIP.
THEY'RE BEING WAREHOUSED
YOU KNOW JUST THERE'S BEEN PUT
IN THERE AND NOT GIVING THE FULL
EARLY COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT THAT
IS BACK YOUNG CHILDREN WE SAVE.
SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THESE.
NON LA A PRESCHOOLS BECAUSE A
LOT OF THEM.
OUR NYACK ACCREDITED.
THEY'RE VERY HIGH PERFORMING
I'VE MADE THIS STATEMENT BEFORE
IN THE MILITARY.
WE HAVE VERY GOOD PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS
BECAUSEWE RECOGNIZE OF BOTH
PARENTS ARE PROBABLY WORKING
PARENTS ARE DEPLOYED.
OTHER STRESSES GOING ON INTO
FAMILIES BECAUSE OF. COMBAT AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT KIDS GO
THROUGH.
.
BUT DOES CHILDREN ARE THE
HIGHEST PERFORMANCE SCHOOL DIST
SCHOOLS IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BECAUSE OF THE EARLY DEVELOPMENT
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT FOR
CHILDREN AND SUPPORTERS
STRUCTURES.
THAT'S WHY THOSE ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
AND I JUST LIKED ALSO STE AS
MAKE A STATEMENT THAT THE. MONEY
TO ASSEMBLY PUT IN HERE FOR
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION SAFETY
PROGRAMS. IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
I WAS HONORED LAST WEEK TO.
.
RECOGNIZE A YOUNG LADY WHO WAS
AT THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
PARTNERS OSHITA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM.
SHE WON THE.
.
THE US STATE PROGRAM FOR A
SPEECH.
IS GOING OUT TO THE NATIONALS.
.
THERE ARE GREAT THINGS HAPPEN IN
THESE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WHEN.
THESE.
.
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS LIKE YMCA
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB WHATEVER OUR
WORKLOADS SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ENSURE OUR KIDS ARE TAKING CARE
PLUS YOU GET THE COLOR BECAUSE.
SALLY SO MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BODY GOES IN THE OF GANGS
AND THEY DO THINGS THAT WERE NOT
VERY HAPPY WITH.
BUT THIS IS A SAFE PLACE WHERE
KIDS CAN GO AND BE TAKEN CARE OF
IT PARENTS HAVE GOOD SENSE SO.
I'D ASK YOU TO LOOK AT THE AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION.
UNDERSTAND THAT WE PUT MONEY SIX
MILLION TO LOOK AT WHAT THE REAL
NEEDS.
AND AND IF WE DO GO THIS WAY.
NOT JUST SCHOOL BASE BUT ALSO
NON. BELLY A PRESCHOOL.
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU ARE.
MR ABDULLAH.
THANK YOU.
.
SOMETIMES I LOOK AROUND AND
REALIZE I'M MAY BE THE ONLY ONE
WHO HAS PRE SCHOOL AGED KIDS
WHOSE HERE ON CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE AND MAYBE THAT'S WHY I
WANT TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE.
HERE TODAY BUT.
HAVING A TO FIVE AND SIX YEAR
OLD AND SEEING THE LIGHT SWITCH
THAT TURNS ON INSIDE OF HIM THAT
HAPPENS WITH EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE
ASSEMBLY IS SO INTERESTED IN
FUNDING THIS PROGRAM.
I GUESS I'M A BIT FRUSTRATED TO
HEAR THAT THERE IS A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION AND I'M USE SLOTS
FROM SIXTEEN. SEVENTEEN AND WITH
THE REGIONAL VARIATIONS THAT WE
SEE.
I'M WONDERING IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS ANY INSIGHTS ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE.
REGIONAL VARIATIONS AND TO
ENSURE THAT WERE TURNING ON MORE
LIGHT SWITCHES FOR CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS OUR.
THANK YOU.
SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE'VE PROPOSED HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ONE TIME INFRASTRUCTURE. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPENING UP NEW
SLOTS FOR STATE PRESCHOOL AT
REALLY IT'S FOR ANY AND AT
PROGRAMS IT FOR CHILDREN FOR WHO
ARE ZERO THREE FIVE.
SMALLER THE EDUCATION WE THINK
THAT'S A GOOD START.
AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO IN TERMS OF INCREASING
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES WITH THOSE
FUNDS.
ARE WE ADDRESSING THE REGIONAL
VARIATIONS THAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED
AMONGST THE.
INLAND EMPIRE I'M SURE WE HAVE
SOME OF THOSE DESERT'S WITHIN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL AND
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THE FUNDS
ARE BEING DIRECTED WHERE WE HAVE
THE GREATEST.
THE PRIORITY AND THAT'S PROVIDED
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
THAT PROGRAM DOES PRIORITIZE
WHAT WE WOULD CALL LOW ACCESS
AREAS.
AND DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION TO LOOK AT DATA THAT'S
COLLECTED BY LOCAL CONTROL A
SITE LOCAL PLANNING COUNCILS.
WHICH
THAT HAVE THIS DATA I'M TO
ENSURE THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
PRIORITIZED TOWARDS THOSE LORAX
LISTENERS.
I'M AT MY LAST TWO CENTS HERE
BUT RURAL CALIFORNIA TENDS TO
GET FORGOTTEN IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND.
MY HOPE.
WE CAN MAKE SURE THEIR VOICES
ARE HEARD HERE TO.
THINK.
THANK YOU ON I I DID WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR SCARES
POINT AROUND A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN. WHO ARE CURRENTLY
AND WE FUND FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN IS NOT CORRECT?
I MEAN I I'M SORRY.
.
I BELIEVE YOUR QUESTION IS HOW
DO WE FUNDED.
.
I. DON'T NO MY QUESTION IS IS.
DOES EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHETHER THEY OFFER FULL DAY OR
HALF DAY KINDERGARTEN GET THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY PER STUDENT
THAT'S.
SO EVERY DISTRICT REGARDLESS OF
HOW MANY HOURS THEY'RE BEING
OFFERED IS BEING PAID THE SAME.
THAT'S CORRECT. ON SO FOR TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE DISTRICTS.
THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO TAKE THE
MONEY FOR FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
BUT NOT OFFER FULL TO CAN CARD
IS THAT CORRECT.
IF THAT'S SO I GUESS MIKE MY
QUESTION IS IS ON.
GIVEN THE SITUATION THE HOUSES
BOTH DELEO AND FINANCIAL BE.
CUT THOSE DISTRICTS THE TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT THAT OFFER AREN'T
OFFERING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
OR DO WE NEED TO DO SOME
AUGMENTATION SO THAT THEY CAN
OFFER FOLLICULAR.
AND SO WE DID.
.
RIGHT.
SMALL REPORT ON THIS ISSUE.
IN FEBRUARY THEY QUESTION BEING
WHAT ARE THE COST DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN FULL THEN PARTY PROGRAMS
WE FOUND. ACTUALLY RATHER
SURPRISINGLY THAT THERE AREN'T
THAT SIGNIFICANT COST
DIFFERENCES THIS
MIGHT BE A LITTLE SURPRISING BUT
IF YOU'D BREAK DOWN WHATARE THE
COST ELEMENTS IN A KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM.
A LOT OF THEM ARE THINGS LIKE.
.
CLASSROOM SPACE MATERIALS
ADMINISTRATION WHICH ARE ARE
ALREADY SPREAD ACROSS A NUMBER
OF CHILDREN.
OFTENTIMES OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS ON A PER CHILD BASIS.
THEY'RE NOT VERY SIGNIFICANT
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT COST IS THE
COST OF THE TEAM
SALARY.
SO YOU'D SAY THEORETICALLY.
PART DAY PROGRAM COULD BE
SAVING A LOT OF MONEY IF IT WERE
I'M PAYING ITS PARTY TEACHERS
LESS IF IT WAS EMPLOYING THEM.
ON A PART TIME BASIS OR IF THEIR
PARTY TEACHERS WERE TEACHING TWO
CLASSES PER DAY HOWEVER WE FIND
THAT THE FIRST TWO OPTIONS ARE
EXCEEDINGLY RARE IT IT'S RARE
FOR TEACHERS TO BE EMPLOYED ON A
PART TIME BASIS OR TO BE PAID
BLESSED.
IF THE INSTRUCTOR PARTLY BECAUSE
FROM AND IT'S ACTUALLY AGAINST
STATE LAW TERRIERS FINE HAVING
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN. SO CD WAS
CONTRACTED TO DO A STUDY OF
EXACTLY THAT QUESTION IN THEIR
SURVEY.
RESPONSES INDICATED THAT AMONG.
DISTRICTS ARE CURRENTLY ONLY
OFFERING PARTY PROGRAM MOST OF
THEM ARE INTERESTED IN OFFERING
A FULL DAY PROGRAM. OF BUT MOST
CITE A LACK OF FACILITY SPACES
THEIR PRIMARY BARRIER.
SO BASED ON THAT CD STUDY THEY
FOUND THAT.
THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OR SO
ROUGH PREFER PERCENT OF.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
DON'T OFFER FULLY CONCURRENT
THEY WE MIGHT BE INTERESTED IF
THEY HAD. SOME SUPPORTING TO
BUILD OUT FACILITIES SO HE WAS A
LACK OF CROSS.
THAT'S CORRECT.
FINANCE.
AND WE BELIEVE THE ANALYST HAS.
ACCURATELY IDENTIFIED AND SOME
ISSUES AROUND FULL DAY.
OKAY SO. WOULD YOU. DO THINK WE
BETTER OFF OFFERING MONEY FOR
FACILITIES TO GET THE FULL DAY
OR SHOULD WE.
CUT THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT DOES
IT DOESN'T SEEM FAIR THAT WE'RE
GIVING. DISTRICTS MONEY.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT OFFERING
THAT SERVICE.
I THINK THE ELSES RAISED A GOOD
POINT WITCHES.
AND MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
PEOPLE ARE THE COST
AND EVEN FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO ARE NOT OFFERING A
FULL DAY THEIR COST STRUCTURE IS
REALLY NOT MUCH DIFFERENCE.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE THAT WE HAVE
A SIMILAR APPROACH TO BOTH
PRESCHOOL AND KINDERGARTEN WHICH.
THESE AREAS THAT THE STATE WORD
THESE ARE BEING OFFERED THERE
ARE.
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES SOMETIMES
REAL INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES LIKE
FACILITIES OTHER TIMES IT
STAFFING.
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE
REDUCING THE THE FUNDING AMOUNT
WOULD HAVE THE DESIRED IMPACT.
THE DISTANCE LIKE THIS THERE'S
UNIVERSAL AGREEMENT THAT
ACTUALLY. PROVIDING
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT MIGHT.
BAGHDAD AND THAT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
YES.
THANK YOU. SERVICE CLERK.
THANK YOU.
.
THE.
CONFERENCE
CHAIR FOR TAG FURTHER ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS AND I WAS.
LESS.
SPECIFIC IN MY COMMENTS ENACT
ITS IT.
DOZEN OUR MATERIALS POINT OUT
THAT THE.
.
BELIAU IS REYES THAT.
THE.
THAT THEY FEEL THAT THE RATE
DIFFERENTIAL.
THE LACK OF A RATE DIFFERENTIAL
WAS NOT INCENTIVIZING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE PARDEE OVER
FULL DAY. AND THAT'S THE ADDING
A HIGHER RATE ACROSS THE BOARD
WOULD SIMPLY JUST PROVIDED VOTE
MORE FUNDING TO PART OR RATHER.
FIND MORE THOSE WHO WERE ALREADY
PROVIDING IT IN DOES.
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ADDRESS WIRED TWENTY
PERCENT ART BUT I THINK THAT'S
REALLY THE ISSUE IS WISER TWENTY
PERCENT NOT.
AND WHAT ARE THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHAT'S THE YOU KNOW
JUST KNOWING TWENTY PERCENT.
DON'T DOESN'T GIVE US ENOUGH
INFORMATION.
KNOWING WHAT.
THE DISTRICTS IS GOING TO GIVE
US MORE INFORMATION ABOUT ARE
THEY. ARE DISTRICTS WOULD THAT
ARE.
.
YOU KNOW HAVE THE HIGHEST.
PERCENT OF.
SPECIAL ED KIDS AND SO THAT'S
THE HAVE OTHER FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS ON THEM OR YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THESE THIS PROFILE.
AND. BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE US TO
THE GET TO THE POINT WHERE ALL
OF ARE DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN BUT I
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO BUT.
COMPLICATE OUR FUNDING ACROSS
THE BOARD IF WE ARE YOU HAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
BUT DO YOU WANT TO SEE WHAT IT
IS THAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET
THEM ALL TO SO. APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS YOU ASK.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WITHIN
THE NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE
FACILITY INVESTMENTS ARE GREAT
USE OF ONE TIME FUNDS BECAUSE
THEY REALLY ARE ONE TIME IN
NATURE.
AND AND I WOULD OFFER THAT THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
BACK TO THE LA ALL I'M STILL
CONFUSED ABOUT WHY FACILITIES
WOULD BE THE LIMITING FACTOR ON
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN BECAUSE
YOU WOULD THINK THAT IF YOU'RE
ALREADY OFFERING. PARDEE
KINDERGARTEN YOU'VE GOT THE
CLASSROOM THERE
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE ISSUES A
PASSING OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT I.
KNOW THAT TO EXPLICATE THE ISSUE
OF LAMAR.
IT WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS IN A
DISTRICT THAT OFFERS A PARTY
PROGRAM IS THAT IN A SINGLE
CLASSROOM THERE WILL BE A
MORNING KINDERGARTEN CLASS AND.
AFTERNOON CLASS SO THEY IF THAT
DISTRICT WOULD DO TRANSITION TO
A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN THEY
WOULD NEED TWICE AS.
CLASSES.
THANK YOU.
LOOK. AT AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THERE ARE SPECIFIC BUILDING CODE
STANDARDS FOR KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS
SAID THAT THE OTHER CONSTRAINING
FACTOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COLONEL.
.
IT ENDED JUST A A NOTE ON THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL DON'T HAVE
OBVIOUSLY ARE SPEAKER. UP
TOGETHER BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ARE WE GOT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY FROM.
IN PARTICULAR SOME OF THE HARD
TO SERVE AREAS BECAUSE THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND IN OUR OUR
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS REALLY DRIVEN.
TO I'LL TRY TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR GREATER STATE PRESCHOOL
PARTICIPATION AS WELL SO I WOULD
JUST MAKE THAT NOTE.
SENATE MORE LUCK.
THANK YOU MISTER AT THANKS FOR
REFER ME AGE NINETEEN I'M STILL
NOT ABLE TO TIE IN SOME NUMBERS.
I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF FIVE.
MAYBE BEFORE WE VOTE I CAN GET
SOME BETTER.
INFORMATION SO I COULD CAN
ACROSS BUT JUST TO.
MAYBE IF THE LA OKAY KINDA
GILMORE DETAILER WHOEVER
PREPARED THE.
ISSUE REPORTS THAT. WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF WE GET
IT DONE WHATEVER YOU MAY THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
.
SO NIELSEN.
THE.
THE PRE KINDERGARTEN.
.
ISSUE.
HOW MANY NOW OUR ROLE IN IN THE
PRE KINDERGARTEN?
OTHER MANY.
STUDENTS.
SORRY I AM IF YOU DON'T MIND I
CAN AND TAKE THAT. ELEMENT SO
DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU MEAN BY PRE
KINDERGARTEN. THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
CHILDREN PRIOR TO KINDERGARTEN
ONE THIS TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN I BELIEVE ARE THE
MOST RECENT ESTIMATES SHOW THAT
AT TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
ETA IS SOMEWHERE AROUND EIGHTY
THOUSAND.
WE ALSO HAVE STATE PRESCHOOL.
AND WE FUND STATE PRESCRIBE
LEVER ON HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN ON I BELIEVE
ACTUAL ATTENDANCE IS A LITTLE
BIT CLOSER TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THERE'S ALSO HEAD START AS A
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
AND THEY'RE NOT GREAT RECENT
NUMBERS ON THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE SERVED AT OUR
OF PRESCHOOL AGE IN HEAD START.
BUT IT SHOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN
THE REALM OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
AND THE ONE THING THAT WE CAN'T
TELL IS TO WHAT EXTENT THERE IS
OVERLAP.
BETWEEN CHILDREN WHO BENEFIT
FROM MULTIPLE PROGRAMS WE KNOW
THAT I'M A CHILD WHO'S AT THAT
IN TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
CAN'T GENERATE FUNDING FOR
ANOTHER PROGRAM HOWEVER WE DO
KNOW THAT I MANY PROVIDERS WILL
BLEND TOGETHER HEAD START AND
STATE PRESCHOOL FUNDS. TO
PROVIDE A FULL DAY OF CARE FOR A
CHILD.
AS WELL AS STATE PRESCHOOL WITH
OTHER CHILD CARE PROGRAMS.
SO IT'S DIFFICULT FOR US NORTH
THE OVERLAP IS BUT AT THOSE ARE
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE NUMBERS
THAT I I KNOW OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD I DON'T KNOW IF THAT LEO
HAS ANYMORE. AND SPECIFICS.
A A YOU DON'T COME IT DELEO.
NO NOT AT THIS TIME OKAY THAT'S
ALMOST JIM.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO.
FURTHER COMMENTS WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. CHILDCARE.
YEAH.
ISSUE FIVE.
AIRPORT HAS WITH LA O. SO I'M
ISSUE FIVE START ON PAGE THIRTY
EIGHT OF YOUR AGENDA AND IT
BEGINS A DISCUSSION ON BOTH
HOUSES PLANS FOR CHILD CARE
SPENDING. NOW BOTH HOUSES PLANS
INCLUDE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS I'M IN THIS AREA
BUT ALSO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS IN BOTH GENERAL
AND FEDERAL FUNDS. THE PRIMARY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES IS THE SENATE INCLUDES IN
THEIR PLAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MILLION OF RECENTLY
ALLOCATED OR NEW FEDERAL FUNDS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY'S OR WE JUMP INTO THE DIFFERENCES
OF EACH HOUSES PLAN FOR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS.
I WOULD NOTE YOU KNOW TWO
THINGS IN THE FIRST IS THAT THE
STATE IS NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW GOVERNING CHILDCARE.
WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A PLAN
ON OR A COST ESTIMATE ABOUT WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO GET IN
COMPLIANCE. AND THE SECOND IS
THERE'S NOT CLARITY OF THESE NEW
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE ONE TIME OR
ONGOING WE LIKELY WON'T HAVE
CLARITY ON THIS ISSUE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
OF THE NEW FEDERAL FUNDS BOTH
HOUSES SPEND THE SAME AMOUNT ON
CHILDCARE SLOTS.
THE MAJOR DIFFERENCE BEFORE YOU
IS AT THE SENATE ALLOCATES A
HUNDRED MORE MILLION TO CD
SO THAT THE DEPARTMENT COULD GET
IN COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS ADDED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. THE STATE CURRENTLY
HAS WAIVERS FOR SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ARE SET TO
EXPIRE OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
THE FOR THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
IN THE SENATE PLAN CD <c.green> WILL</c>
SUBMIT A PLAN ON HOW THEY WILL
SPEND THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THEN WITH SUBMITTED TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BY BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THE REMAINING FUNDS OF THIS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION NOT USE FOR
COMPLIANCE WOULD BE USED FOR NEW
SLOTS.
SO THE SENATE ALSO USES NEW
FEDERAL FUNDS TO MEET THE
REQUIRED MINIMUM QUALITY
SPENDING LEVEL. AND WITH REGARDS
TO THE ASSEMBLY PLAN THEIR PLAN
ALLOCATES FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
SLOTS THE SAME LEVEL AS THE
SENATE PLAN.
AND THEY ALSO SPEND ON THESE
FEDERAL FUNDS ON A VARIETY OF
ONE TIME AUGMENTATIONS TARGETED
AT IMPROVING QUALITY OF PROGRAMS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY PLAN LEAVES A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDS AND SPENT.
WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
SENATE'S PLAN BECAUSE WE THINK
IT MAKES SENSE TO SET ASIDE
FUNDING FOR COMPLIANCE.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND A MOCK A
MODIFICATION TO THE SENATE PLAN
INSTEAD OF THE RIVER REMAINDER
OF THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION SET
ASIDE FOR COMPLIANCE AND NOT
AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO SLOTS IF
CD <c.green> TO SET A DATE</c>
DESIGNATES THAT THEY DON'T NEED
THIS HUNDRED MILLION. ON THAT IS
THAT THE FUNDS THEY DON'T
DESIGNATE THAT THEY NEED FOR
COMPLIANCE WOULD BE CARRIED OVER
THROUGH THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR.
AND WE THINK HEARING THESE FUND
OVER WOULD HELP MITIGATE THE
REST OF WHETHER THIS IS ONETIME
ONGOING FUNDING.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DISCUSSED. THANK YOU I
JUST KNOW THIS IS ONE OF THE
AREAS OF THE BUDGET WHICH WE'VE
MADE A RATHER SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE'VE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR EARLY
EDUCATION CHILDCARE PROGRAMS BY
MORE THAN ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN THE MAY REVISION WE INCLUDED
A TOTAL INCREASE OF A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE. FULLY
FUNDING PRIOR YOUR POLICY
CHANGES AND RELATED CASELOAD
INCREASES AGREED TO WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. WE WOULD KNOW IN
THE ANNALS HAS TALKED ABOUT THE
FEDERAL CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT FUNDS.
THE TIMING OF THE NOTIFICATION
OF THE GRANT FUNDS DIDN'T ALIGN
WITH OUR RELEASE OF THE MAY
REVISE SO THERE'S A SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE THERE WE WOULD NOTE
THAT SUBSEQUENT.
IN SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE LEARNED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
RECEIVED GUIDANCE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT TO EXPECT
THESE FUNDS BE ON FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN. SO WE
WOULD CHEST I KNOW CAUTION IN
USING THESE FUNDS IN PARTICULAR
FOR ANY ON GOING PURPOSES BASED
ON THAT GUIDANCE.
THANK YOU COMBAT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SOURCE COULD.
THANK YOU I'M.
I MEAN THE FEDS ARE JUST LIKE US
THEY PROVE BUDGET FOR A YEAR BUT
THERE.
.
THAT EXPANSION.
THE FEDERAL CBGB SPAN XIN.
IN THAT BASE FUNDING.
THIS WASN'T THE FIRST YEAR OF IT
CORRECT.
SO. I GUESS I'M.
LESS CONCERNED ABOUT.
ANY FEDERAL MONEY WE HAVE
WHETHER THEY WARN US OR NOT
MIGHT TURN INTO ONE TIME.
BUT GIVEN THAT THIS HAS NOT BEEN.
I'M NOT AS CONCERNED ABOUT IT
BEING PERCEIVED AS ONE TIME ONLY.
AND I THINK THAT.
WHATEVER WE CAN USE TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT ARE.
ABLE TO HAVE JOKE HERE WE SHOULD.
KNOWING THAT YOU KNOW WE FACE A
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE FOR MANY
MANY REASONS.
WHAT I WANTED?
UNDERSTAND ABOUT.
THE SENATE'S ACTION ON USING IT
FOR CD USE.
HELPING THEM GET INTO COMPLIANCE.
I DO WE HAVE ANY ESTIMATE FROM
THEM AS TO WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE.
TERM.
THIS SEEMS LIKE.
I APPRECIATE WHAT AT RUNNING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN
COMPLIANCE BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
THIS SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY
THAT WE MIGHT. THAT IF WE COULD
USE.
MORE OF IT FOR.
ACTUALLY PROVIDING CARE TO
CHILDREN.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA SO.
STRAIGHT UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN A
LITTLE BETTER.
I'M JUST SUCH A JUST ADDRESS
YOUR FIRST QUESTION SO SINCE CCD
BG MONEY IS NOT NEW BUT THEY
INCREASE THAT WE'RE SEEING THIS
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE THAT IS
A NEW. THING THAT IS A NEW ON ME
AUGMENTATION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THIS IS THE FIRST
YEAR THAT WE'RE SEEING THE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO MILLION
OF EXTRA FEDERAL FUNDS. OTHER TO
GET YOUR SECOND QUEEN IS. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE ARE CURRENTLY NOT
ESTIMATES ON WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO GET IT TO COMPLIANCE WITH
WITH CCD BJ.
BUT THAT IS THE INTENTION OF
THE SENATE PLAN THAT THEY WOULD
GO AND MAKE A PLAN FOR WHAT THEY
WOULD. OR HOW THEY WOULD GET IN
COMPLIANCE WITH CCD BG AND THEN
REPORT THAT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I'M.
IS IT THAT DIFFICULT FIRST CD TO
ESTIMATE FOR US.
I READ A.
EVERYBODY ELSE ASK YOU. EARLIER
GROWTH AWAY I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THE PART OF THE THE
CHALLENGE OF FIGURING OUT WHAT
THE COSTS ARE IS. IS TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER THE WEAVERS
THAT WE HAVE WILL REMAIN IN
PLACE MOVING FORWARD AND WHAT
THE PLAN OR THE EXPECTATIONS ARE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR.
MEET AT BEING A COMPLAINT SO
WHAT.
SOME OF THE AREAS WHERE IT WHERE
THERE'S BEEN THE MOST CONCERNS
ARE REGARDING. I'M A STAR
REQUIRING THAT THERE BE ANNUAL.
EXPERT INSPECTIONS OF LICENSED
FACILITIES OF THE STATE CURRENT
DOES SOMETHING MORE LIKE EVERY
THREE YEARS. AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO.
SOME EXPECTATION THAT THERE BE
SOME VISITING OF LICENSE EXEMPT.
PROVIDER SO.
PEOPLE ARE PROVIDING CARE IN
THEIR HOMES WHO ARE WHO ARE NOT
LICENSED IN TRYING TO DO SOME
KIND OF VISIT EVERY YEAR. THAT
BUT THOSE COSTS COULD BE VERY.
EXPENSIVE AND WE HAVE A LOT NO
WEAVER FROM SOMOS REQUIREMENTS
SO.
PART OF THE CHALLENGE OF
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE COULD BE AND.
INAPPROPRIATE PLAN FOR THE
STATE AND THEN AFTER THAT WE WE
COULD FIGURE OUT WHAT THE COST
WOULD BE BUT WITHOUT KNOWING
EXACTLY WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS A KID WITH A NOT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO COME UP WITH
AN EXACT NUMBERS.
SEEMS LIKE A VERY IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND.
.
I JUST THINK IT'S WE FURTHER
DELIVERY.
MIGHT BE WORTH IT FOR US TO. TRY
TO GET THEM TO BE A LITTLE MORE.
HE WAS A LITTLE FIRMER NUMBERS
AND IF NOT THEN.
PROVIDE.
APPROVED A LOWER AMOUNT.
IN DIRECT MORE MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY HAVE MORE CHILDCARE
SLOTS IN THEN IF WE NEED TO
AUGMENTED.
THAT'S MY. IF I MAY OUT ON TO
THE ALEJO'S I RESPONSE.
THAT WE WOULD AGREE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS NOT BEN
AND VERY EXPLICIT AND THERE HAS
HOW THE INTERPRETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF CCTV CHIEF
FEDERAL REAUTHORIZATION ARE THE
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE CITY BG.
NAM WHEN WE'VE DONE COST
ESTIMATES FOR OURSELVES TO CAN
LOOK AT THESE COST WE USUALLY
COME UP WITH A NUMBER AROUND
THIRTY MILLION FOR.
ANNUAL LICENSE INSPECTIONS.
AND WE USUALLY COME UP WITH
ESTIMATES IN THE LOW TENS OF
MILLIONS FOR LICENSE EXEMPT
INSPECTIONS. THAT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO KNOW FOR SURE
HOWEVER.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
ALRIGHT I CAN IMAGINE IT BUT
YEAH DIFFERENCE
IN IN WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING IS
IN THE MAGNITUDE OF FORTY TO
FIFTY MILLION IN WERE. WE ARE
HAVE A NIGHT OF THE FORCES
UPWARDS TO HUNDRED MILLION AND
SO. WHILE YES IT MAY BE THAT IT
COSTS MORE THAN THE FORTY TO
FIFTY YOU'RE DESCRIBING. IF WE.
IF IT DOESN'T COME TO THAT THEN
WE EVEN AFFECT TIED UP FIFTY
MILLION. FOR WHO KNOWS HOW LONG
THAT COULD INSTEAD BE USED RIGHT
AWAY TO HELP FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN IMMEDIATELY I THINK WE
WOULD HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
USING ANY OF THE MONEY FOR SLICE.
GIVEN THE POTENTIAL FOR THE NON
CONTINUANCE OF THE FUNDS IN THE
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO.
YOU KNOW SLOTS ARE AVAILABLE TO
FAMILIES AS LONG AS THEY REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR THEM. SO WE WOULD
BASICALLY BE SOMEBODY LAST FOR
ONE YEAR AND THEN I I I
APPRECIATE THAT DO CAUTION TO
AND YET WE KNOW THAT.
.
SO WHEN THAT IF THE CHILD'S
THREE YEARS OLD THREE WE GIVE
MUST FIGHT FOR YOUR THEN THEY
GET TO BE FOUR YEARS OLD MAYBE
THEN THEY GO TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THAT THEY DON'T
NEED THAT SLOT SO I'M. A LITTLE
BIT LESS CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT.
WEATHER YOU KNOW WHERE WE HAVE
TO MODIFY THE FUNDING LATER
RIGHT.
THAT'S MY THING.
THANK YOU CENTER.
BLOOM.
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PRIORITIZE INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF SLOTS AND AND AND THAT. I IS
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
PLAN DO.
.
BUT I I THINK WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE A BLOCK GRANT TO A
DOLLARS.
WHERE WE HAVE DISCRETION WE
OUGHT TO BE USING THAT TO ALSO
PRIORITIZE MORE SLOT I DID SLOTS
AND? I WANT TO ASK A QUESTION UP
PERHAPS OF LA NO REGARDING. THE
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE TITLED TWENTY
TWO.
FROM.
I THINK IT'S OVER AT A NUMBER OF
YEARS BUT AND IN PARTICULAR
WHETHER IT IS SET A.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING.
FOR.
A FOR THIS YOUNGER POPULATION
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
IS NO TO.
TITLED TWENTY TWO OVERSIGHT
THERE'S UP THAT THERE ARE A
WHOLE RANGE OF.
OVERSIGHT ISSUES THAT DON'T TAKE
PLACE THAT.
AT THESE FACILITIES AND THAT
THAT WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT LOSS
OF.
PERHAPS YOU CAN.
DELVE INTO THAT'LL BUT.
IT'S A GOOD.
LAST YEAR AS PART OF THE BUDGET.
THE THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED.
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD EXEMPT.
A PROVIDERS OF STATE PRESCHOOL
SO UPSTATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE RUN IN AND.
SCHOOLS THAT WERE BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT OPERATE AN ALLEY
FACILITIES.
THAT THEY WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM
THOSE TITLE TWENTY TWO
REQUIREMENTS.
DOT DOT DOT BEGINNING JULY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN.
I'M SO I THOUGHT NOT TAKEN
EFFECT.
THAT THE LEGISLATION LAST YEAR
AND IN THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
ALSO REQUIRED OUR OFFICE TO
COMMUNITY CALLED THE WORK GROUP.
TO MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ON
WHAT IF ANY ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE ADDED TO
OUR OF THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS EVER GONNA BECOME
EXEMPT OF TITLE TWENTY TWO. I'M
SO WE DID.
WE DID.
.
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP CAME WITH
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AND WHEN WE
WROTE ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE IN A
REPORT. THEY RECOMMEND ADDING
SOME SOME SPECIFIC RULES INTO
OUR REGULATIONS FOR THESE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THEN
RECOMMENDING SOME CHANGES TO.
THE EXISTING COMPLAINT PROCESS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TO
USE.
ARE BOTH HOUSES OF ADOPTED ITS
INTO ADOPTED LANGUAGE THAT'S ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE CHANGES THAT
CAME OUT OF ETHICAL TO RECRUIT.
SO.
IF IF THOSE WERE TO TAKE EFFECT
THEM BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE WOULD NOT BE THE
TITLE TWENTY TWO ACCORDING TO
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
ON AN ALLEY A SILLY BUT THEY
WOULD HAVE THESE ADDED.
HEALTH AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
THAT WERE THAT WERE ARE REQUIRED
TO STICK WITH THE WORK GROUP AND
THEY WOULD HAVE A CHANGES TO A
COMPLETE PROCESS TO IT TO OUR.
PROCESS THESE COMPLAINTS IN A
MORE EXPEDITED MANNER.
IF I MAY ADD TO THE ILIAS
RESPONSE.
WE WHEN THE LANGUAGE WAS
ORIGINALLY BACK CONSTRUCTED THE
IDEA WAS TO LOOK AT WHAT OF THE
CURRENT DIFFERENCES AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY BETWEEN TITLE FIVE.
AND TITLE TWENTY TWO TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT MISSING ANYTHING
ENTITLED FIVE THAT WAS CONTAINED
IN TITLE TWENTY TWO. WE GOT TO
BE A PART OF.
AND LISTEN IN ON THE.
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AT THE ILIO
DESCRIBED THAT THEY DID AND WE
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY MADE
DO ADDRESS THE REMAINING ISSUES
BETWEEN TITLE FIVE ENTITLED
TWENTY TWO. AND RECOMMEND.
SUPPORTING THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU I'VE BEEN APPROACHED
BY SOME ADVOCATES WHO FEEL
OTHERWISE SO. MAYBE SOMETHING
THAT WE CANNOT DISCUSS LITTLE.
AND IN ALL OF THAT MORE DETAIL
LATER.
THANK YOU.
THE SHOPS THIS REPORT COMMENT.
LOOKING AT BOTH THE PLANS I
THINK THE SENATE PLAN IS
SUPERIOR. ALSO FROM MY POSITION
I'D. LIKE TO INVITE ONE ITEM TO
STRIKE ME THE MOST.
IS THE FORTY ONE MILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE DEALING IN
THIS AREA. IN MY PREVIOUS LIFE I
USED TO RUN CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR INSPECTING
THEM AT HOLD TEAM TO DO THAT.
AND.
THAT'S.
QUALITIES MOST A PURPORTED ISSUE.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE THE FACT WE
DON'T EVEN USE WORD CHILD CARE
ANYMORE WEEZER. EARLY COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT CHILDREN SO. THE
EXPAND OUR.
PERSPECTIVE WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THESE FACILITIES SO.
IT'S ABOUT THE QUALITY SO I
SUPPORT THE SENATE PLAN.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SINGLE OTHER QUESTIONS WE
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
MR BROUGHT.
SO DEMOGRAPHICALLY LA.
AND SO THIS ITEM IS ABOUT
RELATE THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SO THAT THE ME REVISED
PROPOSAL FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME. TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING FOR THE CREATION OF A
NEW ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT WOULD BE ARE RUN BY THE US
BORDER GOVERNORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M. THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WAS TO
REJECT.
THE CREATION OF THE NEW ONLINE
COLLEGE.
I'M THE SENATE ACTION WITH TO
MODIFY.
TIM TO MODIFY TO ADOPT ONLINE
COLLEGE BUT ADDED SOME
ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS.
TWO OF THE MORE NOTABLE
RESTRICTIONS DOT POINT OUT ONE
IS THAT THERE'S A TEN YEAR
SUNSETON.
ON THE COLLEGE AND THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE NEW
COLLEGE WOULD DEVELOP.
SHORT TERM PROGRAMS THAT LEAD
INTO PATHWAYS THAT EXISTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M SO WE'VE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS.
IN THE PAST BUT THAT THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE ONLINE COLLEGE
IN PARTICULAR I THINK FIRST WE
CAN SEE CLEAR INDICATION FROM
ADMINISTRATION OF WHAT EXISTING
BARRIERS EXIST AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT THIS ONLINE
COLLEGES ADDRESSING.
AND WE ALSO HAD CONCERNS WITH
THE ABILITY OF AN ONLINE COLLEGE
TO.
HOW STATEWIDE ACCESS TO THE
SORT OF HANDS ON EXPERIENCES
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR MOST OF
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN THOSE PROGRAMS GET
GET ACCESS TO THOSE?
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES SOBRE SO WE
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND REJECTING
THAT PIECE.
THAT THERE'S ALSO AN AND
ACTIONS THAT BOTH HOUSES TOOK
THAT ARE.
PROVIDING ONE TIME GRANTS TO
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ONLINE
PROGRAMS.
AND SO ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
THERE'S SIXTY MILLION I'M TO
CREATE A NEW INSTITUTE. THAT
WOULD DEVELOP ONLINE PROGRAMS.
AND AND THE THE TARGET GROUP
WOULD BE THE SAME TARGETED GROUP
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION EVER
POSE FOR THE ONLINE COLLEGE
WHICH SHOULD BE.
WORKING ADULTS WITH NO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CREDENTIALS
ARE MORE MOST LIKELY WORKING IN
LOW WAGE JOBS OF IDEAS THAT YOU
WOULD DEVELOP PROGRAMS FOR THAT
PARTICULAR GROUP.
AND THE IDEA FOR THIS.
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES THAT THAT
THE THE PROGRAMS WOULD BE
COMPETENCY BASED THAT THERE IS
SOME. AND TYPICALLY WHEN PEOPLE
USED OVERCOME AT THE BASIC
FIGURE THAT PEOPLE CAN MOVE
THROUGH THE PROGRAM'S QUICKER AS
THEIR MASTERING CONTENT OR THEY
CAN GO AT A SLOWER PACE OF ANY A
LOT MORE TIME.
AND THAT AND THE THE PROGRAM IT
WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO NOT
DUPLICATE OTHER.
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THAT.
ARE ALREADY BEING OFFERED.
I'M ON THE SENATE SIDE THERE'S
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED AS GRANTS
TO.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN ONLINE
CONTENT AND FOR THAT CONTENT TO
BE TIED TO EXISTING PATHWAYS.
IN IT IN PROGRAMS OFFERED A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M IN ADDITION THE SENATE OFF.
REQUIRES THE CHANCES OFFICE TO
READ A REPORT THAT WOULD MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW YOU COULD
CHANGE NON CREDIT FUNDING RATES
TO.
TO IMPROVE THE DEVELOPMENT OR
ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COMPETENCY BASED PROGRAMS NOT
JUST IN THE ONLINE PROGRAM BUT
MORE BROADLY AND THAT THE
FINDINGS ARE RATE AND THE METHOD
OF FUNDING IS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
VERY. CONCERNED ONE OF THE
PRIMARY BARRIERS FOR MORE
COMPETENCY BASED PROGRAMS.
SO ON THE ON THE ISSUE OF THESE
ONE TIME GRANTS WE DO THINK THE
PROVIDING SOME FUNDING COULD BE
HELPFUL TO HELP OUR IMPROVE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE ARE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. WE DO THINK AT COUPLE
THINGS WE WOULD RECOMMEND IN IN
DEVELOPING THEM IS THAT.
YOU PRIORITIZE PROGRAMS THAT.
IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS NO
ONLINE CONTENT CURRENTLY AND
ALSO IN AREAS THAT HAVE
RECOGNIZED INDUSTRY DEMANDS THAT
YOU ARE CUTTING PROGRAMS THAT.
BETTER PROVIDING AND ACCESS TO
A NEW PROGRAM THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE AND THAT'S GONNA LEAD
TO SOMEONE GOING OUT TO GET A
GOOD JOB.
I'M WE ALSO WOULD RECOMMEND
REQUIRING ALIGNMENT.
AS THE THE SENATE DOES IN THEIR.
PEACE WITH WITH EXISTING
BECAUSE PATHWAYS TO SOMEONE CAN
TAKE A SHORT TERM PROGRAM AND
THEN BE ABLE TO AYE IF THEY WANT
TO CONTINUE WITH THEIR EDUCATION.
CAN DO THAT SEAMLESSLY WITHOUT
HAVING TO START FROM SCRATCH.
ARM AND AND THEN FINALLY I'M WE
WOULD RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE SENATE VERSION.
THE SENATE VERSION HAS THIS
REPORTING REQUIREMENT WHICH
WOULD POTENTIALLY HELP MAKE
CHANGE OF SYSTEM WIDE FOR
APPROVING COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION. AND THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL.
WOULD REQUIRE THESE NEW
PROGRAMS TO ALSO BE COMPETENCY
BASED SO TOGETHER IF YOU HAVE
THOSE TWO REQUIREMENTS TOGETHER
YOU CAN HAVE A LOT MORE.
SORT OF SYSTEM WIDE IT CHANGED
TO IMPROVE WHAT'S GOING ON IN IN
PROGRAMS TO BEGIN TO HAVE MORE
OF THEM BECOME PRETTY.
SALAS UP THERE BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
THINK YOU THE MINISTRATIONS
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS TO COMBAT POVERTY AND
WE'VE YOU THIS PROPOSAL ABOUT
ONLINE COLLEGE AS ANOTHER TOOL.
IN COMBATING POVERTY WE SUPPORT
IN GENERAL THE SENATE'S VERSION
AND.
WHICH DID ADOPT OUR PROPOSAL ON
THE ON MY COLLEGE.
AND THE SENATE ALSO PROPOSES
FORTY FOUR MILLION ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT.
FOR THE ONLINE EDUCATION AND
INITIATIVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR PROBLEMS WITHOUT
INVESTMENT IS JUST HOW IT'S PAID
PACKAGE. ON THERE A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS NOTABLY OUR.
IRON FUNDING.
PROPOSAL FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT ARE USED TO PAY FOR THAT
BUT WE DON'T HAVE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS WITH THAT AND PROGRAM
BEING FUNDED.
ANY GUARD MAJOR CONCERN WITH
THE ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL IS THAT
BACK IN MAY THE GOVERNOR ASKED
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS WORLD
AND WE'VE WAITED PRETTY HEAVILY
WHETHER OR NOT.
WE SHOULD INCLUDE KIND OF
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WITHIN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM OR IF WE NEEDED
SOMETHING NEW AND WE CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT FOR THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
THAT HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE
OR SOME COLLEGE EXPERIENCE BUT
NOT THE DEGREE.
REALLY WE NEED A NEW MODEL.
THESE CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING
SERVED HOT MANY OF THEM ARE IN
LOW WAGE JOBS AND THIS IS A WAY
FOR THEM TO INCREASE THEIR
EARNING POTENTIAL BY THINKING
ABOUT IT IN A COMPLETELY NEW WAY.
WITHOUT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU DONE
A GREAT JOB.
.
ON SUB ONE WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME DISCUSSING THE ONLINE.
COLLEGE AND AND I FIND MOST THE
TIME AND IN IN THE HEARINGS I
LEAN TOWARDS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THIS DISCUSSION WAS PRETTY
ROBUST THAN.
IT IT IT HAS PRETTY STRONG
FEELINGS ON BOTH SIDES WHETHER
TO ESTABLISH A CALL AND ONLINE.
DISTRICT OR NOT.
AND SO I.
I FIND THAT THE ASSEMBLY SIR
PROJ IS VERY REASONABLE. I'VE TO
TRY AND MAYBE FACE AND BASED ON
ALL THE EXISTING RESOURCES AS
OPPOSED TO.
STARTING A WHOLE NEW DISTRICT.
JUST ON MINE.
SO CALLED A COLLEAGUES A SURE
WIN AND I REVIEWED ALL THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS OF ALL. SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS.
ALL OF THEM BUT ONE.
HAVE AN UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT.
AND IF YOU COMBINE ALL THAT THE
DISTRICTS IT OUT THERE. NEVER A
NEGATIVE.
DOT DEFICIT OF FIVE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS SO SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT. COMMITTEE COLLEGES
WERE WERE WE HAVE SOME FISCAL
ISSUES TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH FISH
CAN BE NEXT MONTH JUNE THIRTIETH.
THE COLLEGES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
ADD TO THEIR.
BALANCE SHEETS THE.
UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL AND
THAT WILL ADD ANOTHER TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS BASED ON.
DOCUMENTATION WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
GET SO WE HAVE.
MANY COLLEGE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
UNDER WATER WITH ONE SIMPLE
METRIC OF A BILLION DOLLARS SO.
I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT TO
YOUR ATTENTION AS WE KIND OF
LOOK AT HOW WE SPEND MONEY
BECAUSE. IF WE'RE GOING TO START
ANOTHER DISTRICT SEVENTY THREE.
AND IN THE SENATE HAS
RECOMMENDED.
PROHIBITING THE NEW COLLEGE FROM
CHARGING FEES HIGHER THAN A
TRADITIONAL COLLEGE. YOU'RE
YOU'RE ALREADY PUTTING IT AT A
DISADVANTAGE YOU'RE YOU'RE
HINDERING IT BECAUSE OF. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN ONLINE COLLEGE
WOULD BE A WOULD BE A REALLY
MASSIVE MONEYMAKER BUT IF YOU'RE
GONNA. LIMIT IT TO THE SAME FEES
YOU'RE CHARGED. PER COURSES AT
OUR OTHER DISTRICTS YOU'RE
READING.
ASKING FOR. EXPENDITURES IN
EXCESS OF REVENUES.
SO I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT UP.
BRISTER CHAIRS YOU KNOW AS WE
LOOK AT THE LONG TERM.
I'VE I'VE BEEN CONCERN ON SUB
ONE ABOUT OUR. EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS UPRIGHT BRING IT UP.
UNDER THE UC AND CSU BUT. WE
KNOW WHERE THE TENURE PLANTS
WERE. ORANGE COUNTY.
FILED FOR CHAPTER NINE
BANKRUPTCY.
SO WE HAVE A STRATEGIC FINANCIAL
PLANNER GOES OUT TEN YEARS WE
KNOW. WHAT'S HAPPENING AND AND I
WOULD JUST LOVE TO SEE WHERE ARE
OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
GOING IN AND AND WHEN WILL THEY
BE HERE.
TO ASK FOR SIGNIFICANT CHUNKS OF
MONEY BECAUSE THERE WILL BECOME
A POINT WHERE YOU CAN'T CHARGE A
HIGHER TUITION.
SO I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT BECAUSE FOR THOSE OF FOLLOW
THEY MAY INHERIT. A PRETTY
STICKY WICKET AND I JUST WANTED
TO A.
SEE IF SHE COULD DO STICKY
WICKET DOLLARS AYE. BUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SHE SIGNALED YOU IF YOU DO DRAFT
FOR.
DID THIS EARLY ó WERE BY
FINANCE ONE ADDRESS. I GUESS IS
A STATEMENT BUT ALSO SORT OF
QUESTION. TERMS OF HOW DO WE A
LONG TERM MAKE.
THE COMMUNICABLE JUST MORE
FINANCIALLY STABLE BUT ALSO HOW
HOW DO THE ONLINE PROGRAM
AS LONG TERM SORT OF PAPER. PAY
FOR THEMSELVES BUT ALSO
POTENTIALLY BE REVENUE OUR
GENERATOR WELL OFF PICKED TO
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE BEFORE US
WHICH IS THE COST STRUCTURE OF
AN ONLINE COLLEGE IS MUCH
PREFERABLE. CANDIDLY.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE FACILITY
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER COST
FACTORS THAT AND OTHER LOCAL
COMMUNICATES DISTRICTS ARE FACED
WITH. SECONDARILY THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERN WITH THE SENATE PROPOSAL
THAT WE WOULD KEEP THE FEES THIS
IS A PUBLIC INSTITUTION. AND AS
SUCH IT WOULD FALL IN LINE WITH
CAN YOU COLLEGES SEE ISSUE IN
YOU SEE TO KEEP FEES AFFORDABLE
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND WE
DON'T TAKE ANY ISSUE. ON WITH
KEEPING OUR FEES THAT THAT SORT
OF A LEVEL.
THANK YOU.
I SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU AS
CHAIR.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY ONE TO
COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION.
FOR THIS ONLINE EFFORT I'VE
THINK I'VE BEEN SAYING I THINK
CONSISTENTLY SINCE I'VE BEEN UP
HERE. BOTH TO OUR FRIENDS IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND.
OUR FRIENDS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN AND OF SEE
ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE THAT. GIVEN
THE BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS AT THE
STATE.
HAS MOST IF NOT ALL OF THE TIME
TO TALK TO SOME EXTENT TO
ANOTHER.
AND WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO
BUSINESS IN EDUCATION TODAY JUST
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
THE PAST SIXTY YEARS THAT WAY.
AND SO THIS ONLINE EFFORT IN
THIS EMPHASIS ON TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE PATH.
FOR ONLINE EDUCATION I THINK IS
A VALUABLE ONE IN ONE WORST
COMMENDING.
HAVING SAID THAT YOU KNOW I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED IN THE MILITARY
WE CALL IT THE TWO'S TO TAIL
RATIO.
YOU CERTAINLY WANT MORE TEETH
THAN YOU HAVE TALE BECAUSE THEY
OF COURSE THE TEETH OR WHAT.
GIVE YOUR.
GIVE YOU THE IMPETUS RIGHT MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN.
AND SO ARE WHEN CONSIDERING A
TUESDAY TO TAIL RATIO.
.
ONE OF THE ISSUES IT SEEMS TO ME
IN SETTING UP A NEW ONLINE
COLLEGE IS A SEPARATE ENTITY.
IS ALL THAT COMES WITH SETTING
UP A NEW COLLEGE.
IT'S TAKING A BOARD OF GOVERNORS
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A.
ACCUSTOMED TO DEALING WITH THE
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS OF A
COLLEGE IT'S HIRING A NEW.
COLLEGE PRESIDENT IT'S HIRING
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S IT NORMALLY
HAVE TO FOLLOW A PRESIDENT IT'S
HIRING CURRICULUM DEVELOPERS AND
ALL THE REST OF THE THINGS THAT
I ASSUME WE WILL BE DEALING WITH.
WITH A NEW ONLINE.
A COLLEGE AND I GUESS THEY'RE
HAVING SAID ALL THAT. AND GIVEN
THE FACT THAT MONEY IS NOT
UNLIMITED EVEN THIS YEAR.
WHY WOULD E NOT FOCUS FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE PROPOSAL THAT THE?
ASSEMBLY IS COME UP WITH WERE
YOU TAKEN EXISTING COLLEGE OR.
THE CHANCELLOR DESIGNATES OF.
THE CONSORTIUM OF COLLEGES TO.
WITHIN THEIR EXISTING FRAMEWORK
SET UP AN INSTITUTE THAT IS AN
ONLINE INSTITUTE.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO HIRE A
NEW PRESIDENT TO WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE TO HIRE TEN VICE PRESIDENTS
WERE WE HAVE?
A BOARD OF TRUSTEES OR US. MAYBE
A COMBINED BOARD THAT'S CUSTOM
TO DEALING WITH THE DAY TO DAY
FUNCTIONING OF AN ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION.
AND ALLOW THESE
HOPEFULLY INNOVATIVE ONLINE
PROGRAMMES BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
ONLINE PROGRAMS TO SPEED
FRESHMAN ENGLISH YOUR BASIC MATH
OR WHATEVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING ONLINE PROGRAMS INTO.
PLACES OF EMPLOYMENT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
TO TAKE FOLKS WHO ARE. OR OLDER
BUT CERTAINLY MUCH YOUNGER THAN
I AM AND TAKE THEM INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WITH
RESPECT TO THEIR SKILLS SO WE
WOULD TAKE THE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE NOT SPEND IT ON
STRUCTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUREAUCRACY. AND PUSH IT DOWN
TOWARD THE DEVELOPMENT OF ONLINE
COURSES.
THE SETTING OF GOALS OBJECTIVES
METRICS AND MEASUREMENT TO MAKE
SURE AT LEAST INITIALLY.
THAT THE ONLINE PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL AND THEN CONSIDER
WHETHER WE WANT TO PUT.
ANOTHER COLLEGE ON THE
CHALKBOARD OF THE CHANCELLOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
THAT'S A LONG QUESTION MY
QUESTION TO BOIL IT DOWN AS WHY
NOT FOCUS ON THE ASSEMBLIES
COLLEGE YOUR CONSORTIUM. AN
INSTITUTE PROPOSAL.
SENATOR I THINK I WOULD
REFERENCE YOUR FIRST COMMENT ON
THIS MATTER WHICH IS THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO
LOOK AT DOING THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
AND WE FEEL COMMUNICATIVE HAVE
MANY DIFFERENT MISSIONS
IMPORTANT MISSIONS ON INCLUDING.
CERTIFICATES DEGREES THIS IS A
VERY TARGETED APPROACH REALLY
BASED ON WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
RESEARCH ABOUT ONLINE OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE TALKED IS ADMINISTRATION
FREQUENTLY ABOUT ONLINE AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN. UTILIZE
IT MORE EFFECTIVELY WITHIN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
ADULTS GENERALLY DO YOU BETTER
THAN HANGING AYE TRADITIONAL
COLLEGE STUDENT AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT ON
THE WE FELT THAT CREATING A NEW
ENTITY. ON THAT DOESN'T HAVE
SOME OF THE CONSTRAINTS SUCH AS
AN ACADEMIC CALENDAR WHERE THEY
CAN OFFER CURRICULUM ON A
ROLLING BASIS FOR PEOPLE CAN
FIND OUT ON GOING TO TAKE THESE
COURSES. IS THE MORE PREFERRED
APPROACH
I WOULDN'T KNOW.
THAT OBVIOUSLY THAT FIRST YEAR
COST IS MORE SIGNIFICANT TO YOUR
POINT OF BUILDING OUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT WE FEEL TEN TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE EFFORT
WHICH. I THINK IS A REALLY.
REASONABLE COST.
GIVEN THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
WE EXPECT TO SEE FOR WORKING
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE WHO WILL
EARN A MORE.
AND BETTER LIVING WAGE GIVEN
HIGH HOUSING COSTS AND SOME OF
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WORKING
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING.
WELL I CERTAINLY THINK THE
EFFORTS NOTABLE ON I THINK
WHETHER WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE IN
APPROACH AS TO WHETHER WE DO IT
WITH AN INSTITUTE WOULD DO WITH
A SEPARATE. ONLINE COLLEGE I
THINK WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH IT BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
THAT THAT IMPORTANT.
TO THE WORKFORCE OF THE FUTURE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN
I COMMEND YOUR EFFORTS IN THANK
YOU UP MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER ABRUPT.
IT'S GOING TO SAVE.
HE SAID BLOOM HE LOOKED AT ME.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT.
THAT'S RIGHT WILL.
I DO THE QUESTIONS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO I WIN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
YOUR THIS CAME OUT IN JANUARY I
WAS EXTREMELY ENTHUSIASTIC
BECAUSE I'M CONVINCED THAT. THIS
COULD REALLY BE THE CATALYST FOR
AS YOU SAY POVERTY REDUCTION AND
REACHING A WHOLE NEW
STRATOFORTRESSES AT A REDUCED
COST SO. I WAS A AND TUESDAY
AFTER SUPPORTER AND WAS REALLY
DISAPPOINTED WHEN THE MAY REVISE
CAME OUT.
AND PUT SOME SUBSTANTIAL
RESTRICTIONS ON THAT MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE THE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
TYPE OF ONLINE OFFERINGS THAT
COULD BE OFFERED. OTHER
REQUIREMENT FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FOR FACULTY THE
RESTRICTIONS TO ONLINE EDUCATION
ONLY SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
CAPITALIZE KIND OF MY THINKING
THAT MAYBE THAT WASN'T THE RIGHT
WAY
I GO. AND I WONDERED IF YOU
COULD ELABORATE ON WHAT SOME OF
THE DECISION FACTORS WERE IN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PROPOSAL
IN JANUARY AND MAY.
I WAS RED SUIT HE SAID WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE.
MAYOR VISION AND AMENDMENTS
REALLY.
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS OUR MANY
CONCERNS THAT.
WE BIT WE HEARD ABOUT THE ONLY
COLLEGE PROPOSAL ONE OF THEM WAS
TO ESTABLISH A STRUCTURE FOR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING SO WE I
TOOK AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOW
AT THE COLLEGE TO PARTNER WITH
IN ITS EXISTING DISTRICT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A STRUCTURE IN. PLACE.
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN ONCE THE
COLLEGE IS ESTABLISHED I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE OTHER AMENDMENTS
AND.
THE ME REVISION.
REALLY ATTEMPTED TO STRENGTHEN
IT THE.
STUDENT OUTCOMES ARE REPORTING A
STUDENT SUCCESS OUT WE ADDED I
PROVISIONS REGARDING.
THE COLLEGE ADOPTING.
I REGULATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THE COMPLY WITH ACCESSIBILITY IN
DISABILITY.
PROVISIONS WE ADOPTED
ADDITIONAL AYE REPORTING METRICS
ON ON STUDENT OUTCOMES AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE COLLEGES
REPORTING ON WEIGHT GAIN OUT FOR
STUDENTS AND ENSURING THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY WORKING FOR
THAT INTENDED.
A POPULATION THERE WERE SOME
AREAS AT.
AMENDMENTS IN SOME AREAS
REGARDING CURRICULUM AND THOSE
WHO REALLY JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE CURRICULUM DEVELOPED BY
THE COLLEGE AND ITS FACULTY
WOULD HAVE TO SEE PROTECTIONS.
AS.
OTHER CURRICULUM I DEVELOP A
FACULTY AT OTHER COLLEGES AND A
REALLY.
CLARIFY THE INTENT TO DEVELOP
UNIQUE CONTENT TO THAT ISN'T
DEPLETED OF.
OF ON CONTENT IT UP OTHER
COLLEGES SO THOSE WERE THE SEVEN
SEVEN MEN MEN'S THAT REALLY
TRIED TO STRENGTH AND.
THE REPORTING AND THE TYPE OF
INSTRUCTION AND THE TYPE OF ON
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT THE
COLLEGE.
WELL IN RETROSPECT I I WASN'T
SURPRISED WHEN THAT HAPPENED
OF MY INTERPRETATION OF IT WAS A
BIT DIFFERENT. I THINK THAT THE
EXISTING SYSTEM GOT ITS CLAWS IN.
RIGHT AND.
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE
ONLINE OFFERING LOOK MORE LIKE A
TRADITIONAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A DIRE
MISTAKE BECAUSE. THE WHOLE. OF
THE WHOLE REASON FOR TRANSITION
AND ONLINE OFFERINGS.
IS TO AVOID BEING LOCKED INTO AN
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THAT'S BASED
ON.
A PARADIGM HUNDRED YEARS OLD.
RIGHT WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY AND AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DELIVER AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT THAT WE
DID. NOT EVEN TWENTY YEARS AGO
AND I THINK THAT THAT A SHIFT TO
THAT KIND OF. EDUCATIONAL MODEL
ALSO REQUIRES SHIFT IN OUR
THINKING ABOUT WHAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT KIND OF
OFFERING LOOKS LIKE.
AND I THINK IT'S A A DIRE
MISTAKE TO ASSUME THAT IT LOOKS
JUST LIKE WHAT WE'VE GOT. AND SO.
THAT'S WHY I WAS DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE IT LOOKED LIKE THE
EXISTING SYSTEM WAS TRYING TO
MAKE IT LOOK JUST LIKE ANOTHER
BRANCH OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT KINDA
CATALYZE THE SANDWICH THINKING
ABOUT. GOING TO DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AND AND THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
AND IF I MAY ADD TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY IS IN THE PROPOSAL
IS AT THAT THE COLLEGE WOULD BE
TIED TO THE ACADEMIC CALENDAR
AND. I WOULD BE REQUIRED TO TO
EXPLORE DEVELOPING COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATIONS AND THOSE ARE
TWO CORE COMPONENTS THAT ARE A
PART OF THE PROPOSAL CHURCH AND
THOSE ARE UNLIKE. TRADITIONAL
OFFERINGS BUT EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT THE CHANGES
TO BE MADE. ARTWORK IT SEEMED
LIKE DESIGNED TO MAKE IT LOOK
MORE LIKE A TRADITIONAL OFFERING
AND I JUST I THINK THAT'S A
MISTAKE.
IF FOR GOODS THAT I THINK THIS
IS A A MYSTERY AUTHOR MEMORABLE
ROLE TO GOT TO ADD SOME COMMENTS
ON JUST. THE ISSUE OF AS YOU
DECIDE HOW YOU WANT TO HAVE
PROVIDED SOME FUNDING FOR IT FOR
ONLINE. PROGRAMS DECIDING WHAT
YOU WHAT THE INTENT OF THAT THAT
FUNDING IS FOR. IF.
IF YOU WANT THERE TO BE.
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM.
THEN I THINK SOMETHING LIKE THE
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE
PORTION OF THE.
A ONE TIME PORTION OF THE
SENATE VERSION WHERE YOU'RE
PROVIDING FUNDING TO COLLEGES
WILL HAVE TO WORK WITHIN THE
EXISTING RULES OF THE SYSTEM TO
MAKE THE PROGRAMS WORK. THAT
FIFTH
IF IF YOU WANT THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE TO IMPROVING YOUR NOT
GONNA CHANGE THE RULES THEN THE
FOLKS HERE GIVING THE MONEY TO
TO EXPERIMENT COME UP IN THE
PROGRAMS.
HAVE TO USE THOSE SAME RULES IF
YOU'RE DEFINING AN ONLINE
COLLEGE AND YOU WANT TO BE
DEFERRED YOU DO NEED TO HAVE A
COMPLETE DIFFERENT MISSION
ATTACK. THE IDEA THAT THEY WOULD
BE. DEFERRED AND YOU NEED TO GET
TO DO INNOVATIVE THINGS BUT IF
YOU'RE DOING THAT YOU'RE ALSO
THOSE BATS ALSO MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE AND THE REST
OF THE SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
ADOPT THESE CHANGES. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO THEY'LL GET
THE PLAY BY THE FEDERAL SITE
JUST THAT. ARE AT IT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
MISSION OF THE TH DUH INSTITUTE
OR THE NEW COLLEGE AND I'M WHAT
IS THE WHAT IS YOUR HOPE FOR.
WENT WHEN THAT PROGRAM IS IS
ROLLED OUT.
HOW THAT CHANGES THE SYSTEM
MOVING FORWARD IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT A SPECIAL INNOVATIVE THING
OR THE THING THAT'S INTENDED TO?
HELP COLLEGES TO HAVE THEIR OWN
SPECIFIC RULES HOW TO HAVE A
BETTER OPERATE. AND I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT FROM THIS YOU CAN
MOVE ON TERMS OF THE FUNDING AT
THE CLOUD CENTER MORE OCCUPANTS
IN AS WELL. ACTUALLY IT IT IN
THE THIS PROPOSAL WOULDN'T BE OF
CONCERN WITH THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF THE ONCOLOGY PART
BECAUSE THE. COLLEGES GETTING
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
RIGHT NOW JUST IN PERPETUITY.
AND THEN IN THE FUTURE WOULD BE
GETTING.
PER AFTER YOU FUNDING AS IT HAS
ENROLLMENT SO IT ACTUALLY GETS
AND WOULD GET MORE AMOUNT
PRESSED YOU BASIS.
THEN.
CURRENT COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO SO
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING FOR YOU
THINK ABOUT AS YOU IF YOU ARE
GOING TO DEVELOP IT ONLY BECAUSE
YOU WANT THIS TO BE A CASE RIGHT
NOW. I THINK I CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY IN INITIALLY AS THE PROGRAM
RAMPS UP YOU HAVE THEM ONGOING
MONEY BUT IF YOU HAVE BOTH OF
THESE IN PLACE WHERE YOU GET THE
SAME AMOUNT OF PRESS T. FUNDING.
AND TWENTY BILLION ONGOING AND
POTENTIALLY A LOWER COST MODEL
THEY'RE GETTING A LOT OF MONEY
THEN MAYBE IT TAKES OPERATE THE
PROGRAM
OKAY BUT I THINK WERE INFERIORS
AGREEMENT.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THE MORE YOU
IF YOU'RE GONNA START READ
SOMETHING REVOLUTIONARY HAS TO
BE REVOLUTIONARY AND THE MORE
YOU TRY AND MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
WHAT WE'VE GOT. THE MORE YEAR
DUPLICATIVE OF THE EFFORTS THAT
ARE BEING DONE IN THAT BY THE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT EXIST
SO NOW THAT THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ASSEMBLY MODEL
WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE AS
WELL.
I THINK IN THIS BOOK I'M NOT
SURE WHAT TO MAKE OF.
MIGHT A GOOD FRIEND FROM BIG
BEARS TALK ABOUT REVOLUTION.
.
THE.
I I AM A.
.
A BIG CONCERN.
THAT BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY ARE.
IN AGREEMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROGRAM IS NOT
THE WAY TO GO BECAUSE.
I MAKE AND UP SELLING LIKE A
HERETIC HERE MAYBE A
REVOLUTIONARY HERETIC BUT I I
ACTUALLY.
AND I'M QUITE PLEASED WITH THE
DIRECTION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO TAKE ON
THIS ISSUE. AND. OUTLOOK.
WERE NOT A REVOLUTIONARY
ORGANIZATION THAT MOST CASES
WERE.
A DELIBERATIVE BODY THAT
COMPROMISES TO GET THINGS DONE
AND SO THERE ARE SOME
COMPROMISES I THINK MOST OF THEM
ARE ARE.
A WEALTH.
WELL THOUGHT OUT AND WELL
INTENTIONED. A IN IN OTHER MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL BUT I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE ABOUT ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
IT IS.
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEING MADE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF INCOME
INEQUALITY. OF WERE REALLY
FOCUSED IN WITH THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS FOCUSED
IN. ON.
A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE NOT BEING
SERVED BY THE CURRENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
FOR ALL THE GOOD THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM DOES.
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE WHO CAN
BENEFIT FROM AN ALTERNATIVE
SYSTEM.
AND SO I I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY BEARS ARE
VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE. THE.
INEQUALITY THAT WE SEE
CURRENTLY FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
IS ONLY GOING TO INCREASE WITH
MANY OF THE TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGES THAT WERE SAYING AND WE
HAVE TO BE. PUTTING CALIFORNIA'S
IN A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN KEEP
UP WITH THAT CHANGE AND WHERE
MANY HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND CAN'T
CATCH UP AND I THINK THAT THE.
OTHER THAT'S WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
SEEKS TO DO.
THANK YOU.
GIPSON NO OTHER COMMENTS.
WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUES SEVEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PORTION.
AND SO THAT'S ON THE ISSUE HERE
THOUGH THAT MAY REVISE OUR FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I'M.
WAS.
TO CHANGE THAT THE EXISTING ARE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE FUNDING
APPORTIONMENT SYSTEM WHICH IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY BASED ON A DISC
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT ENROLLMENT.
AND AND SHIFT TO A SYSTEM THAT
WAS SIXTY PERCENT BASED ON
ENROLLMENT TWENTY PERCENT BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AMERICAN ME BECAUSE
DISTRICT. AND TWENTY PERCENT
BASED ON PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
I MEAN AND THAT INCLUDED A TOTAL
I'M IN THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
TOTAL OF OUR TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE MILLION.
TO ALSO INCLUDE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION SO THAT EVERY
COMMUNICATIVE DISTRICT WOULD GET
AT LEAST WHAT THEY GOT IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN GROW BY COST
OF LIVING. ANSELMO'S HOLD
HARMLESS PRISONS WOULD PHASE OUT
OVER TIME BUT THAT WAS THAT THE
PROPOSAL FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THEY ASSEMBLY REJECTS.
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THEN DOESN'T PROVIDE THAT
TO SEVENTY NINE ABOUT THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE ALARMIST BUT
INSTEAD PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A BASE INCREASE.
AND THE FIRST CALL ON THOSE
FUNDS WOULD BE TO PROVIDE TO
COLLEGES.
OR COMMITTEE BECAUSE DISTRICTS
WHO WOULD.
ARE POTENTIALLY DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND MY FEET REDUCTION
IN FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING.
AT LEAST A COLA I'M IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. ARE AND THEN THE THE
REMAINDER OF THE FUNDING WOULD
BE AVAILABLE FOR BASS
APPORTIONMENT INCREASES FOR THE
COLLEGES.
I'M THE THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ALSO
REQUIRES THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND TO CREATE A TASK FORCE AND
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
BY MARCH FIRST TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. ON A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA. I'M IT AND.
DUH TASK FORCE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO LOOK AT OPTIONS FOR
PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS CERTAIN STUDENT
POPULATIONS. I'M TO LOOK AT WAYS
TO MINIMIZE THE VOLATILITY IN
FUNDING BECAUSE OF.
UPS AND DOWNS IN ENROLLMENT.
AND THEN TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO THAT FUNDING IN
AGGREGATE IS NO LESS THAN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS.
I'M MOST NOTABLY I WOULD POINT
OUT THE TASK FORCE IS NOT. TO
LOOK AT PERFORMANCE BASED ARE A
PERFORMANCE BASED COMPONENT IN
THE FUNDING FROM YOUR.
I'M THE SENATE REJECTED THE
FUNDING FORMULA AS WELL AND THEY
PROVIDE HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN A BASIC PORTION
INCREASES.
I'M YOU KNOW KNOW OUR TASK FORCE
REQUIREMENT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT SO ISSUE BEFORE. YOU HERE
IS REALLY DE UM BOTH BOTH HOUSES
ARE REJECTING THE PROPOSAL BOTH
A PROVIDING FROM A PORTION
INCREASES.
SOME SMALL DIFFERENCES I THINK
THAT THE BIG. DIFFERENCE IS
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT TO LOOK
INTO THE POSSIBILITY OF IN
FUTURE YEARS CREATING AND A
FUNDING FORMULA.
I'M STARTING A FEW COMMENTS FOR
US INTO IF YOU DO WANT TO KIND
OF GO IN THAT DIRECTION WE DO
THINK THE TASK FORCE APPROACH.
IT MAKES SENSE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR MORE TIME.
TO REVIEW THE FORMULAIC
CONSIDER WHAT WHAT COMPONENTS
YOU WANT TO BE INCLUDED WE KNOW
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AS
THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
OUT OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
HOW HOW DIFFICULT THIS IS TO
REALLY GET HOOKED A SENSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE FORMULA?
TO GO TO GIVEN THAT THE CHANGES
THAT MAY REVISE ARTISTS PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL COMPARED TO THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL SO YOU DON'T
REALLY ONLY HAD A FEW WEEKS TOOK
A LOOK AT THE SPA.
PROPOSAL.
I'M.
THAT THE OTHER ISSUE REPORT OUT
IS IF THE A IN IN TERMS OF.
HOLDING DISTRICTS HARM WITH
ANOTHER'S CONCERNS ABOUT
PROVIDING SOME CHRISTIAN SOME
STABILITY A* ABILITY IN THE
TRANSIT
TWO AND A FORMULA. ARM WE ARE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THAT.
UNPREDICTABILITY IN THE FIRST
YEARS BUT WE WERE JUST ARE
RECOMMEND THAT ANY OF THESE
KINDS HOLE HARNESS PRISON TO BE
TEMPORARY. ARE AND EVENTUALLY
FADE OUT ON THE GOAL OF CHANGING
FUNDING FORMULA IS TO ALIGN WITH
A POLICY GOAL THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE WITH THERE MIGHT BE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING TO BE BASED ON NEED FOR
EXAMPLE FOR CERTAIN STERN
POPULATIONS OR TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR.
IMPROVING PERFORMANCE.
DOT THAT THE DUMB THE LEAD THE
LESS YOU LEAVE FOR A HOLD
HARMLESS THE MORE YOU AVAILABLE
TO FUND THOSE GOALS I'M SO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THAT THE
BILL BE TEMPORARY.
AND THEN I THINK WE WOULD JUST
POINT OUT AND IF YOU ARE.
.
FOCUSED IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER AYE MAKING CHANGES IN
LOOKING AT THE BOTTLE SERVICES
FOR CERTAIN STUDENTS.
WE DIDN'T WE WROTE A REPORT IN
DECEMBER ARE OF LAST YEAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE LEGISLATURE
LOOKING AT.
PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES
FOR LOW INCOME AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS ARE IN IN
THE ENTIRE HARITH SYSTEM BUT WE
HAD. SUCH A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THERE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
THE POTENTIAL FOR A STREAMLINING
EXISTING CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
THAT THAT EXIST AND POTENTIALLY
LOOKING AT SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
THAT COLLAPSES THE. ATOM SOMOS
PROGRAMS WOULD PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY WITH STREAMLINED
PLANNING FOR COLLEGES WOULD
REDUCE THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AND IMPROVE COORDINATION AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL. I'M THERE WAS
THERE ARE WORTH THREE PROGRAMS
ARE CONSOLIDATING THE MAY REVISE
IN ALL HOUSES OUT BOTH HOUSES
ADOPTED THAT ACTION BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE'S MORE THAT YOU COULD
DO PERSON SEATS HERE. TO PROVIDE
MORE STREAMLINING FOR OUR
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
THANK YOU.
SIR NIELSEN.
WHERE DID SERVICE ARE CENTER DUH
MISS COST?
I BOUGHT DEFINITELY WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE FROM THE
DIVESTITURE.
AS THE ANALYST NOTED WE'VE
BUILT IN A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO HOLD
COMMITTEE BECAUSE DISTRICTS
HARMLESS AS WE TRANSITION TO
THIS NEW FUNDING MODEL THIS
FUNDING MODEL IS PREDICATED ON
SOME OF THE WORK THAT HAPPENED
AT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ON
VISION FOR SUCCESS AND REALLY
WHAT IT WOULD DO IS A LYING HOW
WE FUND COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH
A MORE STUDENT CENTERED APPROACH.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD KNOW IN
GOING BACK TO SENATOR MORLOCKS
QUESTIONED DURING THE K. TWELVE
A PORTION OF THE AGENDA AND
WHICH WE SEE EIGHTY A DECLINING.
THAT'S A DEMOGRAPHIC TREND THAT
THE WAVE EVENTUALLY THAT WILL
GET TO OUR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND ROME ACCOUNTS IS WELL. IN
SO BY MOVING TO A MIX REALLY.
OF ENROLLMENT AND.
PERFORMANCE SPACE.
I YOU CAN HELP MITIGATE AGAINST
THAT.
I WOULD KNOW THAT.
ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES IN THE
PROPOSAL BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELEASE AND MAY REVISE
THOSE WERE PREDICATED ON THAT
MEETINGS WE HAD WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND IT SOUGHT TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE FIELD.
BASED ON HOW ARE JANUARY
PROPOSAL LAFAYETTE WHICH IS
NOTES.
THAT WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
WITH HOW THE ASSEMBLY CHOSE TO
UTILIZE THE FUNDING.
WHICH IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY.
OBVIOUSLY TONIGHT ARE FUNDING
PROPOSAL. AND THEN EXTENDED THE
HOLD HARMLESS TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENT DISTRICTS WHICH IS
BASICALLY OFFERING DISTRICTS
MORE MONEY FOR SERVING LAW
STUDENTS.
I WHICH IS THAT A COUNTER
PURPOSE WITH THE PROPOSAL WE'VE
PUT FORWARD WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
SENATE NIELSEN.
THANK YOU WHAT I HAVE DISK
CONFESS I. FIND MYSELF WORD
SYMPATHY WITH.
A COLLEAGUE ON THE LEFT HERE.
AND AND.
MY COLLEAGUE ACROSS SERVICE OVER
OBERNOLTE.
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S.
PLAN.
.
IT INSTILLS.
SO PERFORMANCE CONSIDERATION.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND I WOULD CONCUR THAT. MY
OPINION WOULD BE THAT THE MAY
REVISE SOMEWHAT UNDERMINES AT.
MAYBE NOT ENOUGH TO SAY NO TO
THE ENTIRE.
PROGRAM.
TELL ME NOW AS FAR AS THE.
.
SO WOULD YOU KIND OF CALL OF THE
MIXED PERFORMANCE.
.
MISS COST IT NOW.
THE.
PART WILL STILL BE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT.
BASED.
AND THEN IT THE OTHER THAN YOU.
PROGRAM OUT.
THE TENANTS FIFTY PERCENT.
AND THEN TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
IS THAT THE BALLOT OUR PROPOSAL
IS SIXTY PERCENT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED BASED ON ENROLLMENT
SO SOMEWHERE TO HAVE TEA WHICH
IS KIND OF THE BASE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS THAT WE PROVIDE TO
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
TWENTY PERCENT WOULD BE BASED ON
ENROLLMENT OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS
AND THE FINAL TWENTY PERCENT
WOULD BE BASED ON PERFORMANCE OR
STUDENT SUCCESS METRICS WHAT'S A
BLENDED MODEL.
ONE OF THE ISSUES RELATED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR A LONG
TIME HAS BEEN.
THAT.
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT.
AND.
SCHOOLS.
PUTTING TOGETHER CLASS IS SIMPLY
THE.
HELP PEOPLE ENROLLED.
FOR LONG TIME I'VE OBJECTED TO
THAT.
CONCEPT.
AND IT SEEMED LIKE TO ME THAT
THIS ONLINE.
IT'S A PLACE TO START.
NOT JUST FOR THOSE PURPOSES BUT
TO BROADEN. THE POPULATION.
ANYWAY I THINK THAT WOULD BE
MORE. BENEFICIAL THAN JUST
INVENTING.
SCHOOL BY SCHOOL.
CLASSES TO GAIN FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT.
WHAT DROVE THE GOVERNOR'S?
PASSION FOR THIS.
THIS NEW APPROACH.
WELL THERE'S WE'VE YOU THESE
PROPOSALS IS REALLY
COMPLIMENTARY TO ONE ANOTHER SO
THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROPOSAL REALLY TARGETS A GROUP
OF STUDENTS THAT TRADITIONALLY
HAVE NOT BEEN SERVED.
SOME OF THE INITIAL FEEDBACK WE
HEARD IS THAT SOME DISTRICTS
WORRIED AND IN EMPLOYMENT BASED
FUNDING MODEL WE WERE
POTENTIALLY DECREASING THEIR
FUNDING BY SERVING THE STUDENTS
IN AN ONLINE MANNER.
BY HAVING A PERFORMANCE BASED
MODEL YOU DON'T HAVE DISTRICTS
HAVING THOSE DISAGREEMENTS
INSTEAD YOU'RE FOCUSING
DISTRICTS ON ACTUALLY AND
MEETING THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AND SO WE REALLY DO YOU VIEW THE
ON LINE AND THE ENROLLMENTS.
OR THE MOVE FROM A PURELY
ENROLLMENT BASE MODEL AS
COMPLEMENTARY MEASURES ON
ADDITIONALLY I THINK THE ONLINE
COLLEGE WOULD BE HELD TO THE
SAME PERFORMANCE METRICS.
WHERE WERE REALLY IT'S A SEISMIC
SHIFT IN LOOKING AT?
WITHIN THE COMMUNICABLE JUST
THE MANY DIFFERENT MISSIONS THEY
SERVE AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE
FUNDING THEM. UP FOR MEETING
THOSE GOALS OF THE STUDENTS BOTH
IN THE ONLINE ENVIRONMENT AND
AND THE BRICKS AND MORTAR
SCHOOLS.
SELECT.
SIR MORE.
COMMISSION CHAIR I JUST.
IT WAS FOR THE SAKE OF MISS
COSTED WANNA SAY THAT I DO
SUPPORT THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
AND VOTED. FOR THAT'S I THINK
MISTER CHAIR OUT WE NEED TO
MAYBE.
LOOK AT WHAT OUR STRATEGY WILL
BE FOR STRUGGLING DISTRICTS AND
I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF FIVE MISS COSTA WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
WHAT I THINK SIMILAR TO?
ARE APPROACH ON THE K. TWELVE
SIDE WE'VE.
UTILIZE DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES.
IN A THINK THIS DOES GET INTO
THE ISSUE OF WITH AND THE NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE.
WHAT'S ON GOING WHAT'S ONE TIME
IN NATURE AND WHAT'S PROVIDE
WHAT PROVIDES MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL DISTRICTS.
WE PUT ADEQUATE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT IN OUR PROPOSAL HIGH IN
DISCRETIONARY.
RESOURCES I'M ASSOCIATED WITH
OUR FUNDING FORMULA THIS IS
REALLY FLEXIBLE DOLLARS BY
HOLDING THEM HARMLESS IT GIVES
THEM GREAT DISCRETION ON HOW TO
FEND HOW TO SPEND THESE FUNDS.
AND I THINK YOUR CHANCES ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE AS WELL SO I'M
SURE HE'LL BE BACK.
NEXT YEAR WITH THE SAME.
RECOMMENDATION.
THAT CORRECT.
I'M NOT SURE I'M FOLLOWING YOUR
QUESTION WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
THE ONLINE FUNDING PROPOSAL AND
HOPE FOR ITS INCLUSION AND I
THOUGHT I'D DROP ONLINE AND
TALKING ABOUT YOUR AND FUNDING
FORMULA YOUR FUNDING FORMULA.
SO.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE FOCUSED ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND I CONCUR WITH MY.
COLLEAGUE FROM PAYMENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
I'M GONNA TAKE DECIDE PROVIDENT
AND DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THE.
HAVE YOU SHOULD IN ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS ON IT AND.
ON HIGHER ED TO RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE NEEDS OF SOCIETY AND
THE IN ON THIS NUMBER OUT THERE
AND HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE NEED TO
HAVE DEGREES.
DO YOU HAVE A.
DID YOU WITH INCOME INEQUALITY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW WHAT
HOW CAN WE HELP PEOPLE GET JOBS
HOW CAN YOU GET. DEVELOP THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
HOW DO WE GET THE SKILLS WE NEED?
AND THE WORLD ECONOMY.
SO ALL THESE THINGS ARE CHANGING
RAPIDLY.
AND I THINK OUR.
CONCEPT OF.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BE IN A
PLACE TO GET IN A A.
AND TRANSFERRING TO WAS CE AS
YOU'D BEGIN TO BE A OR B. S..
BECAUSE WHEN I ATTENDED A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE MAJORITY
OF US DID THAT.
BUT NOW IF YOU LOOK AT IT WHAT'S.
ILLEGAL BY WHAT'S PERCENT OF.
GRADUATES.
OR ATTENDEES OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACTUALLY TRANSFERRED TO
ISSUES YOU ARE YOU SAY.
TO GET HIRED TO GET A BACHELORS
DEGREE.
WHEN RUNNING RATHER.
I DON'T THINK THAT NUMBER BUT
IT'S LESS THAN HALF OF STUDENT I
WAS GONNA SAY IS LESSEN TWENTY
PERCENT.
AND SO IT'S NOT A BIG GROUP.
WHICH WAS IT THE SAME ONE I
TENDED OF COMMUNICABLE JUNE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. SO SO THIS
CHANGED.
AS I WAS TOLD THE STORY SEVEN
PERCENT.
OKAY.
SO THE.
SO THERE'S A.
AND THAT'S NOT A BAD THING.
IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT NEEDS
WITHIN SOCIETY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO SO I THINK WHAT THE
CHANCES TRYING TO DO AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NEW VISION IS
FIGURING OUT. WHAT IS THE ROLE
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES?
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF
EXPERIMENTS AROUND THE STATE IN
MY OWN DISTRICT AMERICA'S TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IS GIVING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE TO
WORK IN THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY BECAUSE. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PARTYING WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO GIVE THE NEEDS.
TO THE INDUSTRY YOU KNOW
TECHNICIANS WORK IN
PHARMACEUTICALS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TO UC SAN
DIEGO TO WORK IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY.
SO THAT YOU MANY COLLEGE FILL
THAT ROLE NOW I KNOW WE HAVE THE
NUMBERS YOU MANY COLLEGES DOING
IT THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SOME ARE GOOD AND SOME SOME OF
MARK DOING SO WELL THIS VERY
SMALL NUMBERS STUDENTS TAKING
ADVANTAGE IN THE MODERN MONEY WE
PUT INTO IT PROBABLY ISN'T GIVEN
AS THE RATE OF RETURN WE WANT.
BUT I THINK THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE
I THINK WE'RE TRYING TO REDESIGN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO.
I.
CHANGES REALLY TOUGH.
AND SO IN THE DISCUSSION WE HAD
AND IN EDUCATION.
IT WAS ALWAYS A DISCUSSION ABOUT.
AND I HAD A NUMBER OF THE.
.
OF THE FACULTY.
MEMBERS ATTEND COME TO MY OFFICE
AND THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
BEING MEASURED FOR SUCCESS BEING
EVALUATED.
AND THE WHOLE DISCUSSION ARE YOU
GONNA VALUE IT MEANS HOUSING
TEACH CLASSES BECAUSE I'M
TEACHING STUDENTS TO.
PROBABLY WON'T A SUCCESSFUL IN
HIGH SCHOOL SO THEY DIDN'T GO TO
SEE ISSUE WOULD HOLD ME DIRE
STAND SO THERE.
TEACHERS ARE WONDERFUL PEOPLE
BUT THEY DON'T LIKE TO BE
EVALUATED
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT. ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE. SO.
I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE.
.
TO THE. TO THE FACULTY BECAUSE
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE INDICATE MANY
COLLEGES WE REALLY UNDER FUNDED
IT. AND SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT
VERY MANY FULL TIME FACULTY.
HOW MANY FULL TIME FACULTY HAVE
INCOMMUNICADO EDGES AVERAGE AND
WE KNOW THAT ONE?
I DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFIC TOTAL
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S ROUGHLY FIFTY
SIX PERCENT OF THE FACULTY OR
FULL TIME FACULTY WHEN WHEN DONE
BY FDA OUT SO QUICKLY.
ABOUT ANYTHING IS THAT I EITHER
BUT OKAY BUT.
MY POINT IS YOU USED TO BE WHAT
I WOULD THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
IN A JUNIOR COLLEGE CALL THEN A
LOT OF THE FACULTY OR FULL TIME
AND THEY HAD OFFICE HOURS YOU
COULD. JUST LIKE ANY OTHER PLACE
IT WAS A DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT
THAN IT IS TODAY.
AND LIKE I SAID EARLIER THIS
WOMAN IS BAD THIS IS A DIFFERENT
ROLE THAT THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES
ARE PLAYING WITH IN SOCIETY.
SO I THINK.
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF GOING BACK IN
LOOKING AT.
HOLDEN THIS WEEK HOLDEN THIS.
DISCUSSION IN MEETING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE AND
IF IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE THE.
NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
TRANSFER TO BERKELEY TO GET THE
FRENCH LITERATURE DEGREE SO WE
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS.
WE NEED TO I LOVE BEING THEM UP
HOURS AGO EITHER FRENCH YEAH AND IN THE FORTY NINTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT ARE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THEM. BUT
THE.
SO I THINK THE WE NEED TO ALLOW
THEM TO DO WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
AND GROW TO IT AND SO GIVEN THE
TIME TO GO BACK AND RE. READ
LOOK AT IT.
WE DO KNOW. BACK OFF.
THAT EDUCATION HIGHER EDUCATION
IS A KEY COMPONENT FOR GOOD JOBS
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE HAVE SOME REAL.
INEQUALITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE GOTTA GET IT RIGHT AND I
DON'T THINK THIS IS RIGHT AND
YOU GOTTA GO BACK WORK ON A BIT
MORE. I THINK BECAUSE THE
CHANCES RIGHT GOT TO DO THIS.
ALLOWED TO GO FORWARD IN AND
FIGURE IT OUT.
IN THIS CHANGE IS HARD.
HELLO.
I WOULD JUST NOT ON THE
PERFORMANCE SIDE OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA WE DO YOU TRY TO
INCORPORATE THE MULTITUDE OF
MISSIONS THAT THE COMMUNICATIVE
SERVES THERE ARE. MEASURES FOR
ADT ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER BUT CERTIFICATES AS
WELL AND WE REALLY TRIED TO WAY
THAT.
TO YOUR EARLIER POINT KIMMY
COLLEGES DO YOU SERVE AS A
TRANSFER PATHWAY FOR SOME
STUDENTS BUT FOR OTHER STUDENTS
IT'S THE AND. AN AREA TO GET A
CERTIFICATE WERE TO REACH OTHER
EDUCATIONAL GOALS SO WE DID TRY
TO INCORPORATE THAT IN THE AND
STUDENT PERFORMANCE SECTION OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
AND I THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
AYE ALLY TH HOPEFULLY THIS
DISCUSSION OF THE TRANSPARENT.
YOU KNOW THE KATIE TWELVE SYSTEM
COULD DEVELOP A DASHBOARD WITH
THERE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE I'D
IMAGINE SOMETIME TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SHOULD HAVE.
THE SAME ACCOUNTABILITY SO
PEOPLE LOOK AT SAY.
YOU GET DEGREES OUT THE SCHOOL
OR YOU GO TO AMERICA BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO BE WORKED IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL SO. PEOPLE WILL
HAVE.
AN EXPECTATION OF WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THAT. TOO MANY COLLEGES IN
YUBA CITY COLLEGE MAY BE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN AMERICA'S
DOMINICAL.
AND THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S RELATION BETWEEN THE
COLLEGES EXACTLY THAT.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
USED TO BE A JUNIOR COLLEGE THAT
WHEN I TENDED NOW WE'LL CALL
THAT.
IT'S IS MUNITY COLLEGE I THINK
THERE'S A REASON WE CHANGED THE
NAME.
ETCETERA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF YOU KNOW WITH THIS THESE
FORMULAIC APPROACHES TO FUNDING
IN FOR EXAMPLE K. THROUGH TWELVE
WE REQUIRE.
DISTRICTS TO HAVE A PLAN AND IN
THE PLAN HAS CERTAIN REVIEW
ELEMENTS IN.
IN OF SUBJECT TO
EVALUATING HAD DISTRICTS USED
THE MONEY GIVEN THE.
ATTENUATED RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
OUR STATE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN
THESE VERY CAN BREEZE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS THEM.
IN THE STATE MAYBE I MISSED THIS
BUT WHO DECIDES HOW THIS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT MONEY IS
SPENT IN.
AND WHO.
AND WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR.
ADJUSTING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE MONEY IF
SOMEONE WHO EVER THAT IS OR SOME
GROUP DECIDES THAT IT ISN'T
SPENT APPROPRIATELY. IS THAT A
FAIR QUESTION.
YEAH RIGHT SO KEY SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OWN NOTE
THAT I'M PART OF THE PROPOSAL
AYE REQUIRES.
AT THE LOCAL DISTRICTS WHO
ADOPTED AND THE GOALS OUTLINED
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS IT SO
LAST SUMMER.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
BOARD OF GOVERNORS ADOPTED A
VISION FOR SUCCESS THAT OUTLINE
VERY SPECIFIC GOALS ON IMPROVING
I STUDENT SUCCESS AT METRICS
SO.
AT THE PROPOSAL REQUIRES. LOCAL
DISTRICTS TO INCORPORATE THOSE
IN THEIR MASTER PLANS AND TO
ALIGN THEIR BUDGETS WAITED AT
THOSE MASTER PLANS AND THOSE
SCHOOLS AND SPECIFY HOW THEY'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON. ON THE
SPECIFIC METRICS I'D ON HOW TO
SPEND THE FUNDS THAT STILL A
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS HAVE LOCALS
REALLY A LINE.
THEIR THEIR LOCAL GOALS WITH AT
THE STATE WHITE HOUSE AND AT
VARIOUS SUCCESS AREAS. WHERE AS
YOU MAY KNOW I WASN'T I DIDN'T?
DO NOT SIT ON A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HEARD ANY OF
THESE
CARE ISSUES AND SO. I'M SOMEWHAT
UNFAMILIAR WITH SOME OF THE
DETAIL BUT FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS
PART OF THIS PROCESS AND AS PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. IS
THERE SOME PLAN TO ACCUMULATE
DATA TO TRY TO MATCH UP THE.
DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT MONEY WITH EDUCATIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS THAT WHAT THE
STUDENT SUCCESS DOZEN IS THE
DATA AGGREGATED IN IS THE DATA
THEN MADE AVAILABLE TO OF THE
STATE'S CHANCES OFFICER TO US OR
TO BOTH. TO EVALUATE WHETHER.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT IS
EFFECTIVE OR NOT AGE AS I THINK
I AM.
CLEAR THIS IS CURRENTLY A DEBATE
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE ENVIRONMENT RIGHT
NOW AS TO WHETHER. SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS OR THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DISTRIBUTE
MONEY AS OPPOSED TO THE BASE
GRANT ITSELF IS THAT.
THAT'S A QUESTION I THINK
SOMEWHAT ONE DISTINCTION I WANT
TO MAKE IT SEEM THE TWO SYSTEMS
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ALISON I TALKED ABOUT.
REALLY EARLY ON IS THE K.
TWELVE THAT COMPULSORY.
SYSTEM AND THIS OBVIOUSLY IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
MECHANICALLY APPORTIONMENT GO
THROUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO
CALCULATE THE PERFORMANCE
METRICS AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
ENROLLMENT FACTORS THAT WE'VE
BUILT INTO THE FUNDING FORMULA.
AND SADAT HOW THE COLLEGES BUT
ACTUALLY RECEIVED THE FUNDS THAT
GOES THROUGH THE SAME
MECHANIZATION IT DOES NOW JUST
THE FACTORS THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD
DETERMINE ARE DIFFERENT. THAN
JUST PURELY ENROLLMENTS
OKAY.
BECAUSE I MY ADDED IN TERMS OF
COMPARING THE THINGS I THINK
THIS IN THE THIS PROPOSAL HAS A
LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL BECAUSE
THAT. THERE ISN'T THE SAME
REQUIREMENT THERE BE A CERTAIN
PERCENT INCREASE IN SERVICES
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS.
THAT ARE PROUD THAT OUR SERVER
LOW INCOME BUT I THINK THAT THEY
DIEM PART WITH THE FORMULA IS%
THAT THEY'RE. THEY'RE USING THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING IT INSURERS
THAT AS A RESPONSE TO HAVING A
PERFORMANCE BASED COMPONENT YOU
DON'T HAVE COLLEGES THAT ARE SAY.
TRYING NOT TO SERVE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO GET THEIR
PERFORMANCE NUMBERS UP RIGHT WE
WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
COLLEGES HAVE A FISCAL INCENTIVE.
DON'T HAVE A FISCAL INCENTIVES
TO SORT OF.
FOCUSED ON THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
BEST STUDENTS SO THAT'S PART OF
WHY THERE'S THAT THE POMONA
COMPONENT ALSO I IN THE MAY
REVISED THAT MISTRESSES PROPOSAL.
IT ON THE PERFORMANCE SIDE
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR
PROGRAM RECIPIENTS.
THAT'S INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
THE COLLEGE YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
NOT SAYING EXACTLY HER SUPPOSED
TO RUN THE PROGRAM WE'RE NOT
DEFINING WHAT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SERVICE AND WHAT'S NOT NOTHING
LIKE THAT.
LIKE LIKE SOME ASPECTS OF A
FEVER BUT WE ARE SAYING WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE NOT
THAT THAT BECAUSE IF IT'S NOT
COMPULSORY. THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT COLLEGES ARE NOT SORT
OF LIKE. TRYING TO CHOOSING THE
EASIEST TO SERVE STUDENTS I GOT
I GOT AND I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION AND IT.
HAS TO DO WITH THEM IT WAS JUST
A BUT A LINE IN OUR.
IN OUR ANALYSIS AND STAFF COME
IT'S HAVING TO DO WITH THE UNDER
THE PERFORMANCE METRIC ELEMENT
TO THEM.
MEASURING STUDENTS TO OBTAIN A.
REGIONAL LIVING WAGE WITH ANY
YEAR OF COMPLETING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
AS ONE OF THE PERFORMANCE
METRICS AND. HAVING SPENT A
LITTLE TIME THINKING ABOUT THIS
IN ASKING.
IN THE HIGHER ED AREA HOW THE
C. ISSUES IN THE UC'S.
MEASURE THEIR VALUE WITH RESPECT
TO THEIR CUSTOMERS WHO WERE
STUDENTS IN WHAT THE STUDENTS
GET OUT OF THEIR COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE AND. MOST STUDENTS OF
COURSE ONE A GOOD PAYING JOB
WHEN THEY WALK OUT THE DOOR.
HOW DO WE MEASURE WHETHER A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT?
OBTAINS A REGIONAL LIVING WAGE.
WITHIN A YEAR OF COMPLETING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
HAS THERE BEEN THAT'S QUESTION
ONE AND THAT SORT OF A COMPOUND
WHEN IS THERE SOME MECHANISM NOW
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO TIE AND.
THE A DENTED T. OF A PARTICULAR
STUDENT WITH SOMETHING COMING
OUT OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT OR A. TAX
RETURN.
OF IT BE HAVING BEEN RECEIVED BY
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO.
TIE IN A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
WITH THE STUDENT TO MEASURE WHAT
THE WAGE THE STUDENT IS
RECEIVING.
IS THAT.
FAIR QUESTION OVER CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH FINANCE I THINK
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION UP WHAT
IT THEY ARE DOING TODAY TO
OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION IS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WORKS WITH.
THE EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND IN PARTICULAR
THEIR LABOR MARKET INFORMATION
DIVISION WHO COLLECT THIS
INFORMATION FROM.
EMPLOYER SO THEY'RE ABLE TO DO
A SOFT MATCH BETWEEN THE
STUDENTS AND THE EMPLOYER DATA
THAT'S BEING SUBMITTED TO HAVE A
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WAGES THAT THOSE STUDENTS ARE
OBTAINING.
THE OTHER ASPECT OF THAT THAT I
WOULD ADD IS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM DOES HAVE WHAT
THEY CALL SALARIES ARE PER.
AVAILABLE ONLINE ALL ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WEBSITE MAY
BELIEVE MANY DISTRICTS ALSO WENT
TO THE SALARIES ARE FROM WHAT
THAT ENABLES A STUDENT TO DO. IS
TO LOOK AT A PARTICULAR PROGRAM
AND HAVE A GENERAL UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE START OF WHAT TYPE OF
WAGE YOU COULD EXPECT FROM
COMPLETING THAT PROGRAM.
I UNDERSTAND I I HOPE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO.
FINE TUNE THIS.
PERFORMANCE METRICS SO WE ARE
FRANKLY ABLE TO OBTAIN A VERY
ACCURATE FAIRLY ACCURATE REPORT
ON.
WHETHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GRADUATES.
.
RECEIVE A REGIONAL LIVING WAGE
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
EXPANDED BOTH TO THE C. ISSUE IN
THE UC BECAUSE I THINK THE FOLKS
THAT RUN THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
HAVE ARE AN OBLIGATION TO THE
TAXPAYERS BUT CERTAINLY AN
OBLIGATION TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
WHO WERE STUDENTS TO DEMONSTRATE
THE VALUE ADDED. OF THE COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE AND AND THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND THEY ARE CURRENTLY
DOING THIS FOR THE MOST PART. IS
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION THROUGH
ALUMNI ASSOCIATIONS WHICH.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
ALMOST FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN A.
SIZEABLE GENERAL FUND BUDGET WE
GOTTA FIGURE OUT A BETTER WAY TO
SKIN THAT CAT SO GOOD LUCK TO
YOU ON THIS THANK YOU.
THEY MISTER.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR DOLE'S.
MASTER PLAN HAS BEEN MENTIONED
HERE.
I THINK IT WAS A MORE NARROW.
.
TAILORED AFTER THE AT THAT
MASTER PLAN I THINK FINANCE WAS
SUGGESTING THAT WHAT I'M GOING
TO THE REFER TO.
AND THAT IS A MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THAT.
WAS
FIRST IMPLEMENTED UNDER GOVERNOR
BROWN. PAT BROWN.
AND REVISED IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN I WOULD
ARGUE IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT
MASTER PLAN.
SOME THINGS AREN'T THOUGH AND
THAT WOULD BE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BECOMING FOUR YEAR DEGREE
OFFERING COLLEGES.
I AM VERY RESISTANT TO THAT.
BUT WE'VE THE.
WE'D WE'VE HAD THAT THE WHOLE
REASON FOR THE REVIEW OF ASPEN
WAS IN EIGHTY THREE WAS BECAUSE
OF. THE CREEPING.
THE.
SO I GUESS THE OTHER DIFFERENT.
THE INSTITUTIONS THE.
CS YOU.
WAS WANTING TO GET INTO DR ED
EDUCATION.
AND YOU SEE INTO.
TEACHING TEACHERS LET'S PUT VERY
SIMPLY ORIGINALLY THE CSU SYSTEM
WAS CALLED TEACHERS COLLEGE.
WELL THAT WAS THAT CONFUSION.
I FELT IF WE LEFT TO GO IT WOULD
RAIN.
STRONG AND.
REALLY
HEART HURT HIGHER EDUCATION O
THE MASTER PLAN HAS BEEN A GOOD.
TAYLOR.
AND THE DIRECTION IN THE FUTURE
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS KEEP THE MASTER PLAN.
IN MY.
THE ASSEMBLY OF VERSION OFFERS A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION NOW.
THAT'S BASED ON WHAT THE
APPORTIONMENT THE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE IS THAT SIMPLY.
GIVEN THAT IT IS A POOR AMOUNT
OR IS BASED ON SOME CALCULATION.
IS THERE SOME FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT BASIS FOR THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE.
MILLION.
SO THE ASSEMBLY AMOUNT BUT I
THINK I'M TO THAT THE FIRST CALL
WOULD BE TO ENSURE THAT. SINCE
IT TO CREATE ANOTHER.
.
TO.
INSULATE THEM COLLEGES FROM
DECLINING ENROLMENT IF THERE'S
COMMITTEE DECLINING FUNDING OF
THE RESULT OF AN WHEN WE ARE TO
HAVE SOME OUT WHEN YOUR WHOLE
THOMAS BUT TO PROVIDE FIRST.
FURTHER IT'S LIKE THEM FROM
REDUCTION VAN WHATEVER WOULD BE
LEFT OVER WOULD BE UTILIZED TO
PROVIDE AN ACROSS THE BOARD.
PRESS T. INCREASE FOR
APPORTIONMENT SO I THINK THAT
THE THAT BASS INCREASE WOULD
DEPEND ON HOW SERVE WHATTHE
COST WOULD BE THAT FIRST
COMPLEMENT. THAT DAHLE
DISCRETIONARY REVENUE.
BUT DISCRETIONARY FUNDING FOR
COLLEGES YES OKAY BUT TO GET
YOUR POINT SENATOR THAT.
CLOSE TO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT THE ASSEMBLY HAS IN
THEIR VERSION AND WAS DERIVED
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE FROM
DENYING OUR FUNDING FORMULA
PROVISION TO HOLD DISTRICTS.
SO THEY REJECTED OUR PROPOSAL ON
UTILIZED IN A DIFFERENT MANNER.
ONTO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE MASTER
PLAN I THINK THAT IS. THE GOOD
POINTS TO PULL TOGETHER OUR
PROPOSALS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS WELL AS GOING
FORWARD ON THE AGENDA AND
TALKING ABOUT YOU SEE IN CSU.
A KEY COMPONENT OF THE STATE'S
MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
IS THE IDEA OF ACCESS.
AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
THE IDEA HIGHS AND SHOULD OF ALL
OF OVERTIME IN THE BEGINNING WE
TALKED ABOUT IT WITHIN THE.
CONTEXT OF THE MASTER PLAN IT
WAS REALLY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO WERE GETTING INTO COLLEGE
REPRESENTED THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE ECONOMICALLY.
ATHLETICALLY.
I THINK WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS THE
THEME THROUGH ALL OUR BUDGET IS
THAT ACCESS ALSO MEANS
GRADUATING. ACCESS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT ENROLLMENT IT ISN'T JUST
ABOUT ELIGIBILITY IT'S ABOUT
COMING OUT ON THE OTHER SIDE. ON
A WITH A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE
IN THE CASE OF THE CANYON
ECOLOGISTS. AND HAVING ACCESS TO.
HIGH WAGE JOB. ON THAT WILL
HELP YOU LIVE AND WHAT'S AND.
BECOMING INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
AND HOUSING MARKET AND OTHER
COSTS FOR CALIFORNIANS MRS COST
I TOTALLY AGREE.
WITH THAT.
AND INDEED THAT HAS BEEN THE
GOAL OF THE MASTER PLAN AND ONE
OF THE ELEMENTS HAS BEEN
MATRICULATION.
YOU COULDN'T MOVE THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS
MANY DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
IN OTHER QUESTIONS I I APOLOGIZE
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION GOING
BACK TO.
ISSUE SIX ON THE ONLINE PROGRAM.
I KNOW THERE ARE. A. FINANCE
PROPOSAL HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME.
AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEW ON MY
COLLEGE COULD YOU WALK US
THROUGH WHAT THAT IS
FOR.
SURE THERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME IN TWENTY MILLION ON
GOING THE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME IS TO SUPPORT THE START UP
COST OF THE COLLEGE THIS MEANS
PROCURING. AT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THE TECHNOLOGY AT ESTABLISHING
THE PROPHECIES AND ACCREDITATION
PROCESS FOR THE COLLEGE.
COULD YOU BE MORE SPECIFIC ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE YOU HIRING
WHEN YOU SAY PROCURING
TECHNOLOGY. YOU BUYING LIKE YOU
KNOW SERVERS COMPUTERS SAW ME
WHAT.
THAT DOESN'T THAT ONE OF THE
COSTS OF ACTUAL PLATFORM TO
DELIVER THE CONTENT.
ON.
LOCAL CAN YOU COLLEGES HAVE A
SOFTWARE PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE TO
THE ACTUALLY PROCURE ONE I'M TO
DELIVER THE ONLINE CONTENTS ONTO
STUDENTS.
I THINK I GUESS IT'S A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS US LOOKING FOR A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL THAN THAT BUT.
ABSOLUTELY AND I WE WE DID
PROVIDE A UP.
WE HAVE ABOUT WHAT SHE WOULD
BREAK BREAKDOWN AND WE PROVIDE
THAT YOUR STAFF THAT INCLUDES A
BREAKDOWN OF STAFF AND DEPICTS
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT. W. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU.
AND MEMBER PIE MADE THAT HUNDRED
MILLION IS ALSO EXPECTED TO BE
EXPENDED OVER A SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD THANKS SO IDENTIFICATION.
I. GOT IT SO IT'S NOT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
JUST GOT THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ARM.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO ISSUE EIGHT
UC AND CSU A MOMENT.
THERE WE HAVE.
MISTER CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM
THE LA OVER THE NEXT.
AND THEN MR FERGUSON.
THANK YOU JASON CONCENTRA CELILO.
THERE REALLY ARE FOUR ISSUES
BEFORE YOU IN THIS ITEM ALTMARK
TO REACH ISSUE I ONE OF THE TIME.
AND BUT IN ALL THESE ISSUES
RELATE TO ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT
CSU AND YOU SEEN.
THE FIRST ISSUE RELATES TO
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
I'M HERE THE HOUSES HAVE A LOT
OF SIMILARITIES
WITH REGARD TO CS YOU THERE
ACTUALLY IDENTICAL THEY PROVIDE
THE SAME VIDAK THE SAME LEVEL OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND PROVIDE
THE SAME LEVEL FUNDING.
FOR YOU SEE THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF SIMILARITIES WELL BOTH HOUSES
ALSO PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND PRO
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF TOTAL
SUPPORT. BUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE HOUSES IS THE MIX OF
FUNDS THAT GO TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT.
SPECIFICALLY BOTH HOUSES PROVIDE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
FOR TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS TO
GROW AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THAT
YOU SEE. BOTH HOUSES ALSO
PROVIDE SIX MILLION OF THAT BY
REDIRECTING.
FUNDS FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGET.
THAT LEAVES ANOTHER FOURTEEN
MILLION OF THAT FOURTEEN MILLION
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSES
REDIRECTING ANOTHER NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM CERTAIN PROGRAMS
THAT YOU SEE. AN PROVIDING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT THE SENATE PROVIDES
THE ENTIRE FOURTEEN MILLION IS
IN GENERAL FUND SUPPORTS THAT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES ON THIS FIRST ISSUE IS
REALLY THAT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
REDIRECTION.
RECOMMEND GOING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY ON THIS ISSUE. OF
THEY'VE RE DIRECTIONS AT THE
UNIVERSITY PROPOSED WERE PART OF
A WORKING GROUP THAT IT.
STEP IF PIPPIN UP FORMED IN THIS
AND THE FALL WITH A VERY ASIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
AND WE THINK YOU COULD USE THOSE
RE DIRECTIONS FIRST TO FIND IN
WYOMING GROWTH BEFORE PROVIDING
A GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
THE SECOND ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS A
MOMENT GROWTH AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY EXCUSE ME THIS IS JUST
FOR YOU SEE.
HERE THE HOUSES DO DIFFER QUITE
A BIT THEY PROVIDE THEY ADOPT
DIFFERENT GROWTH AND PROVIDE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTS
GROWTH OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF
TWENTY EIGHT A TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS AND PROVIDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE SENATE PROVIDES ADOPTS
GROWTH OF FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
SUPPORT.
THERE'S ALSO A DIFFERENT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE IN THE TYPES
OF STUDENTS THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
SUPPORTING. OF THE ASSEMBLY
DOESN'T SPECIFY THE NECKS OF
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS THE SENATE DOES SPECIFY
THAT THOSE FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
WOULD BE FOR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS ONLY.
ON THIS ISSUE WE RECOMMEND A BIT
OF A COMPROMISE A TAKING THE
SENATE LEVEL OF STUDENTS AT THE
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS BUT TAKING
THE ASSEMBLY APPROACH OF NOT OF
SPECIFYING THE MIX OF
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
EVERYTHING HERE AS FOLLOWS.
IT LOOKING OUT OVER FOR BEEN
PROJECTIONS OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES UP PERSONAL GRADUATES
ARE PROJECTED TO GROW VERY MUCH
IN FACT THEIR SPECTRA DECLINE IN
THAT YEAR VERY SLIGHTLY.
I'M BECAUSE OF THAT WE THINK
THAT.
SOME LOWER GROWTH JUST AS IT IS
JUSTIFIED.
NO THAT'S SAID ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SCHABAS AND.
SEVERAL OTHER VIEW HAVE HAVE
POINTED OUT THAT THERE'S THIS
MASTER PLAN AND PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN.
IS EXHORT OF CONSIDERS A MOMENT
ALL THREE SEGMENTS AND RELIES
VERY HEAVILY ON THE TRANSFER
FUNCTION AND HISTORICALLY
STUDENTS TO OF A DON'T DON'T
MAKE IT TO YOU SINCE YOUR ISSUE
AS FRESHMEN. SO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND WORK THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE TRANSFER PROCESS.
WE THINK THAT STILL THERE STILL
RATIONALE THERE ON. COSTS ARE
STILL A LOWER AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SO PROVIDE STUDENTS
THE OPPORTUNITY TRANSFER TO UC
AND CSU.
AND FURTHERMORE IN RECENT YEARS
AND MOMENT COMMUTER COLLEGES AS
BELOW SORT OF ITS PEAK YEARS SO
WE THINK THERE'S SOME.
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO OBSERVE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
BUT THAT'S A THAT IS A KEY
CONSIDERATION FOR U. S.
REFACTORING YOUR HOME DECISIONS
HOW THAT WILL IMPACT TO TAKE IT
ROAMING ACROSS ALL THREE
SEGMENTS. AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO CONTINUE
TO RELY HEAVILY ON THE TRANSFER
FUNCTION OR TO PROVIDE MORE. ARE
SLOTS FOR FRESHMAN STUDENTS.
OUR THINKING IT ON A NOT
SPECIFYING THE MIX OF
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE STUDENTS
IS JUST THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE
THE UNIVERSITY SOME FLEXIBILITY
TADMOR GRADUATE STUDENTS. AND.
SUPPORT MORE AYE TEACHING
ASSISTANTS TO SUPPORT THE
UNDERGRADUATE.
INSTRUCTION OF THE OF THE GROSS.
THE THIRD ISSUE IS FUNDING FOR
OVER BUDGET ENROLLMENT THIS IS
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY TO ADD A
ADDRESS.
.
AND WOMAN LEVELS THAT HAVE
EXCEEDED A FUNDED TARGETS IN THE
STATE BUDGET IN RECENT YEARS
SPOT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
AND THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES TWENTY
FIVE.
I'M SORRY THE CENTER PROVIDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THAT
PURPOSE THE SIMPLY PROVIDES HALF
THAT AMOUNT TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION.
WE RECOMMEND THE ASSEMBLY AMOUNT
ON THIS CASE A TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION OUR OUR THINKING IS THAT.
ALL THAT THE LEGISLATURE HOUSES
HAVE IN ADDITION TO THIS FUNDING
ADOPTED NOTABLY LARGER BASED
INCREASES IN THE GOVERNOR AND
THE UNIVERSITY HAS ALSO.
IDENTIFIED OTHER SAVINGS I CAN
REDIRECT TOWARDS BUDGET AND IS
ADOPTING NON RESIDENT TUITION
INCREASES AND THESE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO COVER A VARIETY OF
COSTS.
AT THE UNIVERSITY INCLUDING
COMPENSATION CRITICISM ROMAN
GROWTH FOR THE UNIVERSITY ALSO
HAS PLANS TO USE SOME OF THIS
FUNDING AS WELL TO REDUCE
STUDENT THE STUDENT FACULTY
RATIO. WHICH WE UNDERSTAND TO BE
A KICK REASON FOR THIS. ISSUE AS
WELL SO WE THINK GIVEN ALL THOSE
NOTABLE AUGMENTATIONS WHO EITHER
THE LOWER AMOUNT IS JUSTIFIED IN
THIS CASE.
AND FINALLY ON NON RESIDENT ROLE
MEANT THE SENATE ADOPTS A PLAYER
ADOPT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE.
TO DIRECT YOU SEE TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO REDUCE. A NONRESIDENT
ROMAN OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AS PART OF THE PLAN THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE TO
IDENTIFY FUND SOURCES TO COVER
THE. A FOREGONE REVENUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT DECLINE
ENROLLMENT.
THE COLONEL YOU SEE DOES HAVE A
POLICY THAT LIMITS NON RESIDENT
ROLL MEANT. A FOR A SEVERAL
CAMPUSES WERE NON RESIDENT
MOMENTS NOTABLY HYATT KINDA
LOCKS THE PROPORTIONS IN IN
PLACE AND FOR SOME OF THE OTHER
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE MUCH LOWER
LEVELS OF NON RESIDENT MOMENT.
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO INCREASE THEIR PROPORTIONS.
BUT THE SENATE A ROCK REPORT
WOULD WOULD REQUIRE YOU TO DO IS
DEVELOP A PLAN THAT ACTUALLY
REQUIRES REDUCTIONS IN NON
RESIDENT WOMAN FROM MOST OF
THOSE CAMPUSES.
SO THE KEY ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE SATISFIED
WITH THE CURRENT POLICY OR WOULD
LIKE TO SEE FURTHER REDUCTIONS
AND NON RESIDENT MOMENT. DO YOU
THINK YOU'D LIKE TO ADOPT THE
ESSENCE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT A WE
HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS ON ON. ON
AND ADDING TO THE LANGUAGE TO
GET SOME MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT MIGHT HELP IMPROVE THE
CONVERSATION. SURROUNDING
WHETHER OR NOT TO THE EXTENT TO
WHICH IS A NON RESIDENTS ARE
TAKING UPS SEATS AWAY FROM
RESIDENT STUDENTS WE WE SHARE
THOSE.
BOB SUGGESTIONS WITH STAFF AND
WE WRITE WE UNDERSTAND THEY'RE
STILL REVIEWING THAT SO.
THAT'S ARE A RECOMMENDATION
THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS COST.
THANK YOU THIS PACKAGE OBVIOUSLY
WE GET INTO TRUE GENERAL FUND SO
A LOT OF THESE DECISIONS WILL BE
PREDICATED ON WHAT I REVENUES
ARE ADOPTED AND WHAT GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS ARE
ADOPTED AS PART OF THE FINAL
BUDGET. WE WOULD KNOW.
THAT BOTH HOUSES DID INCREASE I
BASE FUNDING FOR BUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OBVIOUSLY THAT DOES CREATE
ONGOING COST PRESSURES WITHIN
THE GENERAL FUNDS.
SECONDARILY WE WOULD KNOW.
THAT AS WE MENTIONED AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER VIEW ACCESS
NOT ONLY. ENROLLMENT BY ACTUALLY
GETTING OUT IN A TIMELY MANNER.
OF BOTH YOU SEE IN CS YOU AS
SUCH WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT ON.
ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM UP REMAIN
FOCUS ON MEETING THE GOALS OF
THEIR GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
REDUCING THE INITIATIVES.
REACHING THE INITIATIVE SCHOOLS
WILL HELP IMPROVE AS STUDENTS
COMPLETING IN FOUR YEARS AND
ADDITIONALLY WILL PROVIDE MORE
VELOCITY IN THE THROUGH PUT. A
WHICH WILL ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR
SOME ENROLLMENT GROWTH WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
WITHOUT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
SO TOMORROW.
IF YOU MISSED YOUR.
.
AGAIN IT JUST JUST ON PAGE FORTY
FOUR IT'S DIFFICULT TO TIE INTO
PAGES TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY FIVE
SO.
MAYBE.
AS REAP MOVE ALONG WITH HIM.
WORK ON THAT BUT ON ON.
ON PAGE.
.
TWENTY FOUR IF THERE IS A
RECOMMENDATION TO LINK.
THE UC RETIREMENT PLAN FUNDING
TO.
A BUDGET CONDITION BY THE
ASSEMBLY AND.
I I. WOULD SWEAR DISCUSS THAT A
LITTLE BIT MISTER CHAIR WAS EVEN
MENTIONED TODAY.
.
AND ONE OF MY EMAIL.
THAT I BUT I GET FROM MY CAL
MATTERS FROM A DAMN MARINE BUT.
AT THIS IS WORK ON.
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE UC
SYSTEM.
AND.
HAVE A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PLAN WAS ADOPTED AND IT'S BEEN
PART OF THEIR. A REGULAR
NEGOTIATIONS.
MEET AND CONFER IT CETERA.
SOME WILL CONCERNED BY TRYING TO.
MODIFY THIS.
THROUGH A BUDGET.
ACT.
WE KNOW THAT.
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS ARE.
PORTABLE IT HELPFUL WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT OF.
MOVEMENT AND EMPLOYMENT SO THAT
FEATURES REALLY HELPFUL. HOW WE
DO KNOW FROM HISTORY NOW THAT
DEFINED BENEFIT PLANS ARE
UNSUSTAINABLE?
IT WE JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT OUR
OLD SCHOOL DISTRICT SCISSOR.
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME MEETING
THESE INCREASED.
PENSION PLAN CONTRIBUTIONS.
RIGHT NOW.
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT OF UC
EMPLOYEES I BELIEVE ARE
UTILIZING THAT DC OPPORTUNITY I.
I THINK THAT'S THE FUTURE WE
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPY STRINGING.
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF EDUCATION.
BY FORCING MORE EXPENSIVE
SOLUTIONS
AND OPPORTUNITIES ON THEM I
THINK THAT SKINNER ONLY BACKFIRE
ON US. AND WILL COME BACK TO
HAUNT THIS.
STATE BECAUSE ARE GONNA COME
BACK AND SAY OKAY YOU'VE YOU
MADE US DO THIS NOW YOU PAY FOR
IT BECAUSE.
WE MADE OUR MANAGEMENT DECISIONS
AND NOW YOU'RE YOU'RE CHANGING
THEM SO I SEE IT AS A. AS MAY BE
UP FISCAL TRAIN WRECK ON THE ON
THE HORIZON AND MAYBE EVEN AN
INSULT TO. GOVERNOR BROWN FOR
ALL OF THE HARD WORK THAT HE'S
READY INVESTED. IN FACT.
.
THE LAST TIME I WAS WITH THE
GOVERNOR AT AND AT A DINNER HE
HAD TWO MAJOR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FUTURE ONE BEING.
CLIMATE CHANGE THE OTHER BEING
THE PENSION PLAN.
CONCERNS IN THE UNFUNDED.
LIABILITIES SO I SEE THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS IS GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION AND. AND
MISTER CHAIR.
AND YOU KNOW AGAIN REVIEWING THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS OF THE. UC SYSTEM THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
KAFFIR HAS AN UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT. OF ELEVEN BILLION WE
JUST GOT THERE. JONES SEVENTEEN
KAFFIR RECENTLY IT'S NOW DOWN TO
A AT NINETEEN BILLION DEFICIT IN
ITS GROWING.
AND THE BUDGET.
SUMMARY OR EXECUTIVE REPORT EVEN
MENTIONED THAT.
THE UC SYSTEM HAS NINETEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNFUNDED
RETIREE MEDICAL THAT HAS NOT
REPORTED.
AS OF YET ON THE BALLOT SHEET
THAT WILL BE COMING ON THIS NEXT
MONTH.
SO WHEN WE GET THE JUNE.
THIRTY EIGHT TEAM KAFFIR FROM
THE UC SYSTEM MIDDLE BE UPSIDE
DOWN THIRTY EIGHT. BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO I I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE CAN BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT WE DO THE UC SYSTEM WE HAD
A BILL LAST YEAR. FORCING THEM
TO HIRE CERTAIN.
OUTSIDE VENDORS BUT AT THE SAME
RATES THAT WE WOULD CHARGE IT IF
THE IF YOU HAD.
THE EMPLOYEES YOURSELVES WITH
THAT'S NOT HELPING MANAGEMENT AT
ALL SO I I THINK WE JUST NEED TO
BE A LITTLE CAREFUL. ABOUT HOW
WE TREAT.
THIS SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO US START
DEMANDING A LOT OF MONEY.
AND.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO
SHARE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU.
SO OUR MATERIALS
DON'T.
THE LA TWO MATERIALS IN THE.
.
THEIR OVERVIEW.
DR FIFTH DIFFERENCE FIRST THAT
THE ASSEMBLY RETIREMENT PLAN
FUNDING.
DO YOU SEE.
BUT THE TIME.
.
MATERIALS ON. THE ISSUE EIGHT IN
OUR BINDER DON'T REFERENCE IT.
SO THE MIGHT UNDERSTAND THAT THE
SENATE DID NOT TAKE ACTION.
ON THE.
.
BUT IT.
ANY FUNDING TOWARDS THEIR
RETIREMENT.
SO WE DIDN'T OKAY.
.
YOU KNOW I GUESS THAT I SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THEN THAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS NOT. HEARD THE
ADMINISTRATION RATHER WAS NOT.
RECOMMENDING ANY.
PROP TWO FUNDING AROUND
UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITY.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL ON THAT
I THAT WE HAVE A WILL SEE IN THE
PAST UTILIZED PROP TWO FUNDING
OF FOR YOU SEE RETIREMENT. AT
ALSO KNOWN THIS IS KIND OF
TECHNICAL ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S
UTILIZING PROP TWO FUNDS IT'LL
REALLY BE A CONFORMING ACTION
DRIVEN OFF OF THE FINAL BUDGET
PACKAGE IN THE REVENUES. THIS IS
ON THE DEBT SIDE OF PROP TWO AND
THERE WILL BE A TOTAL DERIVED
FROM THAT THE REVENUE PACKAGE
THAT'S ADOPTED.
SO THERE THERE COULD BE SOME
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THE PURPOSE.
THAT WOULD JUST DEPEND ON WHAT
THAT FINAL PACKAGE LOOKS LIKE I
THINK YOU KNOW IT AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IN OUR
PROPOSAL WE DID NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THAT SO BUT
CERTAINLY IT WOULD BE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE PLAN THAT
WE PUT FORWARD.
WELL.
.
I THE.
MY MAIN CONCERN IS.
I THINK IT'S WORTH IT FOR US TO
DISCUSS WHETHER WE SHOULD DIRECT
SOME PROP TWO FUNDING TOWARDS
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY BUT WHAT
I.
WOULD I AM ESPECIALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IS UC'S PROPOSAL. TO HAVE
SOME.
TO EITHER HAVE A AND NEW POLICY
YOUR NEW STAFF BEING ABLE TO.
OPT OUT IN BE IN A FOR A WIND
CAVE VERSUS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
DEFINED SYSTEM PENSION. AND THE
REASON I RAISE THAT IS BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW.
ALL OF OUR PENSION SYSTEMS.
OUR BASED ON. THE.
IT.
THE FUNDS THAT ARE COMING IN.
THAT ARE GONNA THEN PROVIDE OUT
LONG TERM SECURITY AND AS SOON
AS WE CREATE A PATHWAY FOR.
EMPLOYEES NOT TO CONTRIBUTE.
TOWARDS THAT DEFINED BENEFIT
SYSTEM. THEN WE CREATE FURTHER
INSTABILITY IN THE SYSTEM.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WANT TO DO SO.
THEN I AM NOT SURE WHY I MEAN I
CAN IMAGINE YOU SEE WANTS TO
LESSEN THEIR. PENSION
LIABILITIES BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT
COULD INCREASE IT.
BECAUSE YOU WOULD HAVE FOLKS
THAT ARE NOT FINDING INTO THE
SYSTEM.
SO I DO HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
THAT.
THANK YOU.
WE QUICKLY.
SEN CENTER MITCHELL THE THIRD A
MORE.
OKAY I WOULD JUST TO MAKE A
CORRECTION BECAUSE A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN IS ONE WHERE
YOU MAKE.
YUR ANNUAL OR MONTHLY OR
HOWEVER OFTEN YOU'RE PAID TO
MAKE A CONTRIBUTION.
AND THE RESULTS DEPEND ON THE.
TOTAL CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
INVEST RETURNS AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU CAN PULL OUT. OUT WITH A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION HIRSCH YOUR
YOUR YOUR EMPLOYER YOURSELF FOR
FUNDING FOR SPECIFIC.
BENEFIT IN THE FUTURE.
AND IN IN ITS STILL EARMARKED TO
YOUR ACTIVITIES SO WHETHER YOU
PARTICIPATE IN A DB ARE DEFINED
BENEFIT OR DEFINED CONTRIBUTION.
HAS NO BEARING ON THE OVERALL
FUNDING AT THE DEFINED BENEFIT
PLAN. OTHERWISE WE CALL IT A
PONZI SCHEME THAT WERE THE CASE
SO.
I WOULD JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR COMPREHENSION SIR
MITCHELL.
THAT'S WHY
TAKE SENATOR MORE LUCK WITH ME
PLACE.
FINDING.
I GUESS THE QUESTION.
.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION I HAVE TO
ADMIT MY BAD I.
THOUGHT THAT THE EIGHT POINT SIX
WASN'T ASSEMBLY.
POLICY I DID REALIZE THAT WAS
IN THE MAY REVISE
SO THE EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION
FROM GENERAL FUND FROM THE YOU
SEE AFTER THE PRESIDENT THAT'S
BEEN REDIRECTED. CAN YOU GIVE ME
A SENSE OF WHAT.
.
HISTORICALLY A.
THE OPPOSITE THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES REMINDER THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT OTHERWISE BE DOING WITH
THAT EIGHT POINT SIX THAT WILL
NOW NOT HAPPEN?
NOT THAT I RECALL THERE WERE
SOME.
.
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS AND SERVICES
THAT WERE PROVIDED.
THROUGH HER OFFICE THAT THAT.
MIGHT NOW BE COMPROMISED IF YOU
TO REMIND ME WHAT THEY ARE TO
PROCEED CERTAINLY OF THE THE
ROUGHLY EIGHT POINT SIX. ROUGHLY
SIX MILLION OF THAT WAS FROM
THERE JUST GENERAL OPERATING
BUDGET.
ANOTHER CHU AND A HALF MILLION
I BELIEVE AND I DON'T RECALL
THAT THE FOUR INITIATIVE VOTE
SUPPORTED FOR PRESIDENTIAL
INITIATIVES.
THAT IS WHAT THE REMAINING TWO
AND A HALF MILLION WAS COVERING.
BEYOND THAT THERE WERE SOME
CAMPUS LEVEL FUNDS THAT WERE
ALREADY AT CAMPUSES SUPPORTING.
INITIATIVES AS WELL ARM AS WELL
AS SOME LOTTERY FUNDING IN TOTAL
WHICH IT COMES UP TO FIFTEEN
MILLION BUT SPECIFICALLY. THE
EIGHT POINT SIX WAS INCLUDED AS
A TECHNICAL SHIP FROM U. COPD TO
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT ACT SINCE I I
GET WHAT THE SHIFTY AND MY
CONCERN IS WHAT WILL NOW.
NOW NO LONGER BE FUNDED IN THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AS A
RESULT OF THAT SHIFTED SO YOU
TALK ABOUT SOME INITIATIVES ARE
THERE ANY WHAT I'M JUST PROVIDE
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT ON HOW
MUCH OF THIS WAS A PROVISION IN
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET ACT THAT.
A SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT IN WHICH
I WE WERE DIRECTED IN CONCERT
WITH A ANALYST'S OFFICE I
BELIEVE THEY PARTICIPATED IN
OTHERS. COME TO LOOK AT THE.
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BUDGET AND TO IDENTIFY AREAS
THAT COULD BE UTILIZED TO FUND
ENROLLMENT GROWTH SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS AN OUTGROWTH OF THAT
WORK.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND SOME STILL
MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT WORK FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT WILL NOW NOT HAPPEN?
THANK YOU LIKE I COULD TAKE A
STEP THE PUBLIC IS SOMETHING I.
AS AND FOLLOW UP TO THE AUDIT.
THAT HAD BEEN TAMPERED WITH THE
BOARD OF REGENTS ACTUALLY HIRED
LE FORMER STATE AUDITOR. AUDITOR
SHOW BURKE AND.
HE IDENTIFIED I BELIEVE.
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS IN. USE
YOUR P. THAT ARM HE THOUGHT
COULD COULD BE LOOKED AT.
SO THAT THOSE WERE THINGS THAT
WE WE SUPPORTED THE BOARD OF
REGENTS TO TAKE A LOOK AT. I
BELIEVE THE. THE BOARD IN THEIR
LAST TO ME MEETING ARTICULATED
ON.
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT COST SAVINGS
TO HELP
COVER.
ENROLLMENT SO THEY DIDN'T
NECESSARILY WANT IDENTIFIED
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT PER SE BUT
THE IDENTIFIED OTHER AREAS LIKE
I DON'T HAVE ALL THOSE DETAILS
BUT. BUT AGAIN.
THE AUDITOR THAT THE BOARD OF
REGENTS THEMSELVES HIRED HAD
IDENTIFIED ABOUT PROJECTS
POSSIBLY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF COST SAVINGS SPECIFIC
OUR PROGRAMS.
OKAY SO YOU KNOW YOU THINK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT IT IN YOU KNOW
COST SAVINGS.
YOU TAKE THEM SOMEPLACE SO YES
CERTAINLY SO THERE THERE ARE
FIVE INITIATIVES THAT WOULD BE
REDIRECTED THOSE FIVE OR THE
AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENTAL
STATIONS. THE NEAREST
PSYCHIATRIC INSTITUTES.
FUNDING FROM SCRIPTS FUNDING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH TEACHING
SUPPORT AND FROM THE MIND
INSTITUTE.
AND THE TOTALS.
GENERALLY VERY BETWEEN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENTATION
STEP OUT STATIONS DOWN TO AS
LITTLE AS A HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
THE MIND INSTITUTE.
INTERESTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR MARK.
THANK YOU RICHARD JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION OUT ON PEAKS
TWENTY FIVE.
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL.
DID HAS DECIDED TO ELIMINATE
THE PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS.
AND.
.
IF THE STATE WITH THE GOVERNOR
ON ON NO FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
WITH ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE A
GROWING HOMELESS AND MENTALLY
ILL.
POPULATION AND.
WE'RE ONLY PRODUCING AN ORANGE
COUNTY MAYBE NINE PSYCHIATRISTS
A YEAR.
IN AND AND I'M JUST WONDERING.
WHY THE ASSEMBLY DECIDED TO
ELIMINATE?
THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM OF FIFTY
FIVE MILLION.
I DEFERRED TO THE ASSEMBLY ON
THAT QUESTION SENATOR YES I KNOW.
I'M SORRY SENATOR FIVE BUT I
THOUGHT AS WELL AS A QUESTION I
WANT MY FIFTY FIVE MILLION WHEN
YOU GONNA GIVE IT TO ME. ALL.
WOULD YOU LIKE IT'S A CASH OR
CHARGE.
IF THAT SENATOR MITCHELL HAS.
SENATE IN SENATE BILL EIGHT
FORTY.
I'M SORRY MISTER CURA FIFTY FIVE
MILLION IN THE IN IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS A BALLOT
FOR PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS ON PAGE. TWENTY FIVE
BUT IN THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL IT
TOTALLY ELIMINATES IT AND I.
WOULD JUST HAVE A GROWING
POPULATION WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
OR THIS IS BECOMING MORE
IDENTIFIED IN AND I JUST WAS
CURIOUS. WHY THE ASSEMBLY? I
DECIDED TO TAKE THAT MONEY OR
WAS IT DIVERTED TO.
THE FUN THIS INCENTIVE TO FOR
THE THE UC RETIREMENT PLANNER.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS IT SAID THAT I AM TO THE
AND THE HEALTH AGENDA HAPPY TO.
DISCUSS IT THERE BIRD AS WITH
ANY BUDGETARY AREA I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE HAD WE DO HAVE THREE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE FAIRLY CLOSE
TO EACH OTHER. BUT THEY DO HAVE
SOME MINOR DIFFERENCES AND THAT
WAS JUST ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES
THRUST.
I GUESS I'LL WAIT THEN FURTHER
HEALTH AGENDA TO GET IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
CENTER SKINNER.
BOB.
THANK YOU.
NOW I WANTED TO JUST GET A
LITTLE MORE INTO THE.
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN OUR TWO
ACTIONS ARE HOUSES TO ACTIONS
REGARDING BOTH OVER IN ROMANCE.
AND.
.
THERE ARE BASE THEY SLOW
FINDINGS THE SAME.
.
ID LIKE THE SENATE'S.
STRUCTURED IT TRIED. TO MOVE.
YOU SEE AN TO INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF IN STATE STUDENTS AND
I LIKE THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED
BECAUSE IT GIVES TIME SO THAT.
WE CAN INTERACT AS TO WHAT THE.
GREEN PARTLY YOU HAS INCREASED
ITS RELIANCE ON THE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY PAY A
HIGHER. FEE AND AS STATE FUNDING
WAS CUT BACK.
IT WAS.
PARTIALLY A MAKEUP OF THE CUT
BACK IN STATE FUNDING. WE ARE
DOING BETTER IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE PROVIDING BUT I LIKE THE
APPROACH OF THE SENATE'S BECAUSE
IT. GIVES THE ABILITY.
OVER TIME TO FIGURE OUT VERY.
HOW WE BOTH SHARE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF?
IN STATE STUDENTS.
BUT I AM CURIOUS ABOUT. OUR.
WE'RE PROVIDING THE SENATE
ACTION IS PROVIDING.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
TO DEAL WITH THE OVER ENROLLMENT
RIGHT NOW.
AND THE ASSEMBLY WENT TO HAVE
LESS THAN THAT.
BUT THEN THE ASSEMBLY WENT FOUR.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR NEXT
YEAR. WHICH MIGHT BE OVER
ENROLLMENT AND WE WENT.
FOR WHAT IT SIMPLY SAID TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ARE NOT QUITE SURE
HOW AT THESE THINGS UP. I'M NOT
CRITICIZING ASSEMBLY LOOK ONLY
BUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
STUDENTS AND THEN SENATE ACTION
IS FIVE MILLION FOR FIVE HUNDRED.
MORE STUDENTS WHICH.
ISN'T A.
RIGHT NOW I GET IT THEY JUST DID
IT ON OKAY BUT ANYWAY SO WERE
WERE SUPPORTING FEWER IN THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD RECOMMEND MORE
BUT WE'RE GIVING MORE.
IN IN THIS YEAR SO.
SOMEBODY JUST
SCRIBE WHAT THE NOT THE
DIFFERENCE THAT'S OBVIOUS BUT
WHAT THE.
MOTIVATION OF THE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES.
WHAT IF I COULD TALK ABOUT THE
MOTIVATION OF OUR OF OUR
APPROACH AND AND WE?
?
WERE ABLE TO.
.
TALK TO YOU SEE AND.
THEY WERE HAPPY TO SUPPORT OUR
PUT NOTHING THAT THEY WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR APPROACH BUT
THEY. WERE OKAY WITH OUR
APPROACH.
.
BAY.
OR ABLE TO WE HAVE TO COME TO
AGREEMENT REGARDING THE TWELVE
AND A HALF. MILLION FOR THE OLD
FIRM ROLE MEANT IN THIS CURRENT
YEAR WHERE WE WOULD PAY HAD TOLD
AND HALF MILLION IT AND THEY
WOULD COME UP WITH THE TOP HALF
MILLION THROUGH. THROUGH THEIR
UNIVERSITY EFFICIENCIES.
SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OUR ACTION OF TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS THE NEED.
BUT THE ASSEMBLY.
I TOOK THE PRAYER THEY PREFERRED
TO GO WITH.
THEY WOULD OFFER TWELVE POINT
FIVE IF YOU SEE WOULD HAVE
BECOME OF THE OTHER CRACK WE WE
AND YOURS YEARS PAST THAT HAS
BEEN AN APPROACH THAT WE'VE
ADOPTED IN BUDGET WHERE.
WE'VE SPLIT THE DIFFERENCE AND
THEN WE ENDED UP PAYING FOR FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS UNDER
OBVIOUSLY.
OUR APPROACH WAS DIFFERENT GOING
INTO OUT YEARS.
WHERE IT WAS WHERE WE BOTH?
BOTH HOUSES.
USE THE TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT NUMBER WHICH IS
HOW DO YOU GET THE FIVE MILLION
FOR FIVE HUNDRED AND THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
OKAY.
BUT THEN.
.
SENATE OPTED TO GO WITH LESS.
STUDENTS
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BURNED
NINETEEN TWENTY.
.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
CLOSING THIS TODAY. BUT.
THERE MIGHT BE.
SOME KIND OF MIDDLE GROUND HERE
WHERE.
.
IF.
IF IN FACT YOU SEE CAN COVER.
PORTION OF THE OVER ENROLLMENT
FROM THIS YEAR.
THEN.
AND I KNOW AND. THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL LOOK AT THIS
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
THAT THEY WERE OFFERING UP ANY
OF THIS GENERAL FUND TO BUT AT
LEAST FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW. WE
WOULD GET CLOSER TO THE SAME
TYPE OF GENERAL FUND IF WE.
IF WE WENT WITH THE ASSEMBLY
SURPRISED JOHN THE CURRENT YEAR
OVER ENROLLMENT AND.
THEN THE ASSEMBLY SUPERCHUNK THE
FOLLOWING YEAR IT GETS IT CLOSER
TO THE SAME. ALEXANDER MITCHELL
HI I WAS JUST GONNA PROVIDE
CLEAR IN TERMS OF THE SENATE IT
WILL YOU KNOW YOU YOU SEE ASK
FOR THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND YET ONLY LONG. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THEY SEE
THEIR NEED RIGHT RIGHT.
RIGHT
EXACTLY
SO THAT IT WILL IT WILL DISTANCE
AT THIS POINT MY PERSPECTIVE OF
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF.
.
A AFFORDABILITY IN WHETHER IT'S
REASONABLE TO EXPECT.
THAT THEY COME UP WITH THE
TWELVE POINT FIVE IN. AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAYS EFFICIENCY.
WELL I THINK I'VE MENTIONED WE
WE HAD TO
BEFORE IT CLOSED WE HAD HAD DONE.
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU SEE IN
THERE THEY HAD AGREED TO IT SO
IT WASN'T IT WASN'T DONE.
FORM KNOW SOMEONE SAY THAT. BUT
I BUT I WOULD SAY AGAIN I THINK
OUR OUR LEGISLATIVE. MAKING YOU
KNOW JUST JUST AND YOU JUST FOR
FOR CLARITY TECH YOU LIKE WERE
SOMEWHAT SPLITTING HAIRS APPEAR
ON THE DIET. I MEAN THE SENATE
PROPOSAL IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL ARE VERY CLOSE NOW
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE AND WE HAVE YOU
KNOW. FAIRLY FAR PARTRELATIVE
TO THIS PROPOSAL NOT IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET OVERALL BUDGET BUT.
NO TO THIS PUZZLE BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION SO WE WE. WE HAD
IS IS THAT ARE ACTUALLY. ALMOST
IDENTICAL IN TERMS OF THEIR
PROPOSAL.
WHAT TIME?
TO CLARIFY. I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE OVER ENROLLMENT
COSTS ARE COVERED.
HOWEVER WE DO IT AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO HAVE MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS NEXT YEAR.
SO I WAS. IN.
.
BECAUSE WHAT I HEAR MOST FROM
FOLKS UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
IS THE FEELING THAT
IN I DO NOT BLAME YOU SEE FOR
THIS.
BUT THAT WITH OUR MASTER PLAN
WE HAVE A PROMISE THAT STUDENTS
WHO ACHIEVED A CERTAIN LEVEL.
WOULD BE GUARANTEED SLOT IN OUR.
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE'VE GROWN
GREATLY IN POPULATION AND WE
DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE WE CAN'T
DO THAT WE'VE ONLY ADDED ONE
CAMPUS.
AND THAT CERTAINLY.
MOST OF OUR UC CAMPUSES HAVE
REALLY TRIED RESPONDED INCREASE
THEIR ENROLLMENT.
THE SAME TIME UNFORTUNATELY THEY
INCREASE THEIR AT A STATE WHERE
ONLY. AND WE IT LEAST MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A LEGISLATORS I
WANT FUNDS ARE YOU SYSTEM BETTER
SO THAT WORK CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
CAN ATTEND AND I WANT WORK
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TEND NOW.
THANK YOU SENATOR SOUL SOLD TO
THE. SENATOR FROM BERKELEY
EFFECT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOD.
HAVE FUN JUST QUICK POINT TO
MAKE ON.
OF FUNDING FOR GRADUATE MAJOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION THERE'S NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE SENATE
VERSION AND I DON'T THINK A. OF
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION HAS
ANYTHING AND.
IN IT.
.
I THINK THIS IS FUNDING THAT'S
IMPORTANT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BUT TO A PARTICULARLY IN MY
DISTRICT TO WHERE WE HAVE.
A NUMBER OF TEACHING HOSPITALS
INCLUDING CEDARS IN MY DISTRICT
DATA OF THIS MONEY WOULD GO
ALONG WAY TO HELP.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
SO WE ARE ADJOURNING.
BUDGET CONFERENCE TODAY.
WE.
ALL. THIS JUST.
WE'LL BE HERE ARE WE WILL BE
RECONVENING MONDAY.
WE WILL BE ANNOUNCING THE TIME.
BUT WILL BE RECONVENING MONDAY.
I DON'T.
ALRIGHT AND WITHOUT WE OUR
JOURNEY THANK YOU